CAN YOU HEAR US OVER HERE AND
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. I'M GONNA
CALL THE SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW SUB COMMITTEE ONE ON
EDUCATION TOOK ORDER- AND LET ME
GO THROUGH A FEW OF OUR
PROCEDURES FOR THE COMMITTEE
HEARING TODAY. IN RESPONSE TO
THE CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS ENDED HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THESE ORDERS TO SENATORS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL MEMBERS WOULD BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY BUT TODAY
I'M JOINED BY SENATORS MEN AND A
CHOI BOGUE SO ALL OF THE
SENATORS ON THE SUB COMMITTEE OR
PRESENT IN THE HEARING ROOM.
THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR A
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I S. IT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE. PLEASE
SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL
PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU'RE
DONE. ONE RECOGNIZE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
- IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL THESE BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN I SEE
IT. ARE THERE NOW. AND R. ONE
OUNCE IT- THE PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. 877-226-8163. EIGHT SEVN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX
THREE. AND THE ACCESS CODEIS.
736-283-3736 TWO EIGHT THREE
THREE. FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
MARKS PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
AND OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR
TWO DOT ONE THING ZERO PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LONG NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LONG
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE ON
MUTED AND IF YOU WILL THEN BE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.%
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING HER
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
WHEN WE GET TO PUBLIC COMMENT
AND WE WON'T HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT
AFTER WE COMPLETE THE DISCUSSION
OF ALL ITEMS ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
I'M GOING TO ASK THE MODERATOR
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE IN LINE. AND
DECIDE HOW MUCH TIME TO ALLOCATE
ACCORDINGLY. ARE WE HOPE TO BE
DONE BY A QUARTER OF NOON GIVEN
OUR COMMITMENTS. ARE FOR OTHER.
EVENTS IN THE ROOM ALL MAINTAIN
THE DECORUM DURING THE HEARING
AS IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTE. ABOUT TODAY'S
HEARING IS THE SECOND OF TEN
HEARINGS OVER FIVE WEEKS OF THE
EDUCATION BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
THE FIRST WAS YESTERDAY ON
STUDENT AID AND- CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. IN
TODAY'S HEARING WE WILL REVIEW
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FUNDING
. AND THE LEVEL OF THE FUNDING
AND EXPENDITURE STRUCTURE AS
WELL AS SEVERAL PROPOSALS WITHIN
THE STRUCTURE WE WILL ALSO
DISCUSS INDEPENDENT STUDY
PROGRAMS AND THE PROPOSAL TO
PROTECT SCHOOLS FROM DECLINE IN
ROMAN. BUT OUR FIRST ITEM WILL
BE TO HEAR. OF ABOUT THE STATE
OF EDUCATION FROM THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND BEFORE
I GO TO HIM LET ME ASK SENATORS
MINIATURE OR BOTH IF YOU HAVE
ANY OPENING COMMENTS. US SENATOR
MEANT- THANK YOU CHIRLA AND- I
WANT TO THANK OUR WITNESSES-
WE'RE- AND YOU NEED TIMES AND I
THINK IN A LOT OF WAYS WERE
INCREDIBLY FORTUNATE BECAUSE OF
THE- AGAIN LARGE SURPLUS THAT
WE'RE FACING AND SO- WE HAVE. AN
ABUNDANCE OF FUNDS WHICH IS A
GOOD PROBLEM TO HAVE BUT WE'RE
ALSO FACING A LOT OF CHALLENGES
AS I KNOW SOME OF THE WITNESSES
ARE GOING TO DISCUSS TODAY- AND
SO I THINK WE'RE AT A CROSSROADS
WHERE THE DECISIONS WE MAKE
TODAY GOING FORWARD. WILL HAVE
HUGE OUTSIZED IMPACTS ON THE
FUTURE OF EDUCATION PUBLIC
EDUCATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS SO
CRITICAL TO GET THIS RIGHT
BECAUSE WE KNOW EDUCATION IS THE
FOUNDATION OF LONG TERM
PROSPERITY. FOR ME AS A FATHER
THREE KIDS WHO ARE IN FIFTH
GRADE THIRD GRADE IN
KINDERGARTEN RIGHT NOW IN A
PUBLIC SCHOOL IN IRVINE- THIS IS
VERY PERSONAL TO ME. AND I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE GOING FORWARD IS
THINKING THOUGHTFULLY PRUDENTLY
AND IN A LONG TERM FRAMEWORK
AROUND THE CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE
FACING UP TO WHAT DEGREE ARE THE
CHALLENGES THAT WORK RIGHT NOW
RICK SHORT TERM AND RELATED TO
COVET. TO WHAT DEGREE ARE THEY
LONG TERM CHALLENGES STRUCTURAL
CHALLENGES THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS AND ARE WE ALLOCATING
OUR SCARCE TAXPAYER DOLLARS
ACCORDINGLY AND SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING TESTIMONY
TODAY I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM MY FRIENDS THE
SUPERINTENDENT THURMOND- BUT BUT
I KNOW IT'S OUR JOB TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET THIS RIGHT GOING
FORWARD AND AGAIN I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE HOW IMPORTANT THAT IS.
THANK YOU CARE THANK YOU SENATOR
MEANT MY APPRECIATE- YOUR
COMMENTS OF SUPPORT THEM. THE
END OF TODAY IS AN OVERVIEW OF
K. THROUGH TWELVE AND OUR CHANCE
TO LOOK AT THE DIFFERENT PIECES
OF THE FUNDING FORMULA PROP
NINETY EIGHT AND HERE FROM THE
SUPERINTENDENT AND SOME OF THE
ISSUES LIKE INDEPENDENT STUDY
FROM LAST YEAR SO IT IS A GREAT
WAY TO LEAD INTO THE NEXT DAY
HEARINGS WHICH WILL DRILL DOWN.
ON SOME OF THE INDIVIDUAL THINGS
WITH NO FURTHER ADO WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO THE TOP BERMAN THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION FOR THE STATE OF
EDUCATION SUPERINTENDENT.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. I
WHERE AND I SENATOR. IN NATURE
BOTH- THANK YOU. IT YOU'RE COULD
FOCUS. ON MEETING THE NEEDS OF
OUR SIX SO- IT HAS BEEN QUITE
THE CHALLENGES YOU CAN IMAGINE
AND I WANT TO START AS I OFTEN
DO BIKE KNOWLEDGE BEING. OUR
EDUCATORS OF BOTH THAT YOU KNOW
TEACHERS AND CLASSIFIED STAFF.
FOR THEIR WORK CUT TO SUPPORT
THE LEARNING NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS. ADMINISTRATORS MANY OF
WHOM LITERALLY HAD TO STEP IN-
BECAUSE OF STAFFING SHORTAGES.
AND OF COURSE OUR FAMILIES- AS
WE ALL TRY TO. DEAL WITH THE
ONGOING IMPACTS OF THE CORONA
VIRUS PANDEMIC. THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR RESILIENCY. AND
CONTINUING TO MAKE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS CAN GET AN
EDUCATION AND THEY CAN BE SAFE.
IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT OUR
SCHOOLS HAVE HAD TO DO THIS.
AGAINST THE BACKDROP OF THE
PANDEMIC ITSELF. OF THE LOSSES
THE DESTRUCTION- THE LACK OF
AVAILABILITY OF COLD IT
MITIGATION RESOURCES. AND SEEING
SPIKES AT DIFFERENT TIMES AND-
THE CORONAVIRUS IT WILL BE- AT.
THE DELTA PEERING INTO OUR OWN
CRIMES. THESE HAVE BEEN
DIFFICULT THINGS OUR SCHOOLS
HAVE. TRIED TO DO ALL THIS AND
NAVIGATE THINGS LIKE.
INDEPENDENT STUDY AND CHASE. A
WAIVER AT A TIME WHEN- STUDENTS
AND STAFF WERE EITHER UNABLE TO
COME TO SCHOOL- THOSE CHALLENGES
HAVE MANIFESTED THEMSELVES IN
WAYS. THAT HAVE TO HAVE FELT
LIKE IMPOSSIBLE. CIRCUMSTANCES
TO OUR SCHOOL COMMUNITIES. A
BILL YET EVERYONE HAS PERSEVERED
OUR SCHOOLS ARE OPEN. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT STUDENTS DO
BETTER WHEN THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION- YOU KNOW
AS OF- JULY I PROBABLY VISITED
FORTY FIVE SCHOOLS MYSELF. TO
SUPPORT THEIR RE OPENING YEAH
AND I'M GRATEFUL TO EVERYONE WHO
HELPED OUR SCHOOLS GET THE
THINGS THAT THEY NEED. TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
OTHERS. PROVIDED ACCESS TO TAKE
HOME KOBE. TESTED ARE NOW
PROVIDING FACEMASKS AND OTHER
TYPES OF PEOPLE. TO ALL OF OUR
STAFF AT THE OF BAD. HELP OUR
SCHOOL NAPA. THE J. THIRTY A WAY
KIND. ANOTHER TYPES OF
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHEN SCHOOL
CAN BE OPEN- WHEN THEY MIGHT
HAVE TO CLOSE IN HOW WE SUPPORT
OUR SCHOOLS DURING THE PROCESS.
IN SPITE OF ALL OF THIS. IS
SENATOR MAN POINTED OUT WE FIND
OURSELVES AGAIN- WITH ROBUST
REVENUE SURPLUSES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THAT POINT TO THE
POSSIBILITY OF HAVING A GREAT
EDUCATION BUDGET. AND WILL NEED
THESE RESOURCES SO THAT WE CAN
HELP OUR STUDENTS HEAL FROM THE
TRAUMA OF THE PANDEMIC. WE COVER
ACADEMICALLY FROM LOST TIME IN
FROM- LEARNING GAPS THAT HAVE
BEEN EXACERBATED DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND THEN TO LOOK OUT
FOR TO THE FUTURE AND HOW OUR
STUDENTS THRIVE ACADEMICALLY AND
PREPARE. FOR SUCCESS IN THE
FUTURE BUT BEFORE WE DO THAT WE
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO KEEP EVERYONE
SAFE AND THAT MAKES SAFETY AT
OUR SCHOOLS. ARE NUMBER ONE JOB-
AS YOU LOOK THROUGH THIS BUDGET
YOU WILL SEE THAT THE
INVESTMENTS THAT IT MAKES FOR
PRE K. THROUGH TWELFTH GRADE.
ARE AGAIN ROBUST- YOU KNOW THIS
YEAR HI EIGHT POINT TWO MILLION
BILLION MORE THAN LAST YEAR- AND
THIS WOULD BE THE HIGHEST LEVEL
FUNDING FOR K. FOURTEEN SCHOOLS
EVER- YOU KNOW JUST AT THE END
OF YOUR HIGHLIGHTS. THE FOUR
MILLION AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT
VARIOUS EFFORTS AROUND-
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION OF
TEACHERS YOU ALL KNOW WE ARE
EXPERIENCING A MASSIVE STAFFING
SHORTAGE IN OUR SCHOOLS. ALL
SCHOOLS IN THE NATION AND ALL
WORK FOR SECTORS IN THE NATION
NOT JUST EDUCATION. ON JUST
YESTERDAY I CAN BEING TO A WORK
GROUP THAT IS FOCUSED ON JUST
ONE THING HI WE OFFSET THOSE
STAFF SHORTAGES AND IT BRINGS
TOGETHER ALL THE PART OF THE
EDUCATIONAL COMMUNITY. TO LOOK
AT HOW DO WE INCREASE
COMPENSATION HOW DO WE HOPE MORE
PART TIME STAFF BECOME FULL TIME
STAFF MORE TRAINING AND WE BUILD
A PATHWAY TO GET MORE TEACHERS
WILL BUS DRIVERS. PRINCIPLES AND
EVERYONE WHO SUPPORTS OUR SCHOOL
COMMUNITIES THERE ARE MANY
COMPONENTS IN THIS BUDGET TO
HELP CLOSE THE OPPORTUNITY GAP-
THREE POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
FOR EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES TO BE RECOGNIZED
THAT LEARNING HAPPENS DURING THE
SCHOOL DAY. AS WELL AS BEFORE
SCHOOL AND AFTER SCHOOL AND HOW
DO WE SUPPORT THOSE PROGRAMS
ANOTHER BILLION AND A HALF
DOLLARS FOR COLLEGE CAREER
PATHWAYS COLLEGE AND CAREER
PATHWAYS. TO SUPPORT- THE
PATHWAY. EDUCATION THAT HELP
STUDENTS GET A TO GREAT FUTURE-
A FIVE HUNDRED MILLION INVEST-
ONE TIME INVEST TO SUPPORT
LITERACY TO MAKE SURE THIS HAVE
RE COACHES SPECIALISTS AS YOU
KNOW IN SEPTEMBER I NAME DATE
AND IF IT'S SAFE TO ENSURE THAT
OUR CHILDREN LEARN TO READ BY
THIRD GRADE AND THAT WE'VE MADE
COMMITMENTS TO SUPPORT NEW
PROGRAMS THAT ADDRESS SCHOOL
READY MISS SET- ADDRESS THE
KINDS OF INTERVENTIONS OUR
STUDENTS NEED. RATIONAL
DEVELOPER THAT EDUCATORS NEED
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
MATERIALS THE BOOKS- WE PLEDGE
TO PROVIDE A MILLION BOOKS TO
FAMILIES- WHO NEED THEM IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ALREADY
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HELP WITH
SOME ONLINE- BOOK AVAILABILITY
WOULD ALLOW STUDENTS JUST IN THE
LAST TWO MONTHS TO DOWNLOAD
BOOKS FOR FREE DURING THAT TWO
MONTH PERIOD. MORE THAN TWO
MILLION BOOKS HAVE BEEN READ
ONLINE AND ALREADY A MILLION
BOOKS HAVE BEEN DOWNLOADED BY
THE WAY THESE STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO DOWNLOAD THESE BOOKS.
UNLIMITED NUMBER OF BOOKS FOR
FREE- AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
DISCUSS- THE EFFORTS THAT WE
NEED TO HELP CLOSE THE LITERACY
GAP AND ENSURE THAT OUR STUDENTS
LEARN TO READ. BY THIRD GRADE.
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING FORMULA. IN EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE OF BILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT THE FIRST
YEAR OF TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN- INTO SET UP THE
PATHWAY TO SEE THAT PROGRAM-
IMPLEMENTED OVER THE COURSE OF
THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS AGAIN AS
I REITERATE ABOUT SCHOOL SAFETY-
A BILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT-
TESTING- ANTIGEN TESTING ON SITE
TESTING- THEN JOB OTHER TYPES OF
RESOURCES. OFFER COATED
MEDICATION- UNIVERSAL MEALS-
THAT- A FIVE HUNDRED AND NINETY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT.
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR
UNIVERSAL MEALS PROGRAM EVERY
STUDENT SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO TWO MEALS REGARDLESS
OF THEIR OF THEIR FINANCIAL
BACKGROUND OR THE ZIP CODE OR
ANY PAPERWORK REQUIREMENTS- AND
OF COURSE THERE'S A COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT. TO SUPPORT
THE RISING COSTS OF EDUCATION OF
FOR OUR SCHOOLS- OF THE SAMBA
ONE POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
TO ADDRESS SCHOOL FACILITY
ISSUES AND SO ONCE AGAIN WE FIND
OURSELVES WITH THE VERY ROBUST
BUDGET- WITH GREAT RESOURCES
THAT WILL ALLOW US TO BUILD AN
EDUCATION SYSTEM THAT QUITE
FRANKLY. IS BETTER THAN WE'VE
HAD BEFORE THE PANDEMIC HAS PUT
A SPOTLIGHT ON INEQUITIES. THAT
EXIST BEFORE FOR HELLO. IN WE
FIND OURSELVES IN A POSITION NOW
TO BILL AND EDUCATE SYSTEM. THAT
CAN GO BEYOND WE'VE HAD. AND UP
QUALITY OF FOR ALL SEASONS UP
WORST. BUT WE GOTTA GET THROUGH
THE CHALLENGES OF SAFETY THAT
THE PANDEMIC I REPRESENTS FOR US
IF I COULD ASK FOR- MY TEAM TO
HELP IN PUTTING UP ASIDE. I LIKE
YOU TO THINK ABOUT THIS YEAR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET IN THE CONTEXT
OF LAST YEAR'S BUDGET- IN MANY
OF THE PROGRAMS THAT WE ARE NOW
IMPLEMENTING. TO DO AS WE SAY TO
HELP TRANSFORM CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS- YOU'LL SEE RIGHT AT THE
TOP ARE UNIVERSAL MEALS PROGRAM
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL I WANT TO
CALL OUT THE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
PROGRAM. THREE BILLION DOLLAR
STRATEGY THAT ALLOWS OUR SCHOOLS
TO HAVE RESOURCES LIKE HEALTH
CARE MENTAL HEALTH CARE SOCIAL
SERVICES. AND OF COURSE
TRANSFORMATIVE SERVICES THAT CAN
HELP TO END THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON. THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE- PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT- BILLIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN ALLOCATED TO SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO
PROVIDE IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING
TO SUPPORT NEW EDUCATORS I'M TO
HELP US. SUPPORT OUR PROFESSION
OF EDUCATORS ANTI RACISM
TRAINING TO GIVE US THE
RESOURCES TO WORK TO OUR SCHOOLS
TO ADDRESS- RACE IN OTHER
BARRIERS THAT HAVE GOT IN THE
WAY. OF OUR STUDENTS THE STATE
HAS ALREADY. PLANNING TO
IMPLEMENT A FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM THAT
SUPPORTS THE NEEDS OF CHILDREN
BIRTH THE TWENTY FIVE. AND OF
COURSE- FUNDING FOR EXPANDED
LEARNING GRANTED EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES AND SO
THANK YOU FOR THE SIDE- WE JUST
WANTED TO SHARE THAT IN THE
CONTEXT OF- THAT YOU THINK ABOUT
THE PROPOSED BUDGET TO THINK
ABOUT. WHAT WE ARE IMPLEMENTING
IN HOW THIS YEAR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET BUILDS ON THE BUDGET THAT
YOU ALL APPROVED. JUST LAST MAY-
IN THAT WE ARE WORKING TO
IMPLEMENT GERMAN THANK YOU ALL
WE WILL BE ALSO- SPONSORING SOME
NEW LEGISLATION THAT HAS IMPACT
IMPLICATIONS. FOR THE BUDGET
BECAUSE WE SEE. OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT ARE NEEDED- TO HELP ONCE HE
AND THRIVE. AS WE TALK ABOUT-
THE- OF THE- SCHOOLS PROGRAM IN
THE MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE A
STAFFING SHORTAGE OF AVAILABLE
COUNSELORS AND CLINICIANS OF ALL
THE SCHOOLS I VISIT I HEAR ALL
THE TIME IS A RISING BEHAVIORS I
HEAR THAT THERE'S A YOU KNOW WE
KNOW THAT THERE IS AN INCREASE
IN DEPRESSION. AMONGST OUR
STUDENTS AND I HEAR IT ON A
REGULAR BASIS AND WE JUST DON'T
HAVE THE PERSONNEL- TO HELP MEET
THAT NEED IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE
NINETEEN COMMUNITIES IN OUR
STATE NINETEEN COUNTIES IN OUR
STATE THAT EXPERIENCE. FIRE IN
THE PAST YEAR- WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVEN'T EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
WE WERE WITHOUT THE RESOURCES WE
NEEDED TO PROVIDE TRAUMA.
INFORMED CARE AND COUNSELING SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WERE
SPONSORING LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD ALLOCATE FUNDS TO HELP
GENERATE ANOTHER TEN THOUSAND
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS OVER
THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS BY
OFFERING SCHOLARSHIPS AND LOAN
FOR ALL SEEM TO HELP- US BUILD
DATABASE. OF THE BURST
COUNSELORS WHO CAN WORK IN OUR
SCHOOLS WHAT THE NONPROFIT
PARTNERS IN MENTAL HEALTH AND
ESPECIALLY WORKING COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN HEALTHCARE
GADGETS LIKE OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES- SO WE'LL CONTINUE
TO TALK ABOUT THOSE PROGRAMS. WE
HEAR US TALK ABOUT A BILL THAT
FOCUSES ON THE MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND HOMELESS
STUDENTS THAT CALIFORNIA SERVES
ABOUT EIGHT THOUSAND OF THOSE
STUDENTS WHO ARE UNACCOMPANIED
IMAGINE IT BEING HOMELESS AND
LIVING ON THEIR OWN SO YOU HEAR
US TALK ABOUT LEGISLATION. TO
HELP GOING FORWARD MORE PROGRAMS
TO SUPPORT OUR HOMELESS STUDENTS
BUT ALSO TO LEVERAGE MORE
FEDERAL RESOURCES FROM THE
MCKINNEY VENTO PROGRAM TO
SUPPORT THEM YOU HEAR US TALK
ABOUT A PAID INTERNSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES THE SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WHO ARE IN
OUR- C. D. E. PROGRAMS. AND
YOU'LL HEAR US TALK ABOUT
PROGRAMS LIKE A BILL THAT WE
HAVE THAT WOULD EXPAND OUR DUAL
LANGUAGE PROGRAMS BY CONVERTING
OUR SCHOOLS INTO DUAL LANGUAGE
PROGRAMS ONE BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT IS SO
IMPORTANT FOR STUDENTS TO
PREPARING THEM. FOR THEIR FUTURE
WE ALSO KNOW THAT AS WE CONTINUE
TO COMBAT DECLINING ENROLLMENT-
THAT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
FEATURE- TO HELP BUILD.
CONFIDENCE FOR FAMILY STICKS
CONTINUE. TO COUNTY. SCHOOLS AND
SO- IT'S A ROBUST BUDGET WE LOOK
. TO THE KIND. ABOUT THE PATH
TOWARDS THE FINAL BUDGET- IN
MAY- IN DISCUSSING MANY OF THESE
NEW PROGRAMS THAT WE BELIEVE
WILL BE IMPORTANT. TO HELPING
OUR STUDENTS HEAL FROM THE
TRAUMA OF THE PANDEMIC HELPING
THEM RECOVER. FROM LOS LEARNING
IN ACADEMIC CHALLENGES AND
HELPING THEM THRIVE AS WE HELP
POINT THEM TOWARDS A GREAT
FUTURE- THIS CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS THAT- CHAIRMAN AMERICA
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY.
QUESTIONS FROM YOU IN THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
SUPERINTENDENT DAN AND LET ME
JUST SAY AS A COMMENT- FROM.
OPENING HERE. THAT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND I
THINK WAS HIGH LEVEL. AND IT WAS
EXACTLY WHAT WE NEEDED TO SORT
OF SUMMARIZE WHAT THE CHALLENGES
IN FRONT OF US AND- I AM VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THE FACT. THAT AS
WE GO DOWN IN DEEP ON EVERY
ISSUE IS WHO IN OUR NEXT DATE
HEARINGS. YOU WILL HAVE STAFF
MEMBERS PRESENT THAT WILL WALK
US THROUGH THE FAX AND WALK US
THROUGH. A YOUR VIEWS IN A WAY
THAT- YOU. ARE THROUGH YOUR
STAFF WILL BE AN ACTIVE
PARTICIPANT IN ALL THOSE DEBATES
AND SO. WE APPRECIATE THE HIGH
LEVEL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING INTO OF THE ISSUES. SO
LET ME ASK- IF EITHER OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE A QUESTION OR
COMMENT BASED ON. CENTER ROAD
SHOW BALK. I DO COULD MORNING.
THURMOND THE PLEASURE TO HAVE
YOU THIS MORE. AND I AM I KNOW I
HAVE LOTS OF QUESTIONS BECAUSE-
WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF ACCESS TO
YOU ALL THE TIME AND I KNOW MANY
MANY PEOPLE ARE JUST INTERESTED
TO. HAVE QUESTIONS THEY WOULD
LIKE TO ASK IF THEY HAD. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE YOU- MY
QUESTION. AND I'M NOT SURE WHERE
TO START- ON ON THIS BUT-
THERE'S A LOT OF
MISUNDERSTANDINGS- IN THE
COMMUNITIES I WAS IN MY DISTRICT
THIS FALL JUST REALLY MEETING
WITH MANY MANY STAKEHOLDERS.
THERE'S A LOT OF
MISUNDERSTANDING ON. WE ARE AT
THE MASK MANDATES COME FROM AND
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY EMAILS
AND PHONE CALLS WE GET AT OUR
OFFICE. ASKING ME TO OUR TO STOP
THESE MASS MANDATE AND- FOR THE
RECORD I WANTED TO GIVE YOU AS A
SUPERINTENDENT OF. EDUCATION FOR
A STATE TO EXPLAIN IT- THE
LOGISTICAL PART OF THAT MASS
MANDATES AND WHO IS IN CHARGE OF
THESE MASS MANDATE AND WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE AND WHAT. IF ANY-
WHAT'S THE WORD I'M LOOKING FOR
WHAT TO PASS YOUR LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE ON THEM FORCING
THEM. THANK YOU SENATOR YOU KNOW
AS IT RELATES TO THE MASK
MANDATES IN SCHOOL- THOSE
MANDATES ARE ESTABLISH- UNDER
THE DIRECTION IN THE ENFORCEMENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND GENERALLY
SPEAKING CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH HAS FALLEN FOR
SMITH THERE UNLESS THERE IS A
COUNTY HEALTH WATER OF SOME
KIND. THAT SUPERSEDES THAT IS
SO- AND SO THAT IS TO SAY THAT
THEY COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH I'M SORRY THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH- SAYS THAT. ALL STUDENTS
AND STAFF SHOULD BE WEARING A
MASK AT ALL TIMES IN EVERY.
SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT- SCHOOL
DISTRICTS GENERALLY DON'T HAVE
ANY- ABILITY TO CHANGE THAT-
BECAUSE THAT IS IN ORDER FOR
HEALTH AND SAFETY AT THAT IS
ENFORCEABLE- TO HELP. PREVENT
THE SPREAD OF KOBE AND GENERALLY
IS RECOGNIZED BY THE HEALTHCARE
COMMUNITY AS BEING ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT FACTORS IN
HELPING TO. KEEP OUR SCHOOLS
OPEN YEAH I KNOW THAT'S
COMPLICATED- BUT YOU KNOW OUR
STUDENTS HAVE FOUND WAYS TO
MANAGE WEARING MASKS AND- AND IT
IT GENERALLY HAS BEEN RECOGNIZED
BY THE HEALTHCARE COMMUNITY. AS
ONE OF THE FACTORS THAT HAS KEPT
OUR SCHOOLS OPEN CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN OPEN MORE THAN
MOST AND HAVE SHUT DOWN FEWER
THAN MOST STATES AND- IT IS A
WIDELY ACCEPTED IN HEALTHCARE
COMMUNITY THAT IT IS BECAUSE OF-
THE MASK MANDATE AND END THE
PRACTICE. OF WEARING FACE MASKS
. THANK YOU VERY FOR THE CALL
FOR. AND I HOPE THAT- MANY OF
OUR PARENTS IN OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE CAN
HERE- YOUR WORDS. THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAVE FOR YOU IS- YOUR
THOUGHTS ON IT THE- VACCINE
MANDATES AND HOW THAT WILL
AFFECT THE STAFFING THE ALREADY
SHORT STAFFED. STOPPING THAT WE
HAVE IN OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS DO
YOU HAVE YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS ON THAT. YOU KNOW I
DON'T SENATOR HAVE ANY DATA-
YET- BOND HOW IT MIGHT AFFECT I
DO KNOW THAT IN SOME AREAS OF
THE STATE. WE'VE SEEN HIGH
LEVELS OF STAFF WHO HAVE-
ALREADY- TAKEN- THE VACCINE
AVAIL THEMSELVES OF THE VACCINE-
WE KNOW THAT- IT IS THE
COMBINATION OF VACCINES. AND
BOOSTERS AND MASKING- AND SOCIAL
DISTANCE THAT HAS WILL BE HELL
ARE KEPT OUR SCHOOLS TO REMAIN
OPEN- I MEAN SCHOOLS IT'S A
TOUGH PLACE TO MAINTAIN SOCIAL
DISTANCING AT SCHOOLS RIGHT
SCHOOLS ARE NOT. BUILT FOR
MAINTAINING A LOT OF THIS AND SO
THE MASKING. HAS BECOME
IMPORTANT AND THE MAN IN THE
VACCINES ARE IMPORTANT AND SO-
AGAIN THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH IS IN A POSITION TO-
ROLLOUT WHAT IS A PROPOSED
VACCINE MANDATE. THAT MANY
ANTICIPATE WOULD GO INTO EFFECT-
PROBABLY BY JULY THIS BY THE WAY
THE BACKSEAT MANDATE. IS WRITTEN
AND SPELLED OUT THAT IT HAS TO
ALIGN WITH CERTAIN APPROVALS
THAT WOULD COME FROM- YOU KNOW
THE FDA AND- OTHER EALTH
ORGANIZATIONS AND THAT AT THOSE
TIMES. THAT VACCINE THAT THE
COLD WITH NINETEEN VACCINE COULD
BECOME LIKE THE OTHER- VACCINES
THAT ARE PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMUNIZATION. SCHEDULE AND SO-
THAT IS- THAT IS WHAT IS BEEN
OUTLINED- TO IT AND TO BE
IMPLEMENTED ADMINISTRATIVELY OF
COURSE WE KNOW THAT THERE IS
LEGISLATION PENDING- WERE
INTRODUCED- IN THE SENATE- THAT
COULD GO INTO EFFECT AND- SOONER
I SHOULD THE ACTOR LEGISLATION-
BE. SIGNED INTO LAW- BUT- IT IS
ANTICIPATED THAT THERE WILL BE A
VACCINE MANDATE LIKELY BY JULY.
OF COURSE STUDENTS IN GRADES
SEVEN THROUGH TWELVE- AGAIN THIS
WHOLE THE VACCINE MANDATE THAT
WOULD COME THROUGH- THIS PART OF
HEALTH AND- IT LARGELY FOLLOWS-
APPROVALS OF THE. VACCINES AND
SO WE WAIT AND WE WATCH. IN THE
MEANTIME WE EVERY CAN YOU GET A
- BECAUSE WE KNOW. THAT DATA
THAT HAVE SEEN IS THAT HOSPITALS
OF HIGHER FOR YOUNG PEOPLE WITH
THAT VARIOUS VARIANTS THAT WE
SEE NOW IS KOBE WE ALSO KNOW
THAT WE'VE SEEN THAT. THOSE WHO
EXPERIENCED THE MOST SERIOUS
CONDITIONS FROM KOBE- EXACTION
HAVE BEEN THOSE WITH OUT OF
VACCINE IN THAT SADLY THAT SOME
OF THOSE SERIOUS CONDITIONS HAVE
BEEN DEATH. AND SO- WE ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE WHO CAN'T GET A VACCINE
IF YOU'RE ELIGIBLE FOR A BOOSTER
TO DO SO AGAIN IF NOTHING ELSE
THEY HELP KEEP OUR SCHOOLS OPEN
AND KEEP OUR COMMUNITIES OPEN.
FOR ME IT'S NOT ABOUT THE
MANDATE AT ALL THIS IS NOT ABOUT
TELLING PEOPLE WHAT THEY CAN AND
CANNOT DO. SIMPLY THIS IS ABOUT
HOW WE KEEP OUR SCHOOLS OPEN HOW
DO WE KEEP OUR BUSINESSES OPEN
IN OUR COMMUNITIES OPEN. AND OUR
ABILITY TO BE AROUND OUR LEVELS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU- RENTAL. AND
ONE LAST QUESTION- WE'VE HEARD
QUITE A BIT OF CONCERNS WITH
REGARDS TO DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ON MANY OF OUR SCHOOLS AND I.
SPEAKING FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE FROM OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT- AND IF MONEY IS BEING
ALLOCATED TO THAT. TO THAT-
SPACE. GIVE ANY THOUGHTS IN THIS
BUDGET AND WHETHER OR NOT WE
SHOULD BE FOCUSING MORE ON
THOSE- ON FUNDS THAT WILL.
MITIGATE THE DEFERRED.
MAINTENANCE FOR MANY MANY OF THE
SCHOOLS WHO I IN I DON'T HAVE A
TOTAL AMOUNT FOR OUR K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS BUT- TO READ THE
ALLOCATING MORE MONEY TO. OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE TO OUR TO OUR- IN
SCHOOLS. THE SHARES ARE SENATOR
I BELIEVE IS YES THAT WE SHOULD
BE ALLOCATING MORE TO OUR
SCHOOLS- YOU KNOW WE HAVE MANY
OLD SCHOOLS AND YOU KNOW I AYE
AYE SIR GO TO SCHOOL BOARD IN A
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT AND WE HAD
A WE HAD TO USE OUR OWN UP ON
PROGRAMS IT- TO THE TO DO MUCH
OF THAT MODERNIZATION AND IT IS
TYPICALLY MORE THAN MOST SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CAN DO AND MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE IN AREAS WHERE FOR
WHATEVER REASON. CITIZENS AREN'T
WILLING TO VOTE TO PAY FOR BOND
MEASURES AND SO THIS BUDGET IS
THOUGHTFUL AND THAT IT OFFERS
YOU KNOW MORE THAN A BILLION
DOLLARS- THAT CAN BE USED FOR A
SCHOOL FACILITIES- IT BUILDS ON-
WHAT IS IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
AND FROM AB EIGHTY SIX THAT
ALSO. IN OTHER BOB BUT IF YOU
DID SAY GAVE FUNDING TO SCHOOLS
DID YOU VERY STRATEGIC
MODERNIZATION AROUND VENTILATION
WE KNOW THAT IS- IMPORTANT
MITIGATION STRATEGY- FOR- FOR
KEEPING US ALL SAFE FROM KOBE-
BUT THERE ARE MANY WHO BELIEVE
THAT EVEN AFTER EVEN IF THE
BILLION PLUS THAT IS PROPOSED IN
THIS BUDGET- IS APPROVED THAT
THEY WILL PROBABLY NEED TO BE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS FOR SCHOOLS
WOULD JUST SAY THAT THIS IS A- A
TOP ISSUE- WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR SCHOOLS HAVE ACCESS. TO
THE TOP FACILITIES TO PREPARE
OUR STUDENTS FOR THE JOBS OF
TOMORROW THAT ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS
SHOULD HAVE A MAKERS SPACE ALL
OF OUR SCHOOLS SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO STEAM AND STAMP- YOU
KNOW THEY SHOULD- HAVE ACCESS TO
UPGRADE TECHNOLOGY- TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR STUDENTS ARE READY FOR
THE JOBS OF TOMORROW AND SO- I
BELIEVE THAT WHAT IS IN THIS
BUDGET IS A VERY GOOD START- BUT
IT WOULD SEEM THAT- AT. THAT
CALIFORNIA'S NEEDS WILL PROBABLY
GO BEYOND THAT- BUT THIS IS AN
EXCELLENT START OF WHAT IS IN
THIS BUDGET AND- WE HOPE TO SEE
IT APPROVED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- SENT ROADSHOW BY SENATOR
MEANT. AT YOU SHOULD RENDON-
THURMAN AND I WANT TO BILL THE
POINT I THINK YOU IN THE AROUND
VERY WELL BUT I DID WANT TO GIVE
MY OWN EXPERIENCE AS A PARENT
AND AGAIN AS I MENTIONED OF A
FIFTH GRADER A THIRD GRADER AND
KINDERGARTNER- AND IT THEIR
SCHOOL AND I KNOW THIS IS AN
ANECDOTE AND I KNOW THAT THE
PLURAL OF ANECDOTE IS NOT DATA
AS THEY SAY BUT- IN MY KIDS
SCHOOL- THE KIDS DO GENERALLY
FOLLOW THE MASS MANDATE- IT'S
NOT A 100% YOU SEE YOU SEE A LOT
OF KIDS WITH THEIR MASKS DOWN
OR- BLOW THEIR NOSE A LOT OF
TIMES THEIR- RUN AROUND WITHOUT
MASKS AT ALL. OF THE TEACHERS
WHO TRIED AND FORCE THAT THE
SCHOOL WORKERS TRY TO ENFORCE
IT- AND IT'S A LOT LIKE YOU KNOW
WE HAVE BANDS ON SWEARING ON
HITTING ON PULLING PEOPLE'S HAIR
AND WE KNOW THE KIDS DO IT- WE
DON'T HAVE A 100% FORSMAN BUT- I
THINK JUST CREATING THE NORM
THAT IS GENERALLY ENFORCED THAT
KIDS WERE MASS IS IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE AS A SUPERINTENDENT
POINTED OUT- EVERY TIME YOU HAVE
ANOTHER COVERED EXPOSURE IT
CREATES THE RISK THAT THE SCHOOL
MIGHT HAVE TO SHUT DOWN THAT
KIDS WILL HAVE TO BE QUARANTINED
AND WE KNOW THAT THE LEARNING
LOSS AND EMOTIONAL HEALTH ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH- NOT BEING IN
PERSON ALL ARE PRETTY
DEVASTATING I THE DATA STARTING
ACCUMULATE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IT'S-IMPORTANT THEY'RE BACK IN SCHOOL
AND IF MATH OR THE WAY KIDS BACK
GET BACK IN SCHOOL I THINK THAT
IS IMPORTANT AND THIS IS
SUPERINTENDENT POINTED OUT- THIS
IS PROVING TO BE. ONE OF THE
PERHAPS THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY
OF PREVENTING TRANSMISSION SO- I
IMPLIED THAT THE WORK OF
TEACHERS ACROSS THIS- STATE OF
SCHOOL WORKERS- I THINK THIS IS
A PRUDENT MEASURE TAKEN IN
RESPONSE TO EXTRAORDINARY TIMES
WORK UNFORTUNATELY YOU HAVE TO
MAKE THESE TYPES A TRADE OFF. IF
YOU WANT TO KEEP OUR KIDS IN
SCHOOL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR MEANT AND LET
THANK BONUS THURMAN AGAIN FOR
MAKING THE TIME TO BE HERE TODAY
AND WE REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOUR STAFF THROUGH
THIS PROCESS THIS WEEK ABOUT A
REFINED ALL THESE ISSUES SO. WE
APPRECIATE. THANK YOU- CHAIRMAN
LAYERED AND THE SENATORS WHICH
OBOE AGAIN MAN AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING CLOSELY WITH
YOU ON THIS BUDGET- LEVINE AND
THE BEST EDUCATION WE CAN'T
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS THANK YOU HI
THANK YOU AGAIN. OKAY WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO
WHICH IS INDEPENDENT STUDY AND I
THOUGHT I WOULD MAKE A FEW BRIEF
COMMENTS. ON THE WAY TO
INTRODUCING THE PANEL THAT WE
HAVE. IN THE LAST YEAR- THE- A
PANDEMIC ONE UP AND DOWN. AND
EVERY TIME WE THOUGHT WE WERE
MAKING OR DEVISING ON A POLICY
WITH REGARD TO SCHOOL REOPENING
THE PANDEMIC CHANGED AND SO. ARE
OUR WHEN WE WERE IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS LAST YEAR WE REALLY HAD
TO POLLS ARE ONE. OF STRONG
ADVOCACY FOR MANY PARENTS AND
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE
COMPLETELY. A REOPEN SCHOOLS
WITHOUT ANY FLEXIBILITY AND WE
STILL HAD A FEW. BOB PARENTS WHO
HAD CONCERNS ABOUT THEIR KIDS
COMING BACK TO SCHOOL AND WE
REALLY WERE NERVOUS. BOB THAT WE
WOULD BE IN A POSITION OF
FUNDING DECLINING ENROLLMENT IF
THERE WASN'T SOME OPTION FOR
PARENTS TO HAD CONCERNS DID NOT
HAVE THEIR KIDS DROP OUT OF THE
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM. AND THE
SO IN THE BUDGET PROCESS WHAT
WAS NEGOTIATED AS AN OPTION. IT
WAS A REGULATED INDEPENDENT
STUDY PROGRAM AND THAT WAS
APPROVED AND AT THE- AND WE MADE
SOME TWEAKS TO IT. IN THE FINAL
WEEKS OF THE LEGISLATIVE SESSION
IN RESPONSE TO SOME OF THE FIRST
FEEDBACK THAT WAS HEARD FOR ME
THAT MIGHT NOT OF BEEN MY FIRST
CHOICE AS THE ALTERNATIVE BUT
GIVEN THE CONCERNS. THAT SOMEHOW
WE WERE GIVING AN OUT TO PEOPLE
OR SCHOOL BOARDS TO NOT RE OPEN
INDEPENDENT STUDY WAS REALLY
DECIDED AS THE ALTERNATIVE. AND
SO BUT NOW WE HAVE GONE THROUGH-
A SUBSTANTIAL PART OF THE SCHOOL
YEAR WITH THAT IS THE
ALTERNATIVE AND WE WILL BE
FACING SOME DECISION. A WHEN WE
GO TO THE MAY REVISED IN JUNE
ABOUT WHETHER TO CONTINUE IT
WHETHER TO TWEAK IT WHAT TO DO
AND IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS
THAT. WE HAVE WE KNOW RIGHT NOW
WE'RE THE PANDEMIC IS BUT WE
DON'T KNOW WHERE IT WILL BE IN
MAY AND- SO THIS HEARING IS
DESIGNED TO JUST HAVE A
DISCUSSION OF THE INDEPENDENT
STUDY AND DECIDE. IF WE SHOULD
START TO THINK OF CHANGES IN
ANTICIPATION OF JUST BEING READY
THIS IS NOT A DECISION THIS DOES
NOT PRECLUDE WHERE WE ARE FOR
TURNS OUT PANDEMIC IT'S A LOT
BETTER BETWEEN NOW AND MAY. BUT
IT IS JUST A DISCUSSION TO BE
READY BASED ON THE EXPERIENCE
THAT WE'VE HAD THUS FAR WITH
INDEPENDENT STUDY. AND SO ON OUR
PANEL TODAY. WILL BE DOCTOR WHO
MAMBA SUPER OF THIS BAR UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. KASANDRA
ANDERSON MARK ONE AND HOPEFULLY
I. DID OKAY WITH YOUR NAME THE
THIRD GRADE INDEPENDENT STUDY
TEACHER IN THE SAN JUAN UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT- COLLECT PETLAND
AN INSTRUCTIONAL AID FROM THE
ARCADE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
WE ARE VERY WELL REPRESENTED
GEOGRAPHICALLY TODAY IN OUR- IN
OUR PANELISTS AND THEN WE'LL
HAVE ERIN A READY- FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. MICHAEL
R. FERRIS FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND MERRY
NICELY FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. AND SO WE WILL BEGIN
- WITH DOCTOR MALDONADO FROM THE
SANTA BARBARA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AND WE WELCOME YOU TO
THE- COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING
GOOD MORNING SENATOR LAYERED
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- KILL
THEM ON THE BALLOT HERE
SUPERINTENDENT SENT OVER UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TODAY AND SPEAK TO YOU
ABOUT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB
ONE THIRTY INDEPENDENT STUDY
BOTH HERE IN OCTOBER UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT BUT IN
PREPARATION FOR THIS TALK THIS
MORNING I ALSO REACHED OUT TO
SOME OF MY SUPERINTENDENT
COLLEAGUES AND I'LL BE SHARING
WITH YOU SOME OF THE THOUGHT
THAT THEY ALSO SHARED WITH ME-
WE BELIEVE THAT STRONGLY THAT
THE LEGISLATURE'S INTENT TO KEEP
KIDS IN SCHOOL WAS THE RIGHT
CALL THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND- I
JUST WANT TO COMMEND ALL MY
SUPERINTENDENT COLLEAGUES
TEACHERS AND- OTHER
ADMINISTRATORS WHO'VE DONE AN
EXCELLENT. JOB IN MY OPINION OF
KEEPING KIDS IN SCHOOLS- OPEN
AND STUDENTS LEARNING WE KNOW
THAT OUR WORK AS EDUCATORS
RELIES HEAVILY ON PERSONAL
CONNECTIONS. AND WE VALUE THAT-
DODD. IN THE VISION. SOME OF THE
BENEFITS OF AB ONE THIRTY HAVE
BEEN THOUGHT IN TERMS OF SOME
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH MORE
INVOLVED THE INTEGRATION OF
TECHNOLOGY EFFORTS THE- MORE
EFFECTIVE THE INDEPENDENT STUDY
BECOMES- OUR DISTRICT IS
RELATIVELY THERE- WE ARE ALMOST
HUNDRED PER WHILE WE ARE 100%
WANT TO ONE DEVICE SCHOOL
DISTRICT- AND IN THAT RESPECT-
WE DID RELY HEAVILY ON OUR
LEARNING MANAGEMENT PLATFORMS TO
ORGANIZE LEARNING RESOURCES FOR
STUDENTS WHICH- WOULD WHICH IS
ANOTHER BENEFIT OF THE PANDEMIC
OF ONE CAN CALL IT THAT. TO HAVE
THE ABILITY TO USE TECHNOLOGY TO
REACH OUR STUDENTS AND PLATFORMS
AND OTHER WAYS TO REALLY RETURN
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY LEARNERS
THAT WE TEACH THESE DAYS-
ANOTHER BENEFIT IS OF COURSE IT
HELPS STUDENTS STAY CONNECTED
WITH THE SCHOOL WITH THEIR
ASSIGNMENTS WITH THEIR TEACHERS
AND CLASSMATES AND WHAT THEY'RE
DOING. AND FOR FAMILIES TO DO
HAVE IMMUNO COMPROMISED A
MEMBERS OR STUDENTS THEMSELVES
THEY ARE ABLE. TO CONTINUE TO
STAY IN PUBLIC SCHOOL. THERE ARE
CHALLENGES WE IDENTIFIED-
COLLECTIVELY- SAY SAYS EVERY SO
TO MY COLLEAGUES. YOU KNOW. THAT
I WAS SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN
MENTIONED EARLIER- DOING THIS
WAS ASKED OF US ON TOP OF AN
ALREADY STRETCHED THIN WORKFORCE
THAT IS GOING ABOVE AND BEYOND
TO KEEP OUR SCHOOLS OPEN. SOME
F THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
HAS BEEN- IMPOSING BURDENSOME
PAPERWORK REQUIREMENTS THAT.
REALLY ARE NOT ABOUT IMPROVING
OUR EDUCATIONAL SERVICES AND
HAVE DISTRACTED MANY OF THE
SCHOOL STEP CONST. WITH
PROVIDING THESE EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES IS TIMING. WHAT THE
STUDENT IS DEEMED POSITIVE FOR
COVERT FOR EXAMPLE THERE
IMMEDIATELY SENT HOME. AND
SOMETIMES WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE
AND- SHORT TERM INDEPENDENT
STUDY POCKET TAT CAN BE SAID
WITH THEM. MANY TIMES THEY HAVE
TO GET THAT PACKET LATER WHEN
THE TEACHER HAS HAD TIME. TO PUT
IT TOGETHER OF COURSE TEACHERS
TEACH- ON A DAILY BASIS BUT
THEIR LESSON PLANS CHANGE
ACCORDING TO STUDENT NEED. TO
HOW MUCH THEY WERE ABLE TO GET
DONE THAT DAY IN PUTTING
TOGETHER HESE POCKETS IT IS
TIME CONSUMING AND IT DOES TAKE
TIME. AGAIN USING A LEARNING
MANAGEMENT PLATFORM HELPS SOME
OF THAT- EFFORT BUT IT DOES TAKE
TIME FOR THEM TO PUT IT
TOGETHER. WHAT THE LATEST A
SEARCHABLE MACRON WE HAD CLASSES
WHERE MAYBE- ONE FOURTH OF THE
STUDENT BODY WAS GONE HALF OF
THE STUDENTS WERE GONE FOR
SEVERAL DAYS. FIVE EIGHT DAYS
DEPENDING ON WHEN THEY COULD
RETURN- THE NEXT TO THE TIME WE
HAVE TO SURE THAT PARENTS ARE IN
OR SIGN WE ONLY HAVE THIRTY DAYS
TO DO THAT AND THAT CAN BE TOUGH
TO DO IN A TIMELY WITH TIMELY
WAY ESPECIALLY APPARENT YOU KNOW
FINDS OUT OF THAT THEIR CHILD
HAS A POSITIVE CASE THEY HAVE TO
REALLY ATTEND TO THAT IN THEIR
HOUSEHOLD IF THERE'S MULTIPLE
FAMILIES LIVING THERE THAT TAKE
SOME OF THEIR ATTENTION AWAY SO
COORDINATING ALL OF THESE PEOPLE
IN A TIMELY WAY. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE MEETING THE
COMPLIANCE REQUIREMENTS AND
POTENTIALLY A FUTURE AUDIT
REQUIREMENTS- DOES TAKE A LOT OF
EFFORT AND TIME FROM WORK AGAIN
ALREADY BEEN STOPPED- WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE THOROUGHLY
LEARN THE RECORDING SIGNING IN
DATING OF ALL OF THESE DOCUMENTS
SO WE HAVE- THAT RECOMMENDATION
TO MAYBE STEAM A STREAMLINED THE
SIGNATURE PROCESS MAYBE CONSIDER
HAVING PASSIVE CONSENT FOR
FAMILIES WITH ONLY ONE SIGNATORY
FOR THE SCHOOL AND THEN- YOU
KNOW I FOUND OUT JUST AND I HAD
TO COME FROM THIS OF MY STAFF.
STUDENT SIGNATURES ARE ALSO
REQUIRED WHEN WE DO THESE
INDEPENDENT STUDY- CONTRACTS AND
AGREEMENTS AND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A- KATE THROUGH TWELVE
SCHOOL SYSTEM SO WE THINK THAT
MAY BE CONSIDERING SOME OF THE
OLDER STUDENTS- BE NICE TO SIDE
BUT NOT NECESSARILY OUR
ELEMENTARY STUDENTS AGAIN THAT
TAKES A LOT OF TIME- THIS IS A
BIT ESPECIALLY HARD AND I WOULD
BE REMISS IF I WAS A
SUPERINTENDENT IN MENTION
FAMILIES WHO LIMITED LANGUAGE AN
ARCTIC ABILITIES- BECAUSE THIS
DOES CREATE ANOTHER BARRIER ONCE
AGAIN MAKES IT ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
TO DO. IT WE WANT TO KEEP THE
VIRUS OUT IS STUDENTS IN SCHOOL
WE REALLY SHOULDN'T- HAVE
BARRIERS THAT PREVENT THEM FROM
COMING EITHER TO GET TRANSLATION
SERVICES IN OUR TECH SUPPORT TO
BE ABLE TO SIGN OFF ON SOME OF
THESE AGREEMENTS AND TEACHERS
HAVE HAD A DIFFICULT TIME OF
COURSE TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO TRANSLATE ALL OF THESE
INDEPENDENT STUDY AGREE SENATE.
AGREEMENT POCKETS OF WORK- WHICH
MAKE IT ALMOST. EMPIRE FOR
FAMILY WHO DON'T ON TO THE TRY
TO THERE'S TO. AT HOME TO
COMPLETE OF THIS OUR- WORK PACK
EVERY. BRING IS THAT OF A
REUNIFIED WE HAVE ONE PRINCIPLE
THAT HAS SOME OF THE MOST FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY STUDENTS AND
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY OR
MORE. WORK WHAT WE'RE REQUIRED
TO GO INTO SHORT TERM QUARANTINE
RIGHT WHEN WE CAME BACK IN FROM-
DISTANT WITH HER BREAK AND THE
STUDENTS WERE IN THEIR LAST AND
GROUP SOMEWHERE BETWEEN THREE TO
FOURTEEN DAYS- IN INDEPENDENT
SHORT. TERM STUDY AGAIN THIS IS
AN EXAMPLE OF THE BIG IMPACT
THAT THE ONLY CRIME HAD ON WHO
WAS ABLE TO BE IN SCHOOL AND WHO
WAS NOT. ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS A
JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL WHEN THERE
WAS TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE
STUDENTS THAT FELL INTO THAT
CATEGORY. SO LOTS OF REQUIRED
TIMELINES TO OVERCOME IN
PAPERWORK. THAT IS SOMETIMES
OVERWHELMING- THIS TIME- WE FEEL
ALSO MAYBE NEED TO BE
RECONSIDERED- WE KNOW THAT THERE
WAS A THREE TO FOURTEEN DAY TIME
LIMIT. I DON'T THINK ANYONE'S
pCRIME WOULD COME THROUGH AND
CREATE SUCH A WAVE THE
REQUIREMENTS ARE FOR CUMULATIVE
ATTENDANCE SO THE YOU A STUDENT-
UNDER ONLY CRYING COULD REACH
THAT FIFTEEN DAY LIMIT VERY
QUICKLY- WHICH AGAIN MAKES IT-
CREATES ANOTHER SET OF PAPERWORK
. A LONG TERM INDEPENDENT STUDY
AFTER THE FIFTEEN DAYS BURNING
THROUGH THOSE FIFTEEN DAYS- ALSO
GO BECOMES AN ISSUE ESPECIALLY
IF THEY HAVE CLOSE CONTACTS THAT
THEN. YOU KNOW GET INFECTED A
COUPLE OF DAYS LATER- IT CAN
BECOME A CYCLE OF- REALLY
DEPENDENCY ON STAYING OUT OF
SCHOOL FOR A LONGER PERIOD OF
TIME. WE KNOW THAT- SCHOOLS CAN
LOSE ADA IF- WORK SEEING THAT
FIFTEEN DAY CABIN NOT REALLY
KEEPING. OUR STUDENTS OUT
LONGER- IF WE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE BACK- IF THE
STUDENT IS SICK WELL THERE IN
THIS ISOLATION OR QUARANTINE
PERIOD- THAT ALSO ADDS ANOTHER
BURDEN BECAUSE WE EXPECTED TO
FIELD TO FINISH THERE ARE-
ASSIGNMENTS DURING THAT
ISOLATION. OR QUARANTINE PERIOD
AND SO WE'RE NOT REALLY TAKING
THIS INTO CONSIDERATION OF AS A
HEALTH FIRST INITIATIVE- AGAIN
GOOD INTENTIONS BUT I THINK SOME
OF THE REQUIREMENTS REGULATIONS
MAKE IT A LITTLE BIT IMPOSSIBLE
AND- THEY ARE NOT REALLY
CONSIDERING THE HUMANITY. OF
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
ALL GOING THROUGH- THE OTHER-
THE THAT WE ARE CONSIDERING IS
JUST SOME OF THE- THE COMPLIANCE
CHECKS GETTING IN THE WAY OF THE
TRUE CONNECTION THAT REALLY
NEEDS TO HAPPEN BETWEEN STUDENTS
WHICH IS RIGHT AND TEACHERS
WHICH IS AT THE HEART OF THIS
LEGISLATION WHICH IS REALLY THAT
THAT PERSONAL CONNECTION. WE
WROTE  LETTER TO OUR SENATOR IN
JULY TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHEN WE
ANTICIPATED SOME OF THESE ISSUES
AND WE ASKED IF WE COULD MAYBE
REPLACE THE REQUIREMENT FOR ANY
AGREEMENTS TO BE SIGNED FOR
SHORT TERMS INDEPENDENT STUDY
WITH THE REQUIREMENT FOR LOCAL
AGENCIES TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
NOTICE TO ALL FAMILIES AND
TEACHERS- AS A WAY TO MITIGATE
SOME OF THIS BUT BURDEN SOME
PAPERWORK AND- AGAIN TO REPEAT
OVER HERE STATEMENT. REALLY
CLARIFYING WHICH STUDENTS ARE
SIGNING OFF ON THESE AGREEMENTS-
AND THAT SOME OF THE WAY THAT
THE LEGISLATION IS WRITTEN RIGHT
NOW- REALLY HELPING PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW THIS IDEA
THAT THIS IS AN OPTION FOR YOU-
BUT REALLY IT'S A NECESSARY
OPTION SO SOMETIMES IT'S
MISLEADING TO TELL PARENTS- THAT
WE CAN OFFER THIS OPTION TO
YOU'LL IT'S OPTIONAL BUT YOU
CAN'T COME TO SCHOOL SO YOU
ALMOST HAVE TO SIGN IT- THINK
CLOSING WE ASKED TO CONSIDER.
REALLY WANT TO LOOK AT SOME OF
THE AUDIENCE TO REALLY CONDUCT
SOME COMPASSIONATE AUDITS THAT
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THAT EVERYONE
IS DOING THEIR BEST- WE HAD SO
MANY STUFF OUT IN JANUARY THAT
ALSO ADDED TO THIS HUGE LIFT- A
BETTER DEFINITION OF MEANINGFUL
CONTEXT I DON'T BECOME
BUREAUCRATIC STEPS THEN AGAIN TO
MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF LONG
TERM INDEPENDENT STUDY LESS
ONEROUS- AND. FOR SHORT TERM AS
WELL. THE ENGAGE WITH OF
TEACHING IS ALSO. FOR MOST ALL
ALSO TO SERVE STUDENTS IN. SO
AGAIN GREAT LEGISLATION GOOD
INTENTIONS WE WANT TO KEEP KIDS
IN SCHOOL. BUT WE REALLY WANTED
TO CONSIDER SOME OTHER
REGULATIONS AND REQUIREMENTS SO
THAT WE- MAKE THIS REALLY ABOUT-
THE PERSONAL CONNECTIONS THAT WE
ARE. IN THE BUSINESS OF IN
EDUCATION THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TO TODAY
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND I KNOW WE MIGHT
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS WHEN WE GET
THROUGH ALL THE PANELS. WILL
MOVE ON TO BECAUSE SANDRA
ANDERSON MARKLAND- THIRD GRADE
INDEPENDENT STUDY TEACHER FROM
SAN JUAN UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME. IT'S MY
PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY YEAH I
ASK TO SHARE SOME OF MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AND SOME OF MY
SUCCESSES AND MY CHALLENGES THAT
I'VE HAD THIS YEAR. I'VE BEEN
TEACHING FOR A COMBINED
SEVENTEEN YEARS IN THE SAN JUAN
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AS A
SPECIALIST OR A CLASSROOM
TEACHER. THIS YEAR I'M AN
INDEPENDENT STUDY TEACHER FOR
THIRD GRADERS. A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT MY CLASSROOM MY STUDENTS
MEET BY ZOOM DAILY FOR AN HOUR
AND FORTY FIVE MINUTES OF
SYNCHRONOUS INSTRUCTION. I ALSO
HAVE A ONE HOUR OF OFFICE HOURS
RIGHT CONDUCT INTERVENTION
GROUPS I NEED WITH SMALL GROUPS
OR PROVIDE ONE ON ONE
INSTRUCTION FOR MY STUDENTS.
EVERY DAY MY STUDENTS HAVE A
SYNCHRONOUS ASSIGNMENTS. AND I
CURRENTLY HAVE A TWENTY TWO
STUDENTS IN MY INDEPENDENT STUDY
CLASSROOM. THIS STUDENT HAVE. OF
ATTENDING THOSE DALY ZERO. AND
CONNECTING TO GOOGLE CLASSROOM
TO COMPLETE DAILY ASSIGNMENTS.
OUR SCHOOL YEAR BEGAN AUGUST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND AT THAT
TIME EACH GRADE LEVEL IN OUR K.
THROUGH FIVE INDEPENDENT STUDY
PROGRAM HAD ONE TEACHER STILL
ALL STUDENTS WERE INITIALLY AND
ROLLED INTO ONE CLASS. SO NEW
STUDENTS WERE CONTINUOUSLY ADDED
FOR THE FIRST FEW WEEKS AND AT
ONE POINT I HAD FIFTY STUDENTS
IN MY CLASS BE FOR NEW TEACHERS
WERE HIRED. BY SEPTEMBER SEVENTH
WE WERE ABLE TO BRING OUR
NUMBERS DOWN TO A MAX OF TWENTY
SEVEN STUDENTS BY HIRING
ADDITIONAL. I'M TEACHERS STILL
OF MY SUCCESSES WHEN INVESTING
SECONDS OF THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN
HAVING EDUCATIONAL STAFF FOR
EXAMPLE I SECRETARY AND THE VICE
PRINCIPAL FOR INDEPENDENT STUDY
AND HOME SCHOOL WERE HIRED AFTER
THE SCHOOL YEAR BEGAN. AND
ALTHOUGH WE WEREN'T READING IN
PERSON COMMUNICATION WITH OUR
STAFF IS CONSTANT YOUR WEEKLY
COLLABORATIONS WE HAVE THAT
SUPPORT SYSTEM WHEN ADDITIONAL
STAFF. WE'VE ALSO HAD THE
SUPPORT OF HOUSING OR MATERIALS
FOR STUDENTS AT AN IN PERSON
SCHOOL SITE WHERE SECRETARY
ALLOCATE THOSE MATERIALS TO
FAMILY. OUR INDEPENDENT STUDY
SECRETARY AND ADDITIONAL STAFF
SUPPORT YOU HAVE ALSO BEEN
MAKING SUCCESSFUL IN MAKING SURE
THAT STUDENTS GIFTED. AERIALS
TECHNOLOGY THAT THEY NEED TO BE
SUPPORTED IN THE PROGRAM.
ANOTHER BENEFIT OF THE PROGRAM
IS THAT I HAVEN'T HAD STUDENTS
WHO HAVE HAD TO MISS MULTIPLE
DAYS OF INSTRUCTION DUE TO
QUARANTINE FOR ILLNESS. WHEN I
GO TO THE CHALLENGES THAT I
FACED THIS YEAR I HAVE IN MY
CLASS I HAD WELL I AM TWENTY TWO
STUDENTS. ABOUT 55% OF MY
STUDENTS WHO ARE NAVIGATING.
THROUGH INDEPENDENT STUDY
WITHOUT ASSISTANCE AT HOME. I
DON'T HAVE A WAY OF HOLDING
THOSE STUDENTS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR BEST QUALITY WORK
POTENTIAL OF WORK. THROUGH THIS
PLATFORM WITHOUT HAVING ACCESS
OR AT HOME SO THAT'S DEFINITELY
BEEN A CHALLENGE UNFORTUNATELY I
SEE THOSE STUDENTS FALLING
BEHIND ACADEMICALLY. I ALSO HAVE
ABOUT EIGHTY TWENTY TWO OF MY
STUDENTS. 36% WHO ARE IN AN
ENVIRONMENT THAT ISN'T CONDUCIVE
FOR LEARNING AND ENGAGEMENT.
THIS MAY MEAN THEY'RE DISTRACTED
BY BACKGROUND NOISE ADDITIONAL
FAMILY MEMBERS THEY ARE
SUPERVISED SO IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
CONCENTRATE OR ENGAGING LESSONS.
DURING OUR SYNCHRONOUS MEETINGS
. AND THAT'S MEANING THAT THEY
MISSED SOME OF THE INSTRUCTION
IN CLASS. OVERALL AFTER LOOKING
AT THE- AND SUCCESSES OF THIS
YEAR I DO FEEL THAT IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION IS MOST EFFECTIVE
FOR STUDENTS AS WE DISCUSSED. I
DO SUPPORT INDEPENDENT STUDY FOR
THOSE STUDENTS WHO HAVE A
MEDICAL NEED OR SUPPORT TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THE PROGRAM I AM
WITH ALL THAT SAID I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT MY
EXPERIENCE WITH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE REALLY APPRECIATE HAVING
SOMEBODY THAT'S ON THE GROUND
THE WAY YOU HAVE BEEN- TO TALK
ABOUT THIS IN MORE HOLDING ALL
QUESTIONS UNTIL WORK. A DONE
WITH ALL THE SPEAKERS WILL NOW
MOVE TO COLLECT HETLAND AND
STRUCTURAL AID FROM THE ARCADIA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN LAYERED AND
SENATORS ARE CHOI BOGUE AND MAN
. HI I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND
OUR QUARTER MILLION MEMBERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. MY NAME IS
COLETTE HEADLINES AND I AM A
SPECIAL EDUCATION PARA
PROFESSIONAL IT SUNNY BRAE
MIDDLE SCHOOL IN ARCADIA. I ALSO
HAPPEN TO BE A MOTHER SO I HAVE
SOME PESONAL EXPERIENCE WITH
INDEPENDENT STUDY. MY DAUGHTER.
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN INDEPENDENT STUDY
FOR THREE OF HER HIGH SCHOOL
YEARS. I'VE WORKED WITH SECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS FOR OVER
FIFTEEN YEARS IN BOTH
TRADITIONAL CLASSROOM SETTINGS.
AS WELL AS RECENTLY THROUGH
INDEPENDENT STUDY. DURING MY
DAUGHTER SKIES SOPHOMORE YEAR AT
ARCADIA HIGH SHE WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH A VERY AGGRESSIVE CASE OF
SCOLIOSIS AND WITHIN JUST A FEW
MONTHS WE WERE LIVING IN
SACRAMENTO AT THE RONALD
MCDONALD HOUSE WITH HER
RECOVERING FROM MAJOR SPINAL
SURGERY. AND SUFFERING THROUGH
SOME VERY SERIOUS SIDE EFFECTS
FROM HER NEWLY ALIGNED SPYING.
CHANGING SCHOOLS WAS NOT AN
OPTION BUTTON OR WAS FAILING
THROUGH NON ATTENDANCE.
THANKFULLY SHE HAD A COUNSELOR
AT THE SCHOOL WHO SUGGESTED
INDEPENDENT STUDY AND SHE HAD AN
INCREDIBLE TEACHER WHO HELPED
HER NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM. AND
BECAUSE OF THE FLEXIBILITY OF
THE INDEPENDENT STUDY PROGRAM
SHE WAS ABLE TO GRADUATE WITH
HONORS IN TWENTY NINETEEN RIGHT
BEFORE. THIS PANDEMIC HIT US. SO
WHETHER IT'S FULLY- JUST LIKE MY
DAUGHTER SITUATION ORACLE THE
NINETEEN INDEPENDENT STUDY
OFFERS A SAFE OPTION. FOR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES TO BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE EDUCATION. CURRENTLY
I SUPPORT MIDDLE SCHOOL STUDENTS
WITH A VARIETY OF NEEDS I WORK
IN A SPECIAL DAY CLASSROOM WITH
THE TEACHER. AND OTHER SUPPORT
STAFF SUCH AS ONE TO ONE AIDS
RIGHT NOW NONE OF MY STUDENTS
ARE PARTICIPATING IN INDEPENDENT
STUDY HOWEVER ON I DO. ON A
DAILY BASIS WE COULD BE INFORMED
OF THE NEEDS FROM SOME OF THE
PARENTS AND ASKED TO SUPPORT.
IT'S HARD TO TELL WHEN WE'RE
GOING TO FEEL THE NEED TO
TRANSITION IN SUPPORT OF
STUDENTS IN INDEPENDENT STUDY.
FOR DECADES INDEPENDENT STUDY
HAS BEEN A VIABLE OPTION FOR
FAMILIES AND STUDENTS IN A
VARIETY OF SITUATIONS. IT'S
ALLOWED FOR INDIVIDUALIZED
EDUCATIONAL SUPPORTS. AS WELL AS
FLEXIBILITY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
THROUGH THE REGULATORY AND AUDIT
PROCESS. AS ITS NAME SUGGESTS
INDEPENDENT STUDY REQUIRES
STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO WORK
INDEPENDENTLY AT HOME WITH THE
SUPPORT OF THEIR FAMILIES AND
SCHOOL STAFF. FOR THIS SCHOOL
YEAR THE STATE ADDED SOME
ADDITIONAL LAYERS OF
REQUIREMENTS TO INDEPENDENT
STUDY THERE BY ALTERING THE
FLEXIBILITY OF PROGRAM AND
MAKING IT MUCH MORE LIKE
DISTANCE LEARNING. K. THREE
STUDENTS ARE NOW REQUIRED TO
SIGN ON FOR SYNCHRONOUS DAILY
INSTRUCTION. STUDENTS IN FOURTH
THROUGH EIGHTH GRADE MUST HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR DAILY LIFE
INSTRUCTION AND WEEKLY
SYNCHRONOUS INSTRUCTION AND HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS MUST HAVE WEEKLY
SYNCHRONOUS INSTRUCTION. THE
STAFF ARE REQUIRED TO LOG DALY
PARTICIPATION DOCUMENTED FROM
ONLINE ACTIVITIES. PRIOR TO
THESE NEW REQUIREMENTS THE RULES
FOR INDEPENDENT STUDY WERE CLEAR
STUDENTS COULD NOT PARTICIPATE
IN THE PROGRAM IF THEY WEREN'T
COMPLETING THE WORK FOR MAKING
PROGRESS ON THEIR ASSIGNMENTS
THERE WERE VERY CLEAR AND
CONCISE PROCEDURES FROM WHAT WE
HAD TO DO BEFORE INFORMING THE
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES THAT
THEY WERE NO LONGER ELIGIBLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM.
EXCUSE ME WITH THESE RECENT
CHANGES WE'VE ENCOUNTERED
SEVERAL CHALLENGES. ONE WE ARE
OVERWHELMED WITH THE NUMBER OF
INDEPENDENT STUDY STUDENTS THAT
WERE REQUIRED TO CONNECT WITH ON
A DAILY BASIS AND THIS IS IN
ADDITION TO THE STUDENTS THAT
WERE SUPPORTING THE CLASSROOM.
TWO WELL WE'RE REQUIRED TO RE
ENGAGE THE FAMILIES AS WE DID
DURING DISTANCE LEARNING. THE
STATE HAS NOT DEFINED WHAT
RECOURSE WE HAVE IF FAMILIES ARE
UNABLE OR CHOOSE NOT TO ENGAGE
IN THE PROGRAM. FOR EXAMPLE SOME
PARENTS MA NOT BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR THEIR
STUDENTS BECAUSE OF WORK
OBLIGATIONS OR EVEN A LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING IN THE MATERIAL OR
THE CURRICULUM. THREE WHEN A
STUDENT IS NOT PARTICIPATING AND
OR COMPLETING THEIR COURSEWORK
WE REALLY HAVE NO GUIDANCE ON
THE TIME LINE TO CONTINUE
KEEPING THE STUDENTS IN
INDEPENDENT STUDY. VERSUS
REMOVING THEM FROM THE PROGRAM.
PREVIOUSLY WE WERE ALLOWED TO
REMOVE THE STUDENT FROM
INDEPENDENT STUDY WHEN THEY
FAILED TO COMPLETE THEIR
COURSEWORK. WITH THIS PROGRAM
BEING A REQUIRED OPTION NOW WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO KEEP
STUDENTS IN THE PROGRAM. EVEN IF
THEY FAIL TO ENGAGE PARTICIPATE
OR COMPLETE THE COURSEWORK. FOR
ATTENDANCE ISSUES FOR
INDEPENDENT STUDY HAVE NOT BEEN
CLEARLY DEFINED AS THEY RELATE
TO TRUANCY AND THE START PROCESS
AND FINALLY WE EXPEND SO MUCH
TIME AND RESOURCES FOR OUR
INDEPENDENT STUDY PROGRAM. SO
WHEN THE STUDENTS AND PARENTS
ARE NOT ABLE TO DO THEIR PART
WILL THERE BE A LOSS OF FUNDING
WILL WE BE HELD HARMLESS AND
COULD WE BE LOSING THE ADA THESE
ARE THE HARD CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE'RE HAVING IN ASKING TO GO SHE
ASIANS TABLE. IN CONCLUSION
INDEPENDENT STUDY HAS BEEN AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION SYSTEM. THROUGH THIS
PROGRAM WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
EDUCATE STUDENTS WHO MAY NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO TRADITIONAL
CLASSROOM EDUCATION BECAUSE OF
UNIQUE ABILITIES AND SUCH.
INSTALLATIONS RICO THE
REQUIREMENTS MADE IT POSSIBLE
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE
A QUALITY EDUCATION WITH STRICT
GUIDANCE AND ACCOUNTABILITY. IN
PERSON LEARNING IS THE BEST
OPTION WHEN IT CAN BE DONE
SAFELY WHEN IT CAN INDEPENDENT
STUDY NEEDS TO STRIKE A BALANCE
BETWEEN THE DISTRICTS
REQUIREMENT TO EDUCATE THE
STUDENTS AND THE STUDENTS
ABILITY TO ENGAGE AND COMPLETE
THEIR COURSE WORK INDEPENDENTLY
. THANK YOU FOR LISTENING I
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORT AND TIME
DEVOTED TO THE STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATION. AND
THANK YOU WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS. WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO ERIN A READY- FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I AM
ACTUALLY BE SPEAKING TODAY ON
THAT ON THE ISSUE AND-
INDEPENDENT STUDY- THANK YOU
LEANING GRANT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SAID GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU TO MUCH EARLIER THAN
SENATORS- SO IN LIGHT OF THE
ONGOING DIFFICULTY WITH STUDENT
ATTENDANCE STUDENT COVER
NINETEEN- THE PANDEMIC AND-
ONGOING ISSUES INDEPENDENT STUDY
WILL CONTINUE TO BE AN OPTION
FOR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES.
TO USE TO COUNT INSTRUCTIONAL
TIME FOR STUDENT WORK THAT IS
BEING DONE REMOTELY. AND TO HELP
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CLARITY AND
FLEXIBILITY. AROUND HOW
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME IS COMPUTED
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES
CHANGES TO INDEPENDENT STUDY
THAT WOULD ALLOW SYNCHRONOUS
INSTRUCTION TO COUNT FOR
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME. IN
TRADITIONAL INDEPENDENT STUDY IN
ADDITION TO STUDENT WORK
PRODUCT- IT ALSO PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY ON THE
TIMELINE FOR ELEAZAR THE COLLECT
ASSIGN INDEPENDENT STUDY PLAN
FOR BOTH SHORT TERM AND LONG
TERM SO ANYTHING OVER FOURTEEN
DAYS- INDEPENDENT STUDY. AND
WHILE WE AS A AS AN
ADMINISTRATION ARE COMMITTED TO
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION FOR TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE ELLIE AS CAN
STILL CHOOSE BETWEEN TRADITIONAL
I ASKED HIM COURSE BASED I
GUESS. TO MAKE QUALITY SHORT AND
LONG TERM REMOTE INSTRUCTION
MODELS THAT BEST SERVE. THE
NEEDS OF THEIR STUDENTS- I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WE'RE HOLDING THE QUESTIONS
TO WE GET THROUGH ALL SIX
SPEAKERS. NEXT IS MICHAEL R.
FERRIS FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MICHAEL SANDERS WITH
THE L. A. O. WE DO NOT HAVE ANY-
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS AT THIS
TIME TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WAS
JUST RELEASED YESTERDAY. WE ARE
IN THE PROCESS OF REVIEWING THE
PROPOSED CHANGES TO INDEPENDENT
STUDY WE WILL FOLLOW UP WITH
SPECIFIC. RECOGNIZE RED STAR. OF
A CONDITION OF MY HAVE ON NO FOR
THE COMMENTS BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
CARPETS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND MERRY NICELY FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. A
GOOD MORNING- CHAIR LAYERED AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- HEARING A
FLEET CHIEF DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION- WE ARE THANKFUL FOR
THE PROPOSALS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION. AS WELL AS
OTHERS. THAT HAVE PUT FORWARD TO
ADDRESS ISSUES REGARDING KEEPING
SCHOOLS OPEN OPERATING SAFELY.
DURING THE PANDEMIC. INDEPENDENT
STUDY IS A CRITICAL TOOL IN
KEEPING SCHOOLS OPEN. AND THERE
ARE OTHER INTERCONNECTED ISSUES
TO ADDRESS TO YOU SUCH AS THE
SUPPLY OF EDUCATORS. AS WE WORK
THROUGH THESE PROPOSALS IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE DO NOT
PENALIZE SCHOOL DISTRICTS. WERE
TRYING TO KEEP CLASSROOMS
RUNNING FOR KEEPING THEIR
STUDENTS HEALTHY AND SAFE. AND
WE WOULD ASK THAT THIS LENS IS
CAPPED. AS WE DISCUSSED HOW BEST
TO HELP ELEAZAR GET THROUGH THE
THIRD YEAR OF THIS PANDEMIC. I
HAVE WITH ME ELIZABETH DEAR
STEAM DIRECTOR OF CDC'S SCHOOL
FISCAL SERVICES DIVISION. TO
ASSIST IN ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. A. N. T. R. I'M
GOING TO DO THIS IS THE TIME FOR
QUESTIONS I'M GOING TO LEAD WITH
A COUPLE. IN. A. L. I'M
WONDERING MAYBE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- SINCE
SOME OF THESE ARE OF PROPOSALS
ARE LATE BREAKING NEWS IF YOU
JUST GO SLIGHTLY INTO MORE
DETAIL ABOUT WHAT THE CHANGES
ARE FROM THE CURRENT YEAR THAT
YOU ARE RECOMMENDING- LENA GRANT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO
CURRENTLY A SYNCHRONOUS
INSTRUCTION- OR IT THE PROPOSAL
WE HAVE NOW MAKE SYNCHRONOUS
INSTRUCTION COUNT FOR
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME-
INTERNATIONAL INDEPENDENT STUDY
PRIOR TO THIS PROPOSAL THAT WAS
NOT- AVAILABLE TO EARLY EIGHTIES
SO I THINK I BELIEVE IT'S
EDUCATION CODE SECTION FIVE ONE
SEVEN FOUR FIVE POINT. FIVE ONE
SEVEN FOUR SEVEN POINT FIVE-
SUBDIVISION BE- ONE AD
SYNCHRONOUS INSTRUCTION- TO
DOCUMENTARY FOR A PARTICIPATION
OF A STUDENT IS DOCUMENTED AND
THEN OF TO CLARIFY IS WHAT CAN
BE INCLUDED IN THE PEOPLE WORK
PRODUCT FOR THE PURPOSES OF
COUNTING TOWARD APPORTIONMENT
CREDIT SO PEOPLE WORK PRODUCT
HAS A DEFINITION IN STATUTE AND
THAT IS CLARIFIED. IN THIS
PROPOSAL. AND THEN- IN ADDITION
WE ARE- ALLOWING- WE PROVIDE
SOME ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY ON
THE TIMELINE FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO COLLECT
THOSE SIGNED INDEPENDENT STUDY
AGREEMENTS FOR STUDENTS THAT THE
BILL INTO BOTH SHORT TERM SO
ANYTHING UNDER FIFTEEN DAYS AND
LONG TERM DID ANYTHING OVER
FOURTEEN DAYS- INDEPENDENT STUDY
TO- EVERY TIME A STUDENT ENTERS
INTO AN INDEPENDENT STUDY PLAN
THEY- HAVE TO HAVE. A THAT PLAN
SIGNED BY THEIR PARENT OR
GUARDIAN AND TO THEIR
INSTRUCTOR. AND EVENTUALLY OUR
PROPOSAL IS TO CLICK TO MAKE IT
MORE FLEXIBLE FOR THE SIGNATURES
HE COLLECTED. AND THAT IS THOSE
THREE MAJOR POINTS ARE THE MAJOR
CHANGES THAT YOU'RE RECOMMENDING
. THOSE ARE THE THREE MAJOR
CHANGES YEAH THANK YOU THEN LET
ME GO TO THE PANELISTS. AND JUST
ASKING MANY OF THE PANELISTS-
DESCRIBED OF WHAT THEY LIKE AND
WHAT THEY HAVE PROBLEMS WITH
THAT LET ME JUST PUT A FINER
POINT ON IT JUST ALLOW YOU IN
THE ANSWER TO ONE QUESTION SAY
WHAT IMPROVEMENTS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SEE IN THE INDEPENDENT STUDY
FROM MARKET I HAVE A FEELING
THAT THAT SOME OF YOU ARE
HEARING WHAT FINANCES FOR POSING
FOR THE FIRST TIME WHICH IS WHY
I WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
REITERATED IT MAY HEARING. AND
THEN WHAT DO YOU WISH WOULD
REMAIN A SO IT'S REALLY WHAT
YOU'D LIKE TO SEE IN THE
FRAMEWORK THAT DOESN'T EXIST
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO REMAIN
AND- LET ME JUST GO THROUGH OUR
FIRST THREE PANELISTS AND SEE IF
ANY OF THEM HAVE ANY COMMENTS
WITH THAT QUESTION AND WE WOULD
START WITH DR MALDONADO. THANK
SENATOR LETTERED- I AGREE WITH
SOME OF THESE. PROPOSALS AT
LYNETTE HE NOW HAS MENTIONED- I
AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE FIFTEEN
DAYS BECAUSE- I AS I UNDERSTAND
IT FROM MY STUDIES ARE
CUMULATIVE DAYS SO. THE CITY
COULD HAVE- TAKEN FIVE IN THE
FALL AND SUDDENLY TEN IN THIS IN
JANUARY MAYBE ANOTHER FIVE
LATER. IN THOSE ALL CREATES SOME
CONFUSION FOR STUFF SO THAT
NEEDS TO BE CLARIFIED- I DO
THINK THAT IT WOULD BE BEST IF
WE COULD MAYBE. REMOVE THOSE
NUMBERS BECAUSE THEY FEEL A
LITTLE BIT ARBITRARY AND
DEPENDING ON HOW THE VIRUS MOVES
AND WHAT IT CAUSES. IN TERMS OF
ISOLATION AND QUARANTINE PERIODS
IT COULD THEY COULD POTENTIALLY
END UP. CREATING AGAIN. A
SITUATION WHERE THE STUDENTS
TRYING TO CATCH UP TO THE WORK
MAYBE ILL. AND THEN HAS TO COME
BACK TO SCHOOL CONTINUE THEIR
LEARNING- SO THE PHYSICIAN OF
FLEXIBILITY I WOULD NEED TO
UNDERSTAND FURTHER WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE- TO MAKE IT MORE.
REASONABLE IN TERMS. MOST ARE
ABOUT THAT I KNOW- SO HERE- SO I
JUST WANT SOME SOME ADDITIONAL
CLARIFICATION OF THAT IT IS VERY
DESTRUCTIVE TO STUDENTS WHEN
THEY'RE MOVING IN AND OUT OF
INDEPENDENCE TO THE SHORT TERM
INDEPENDENCE IN THE LONG TERM
THEY CHOOSE THAT AS WELL BACK
AND FORTH BETWEEN THE CLASSROOM
AND BEING AT HOME. SO I DO I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE US THINK UP A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT SOME
ADDITIONAL- THANKS ABILITY AND
DEFINITIONS BECAUSE THEY SEEM OF
THE STATE FEELINGS SEEM A LITTLE
ARBITRARY AND WHEN IT COMES TO
CUMULATIVE- TIME. PERIODS IT'S
NOT ADDING UP THIS IS US THINGS
ARE UNFOLDING THANK YOU. I THINK
BVE. EARN A READY- HAS JOINED US
AS WELL I THINK I'M GONNA GO
THROUGH THE OTHER TWO BEFORE
ASKING MAY BE FOR RESPONSE. TO
THAT SO BECAUSE SANDRA ANDERSON-
MARC WHEN I WAS JUST WONDERING
IF YOU HAD ANY COMMENTS. WITH
REGARD TO THE QUESTION OF WHAT
YOU LIKE AND WHAT YOU'D LIKE TO
SEE CHANGES. MANY COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU MOUTH THANK
YOU AND I WOULD ASK COLLETTE HAD
LEARNED THE SAME THING. THANK
YOU YOU KNOW REALLY. I BELIEVE
WHAT OUR DISTRICT HAS TALKED
ABOUT. THE MOST IS SIGN THE
FLEXIBILITY AND THE DAILY
REQUIREMENT IN TRADITIONAL.
INDEPENDENT STUDY. A STUDENT WAS
GIVEN A CALENDAR AND I
UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE THAT
THIS REALLY DEPENDS ON THE AGE
OF THE STUDENT BUT IT AS STUDENT
WAS GIVEN A CALENDAR OF WORK A
LOG OF ASSIGNMENTS AND THEY WERE
REQUIRED TO MEET ONCE A WEEK.
WITH THEIR INDEPENDENT STUDY
TEACHER AND THEN THEY WENT OVER
THE PROGRESS. AND COMPLETION OF
ASSIGNMENTS THEY WERE REQUIRED
TO MAKE PROGRESS THAT'S THE KIND
OF FLEXIBILITY I THINK THAT WE
WOULD BE IMPRESSION ABOUT A
LITTLE. THE DAILY PARTICIPATION
IS OVERWHELMING MY DISTRICT HAS
ONE SPECIAL EDUCATION R. OR
INDEPENDENT STUDY TEACHERS FOR
GRADES. K. THROUGH THREE BUT
SHE'S ALSO TEACHING IN CLASS WE
HAVE ANOTHER TEACHER. WHO'S
TAKING CARE OF GRADES FOUR
THROUGH EIGHT. AND THAT'S ALL
THAT'S A BIG DIFFERENCE AND THAT
DAILY INSTRUCTION PIECE IS
REALLY DIFFICULT TO MAINTAIN AND
TO ACCOUNT FOR ALL OF THAT
EXHIBITION SO THAT THAT'S THE
BIGGEST THING I THINK THAT WE'RE
SEEM. I KNOW THAT WE WOULD
WELCOME MORE TIME FOR DAILY
CONTRACTS OR FOR INDEPENDENT
STUDY CONTRACTS TO BE SIGNED THE
TIME LIMITS ARE REALLY
RESTRICTING WE ARE SEEING MORE
OF OUR STUDENTS IN LONG TERM
INDEPENDENT STUDY RATHER THAN
COMING AND GOING. DO TO COPE AND
WE'VE OF COURSE SEEN EXTREME
ABSENCES BECAUSE OF CODE AND
WHATNOT. BUT TRYING TO GET
TOGETHER A PACKET FOR THAT
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT ON THE FLY IS
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT. SO IT YEAH
THAT THAT'S REALLY THE
FLEXIBILITY OF THE PROGRAM TO GO
BACK TO A SORT OF PREQUEL THE
DAYS WOULD BE FANTASTIC FOR OUR
DISTRICT. THANK YOU AND THEN LET
ME ASK THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO. COMMENT ON
SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
JUST MADE AND I DON'T KNOW WHICH
ONE OF YOU WOULD LIKE TO DO IT.
I CAN SPEAK UP REAL QUICK I
SCIENCE CENTER LAYER AND IT.
WILL BE A PART OF FINANCE WE'LL
START THERE. BUT I DO NEED TO
CONFUSE YOU MIGHT THROW MY FACE
UP ON THE ON THE SCREEN HERE I
JUST WANTED TO BE READY IN THE
WINGS- SHOULD THERE BE A NEED.
BUT YOU KNOW AT THIS POINT ON I
WOULDN'T CONFUSE FOR ALL OTHER
REASONS BUT NOT BY THAT. SO FEEL
FREE TO GO AHEAD. YES IT- YEAH
POINT I WOULD SAY. ON ON BEHALF
OF MYSELF PERSONALLY HAVE TO BE
ADMINISTRATION I MEAN WE
DEFINITELY RECOGNIZE- THE
DIFFICULTIES THAT YOU KNOW
EDUCATORS AND ADMINISTRATORS ARE
GOING THROUGH RIGHT NOW-
HONESTLY- TRUE HEARTFELT JUST.
HATS OFF TO ALL OF YOU. KNOW
REALLY INTERACTING WITH WITH THE
STUDENTS OF OUR STATE ON DAILY
BASIS THAT IT GOES. A LONG WAY
AND WE UNDERSTAND IT IS VITAL
AND CERTAINLY WILL TAKE. THOSE
COMMENTS UNDER ADVISEMENT- WE
UNDERSTAND THAT NOTICES THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SOMEWHERE LAST
COUPLE COUPLE OF YEARS WE
IMAGINE THIS WILL BE. YOU KNOW
JUST THE BEGINNING OF A ROBUST
ROBUST CONVERSATION THE WE DO.
STAND BEHIND OUR PROPOSAL AND
WHAT WE ENVISION FOR THE COMING
YEAR. CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE WILL BE SEVERAL PIECES AS
WELL THAT MAY COME INTO PLAY. AS
WE- CONTINUE OUR CONVERSATION
WITH THE LEGISLATURE. AND WITH
YOU ALL ESTATE HOMES SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT WELL THEN
LET ME MAKE A COMMENT AND A
QUESTION THE COMMENT IS. AND I
THINK IT'S FOR OUR FIRST THREE
PANELISTS. OF THE PROCESS THAT
WE GO THROUGH HERE IS THE
GOVERNOR RELEASES THE BUDGET IN
JANUARY. AND WE GO THROUGH THE
TEN HEARINGS AND EVEN MORE THAT
WE HAVE. IN THE HOPES THAT WE
ARE OUT THE ISSUES AND THAT THE
GOVERNOR AND THE FINANCE
DEPARTMENT AND THE DEPARTMENT TO
WILL RESPOND. IN THE MAY REVISE
AND- AND AS MUCH AS I WISH TO
HONOR WHAT CAME OUT TO THE
JANUARY TENTH BUDGET AND I'VE
BEEN A PART OF. A NUMBER. OF
THEM THROUGH THE YEARS MYSELF.
THE JANUARY TENTH BUDGET. IF
DOES NOT BEAR RISK. TO WHAT IS A
- IN JUNE AND THE PROCESS IS
REALLY AIRING THESE ISSUES AND
HAVING THE- THE TO APARTMENT
STAFF LISTENED AS THEY ARE TODAY
IN A WAY THAT THEY CAN DECIDE IF
THERE ARE THINGS THAT THEY WISH
TO INCORPORATE ALONG THE WAY.
NOW MY OTHER QUESTION AND THIS
IS PROBABLY FOR THE FINANCE
DEPARTMENT. WHEN I WENT HOME
AFTER WE ADOPTED THE BUDGET I
GOT BOMBARDED PARTICULARLY IN MY
HOME TOWN OF SANTA CRUZ. BY
PEOPLE THAT HAD BEEN DOING
INDEPENDENT STUDY FOR THIRTY
YEARS. AND SUDDENLY IN THE
COURSE AND I THINK THAT. THE
COURT HAD ONE REFERRED TO THIS
OBLIQUELY IN HER COMMENTS. THEN
SUDDENLY. OF THE HAD ALL THESE
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS THAT
THEY CONSIDERED ONEROUS TO DO
WHAT THEY HAD ALREADY BEEN DOING
FOR THIRTY YEARS AND IT WAS
REALLY PAINFUL FOR THEM AND-
IT'S NOT. AUTOMATE UNSURE WHAT
THE QUESTION IS EXCEPT IS THERE
A WAY TO TAKE SOMETHING LIKE
THAT INTO ACCOUNT. IT IN WHAT
YOU DO BECAUSE- THEY DIDN'T NEED
THE DISCIPLINE TO MAKE SURE THEY
WERE EDUCATING PEOPLE ONE MINUTE
SOMEBODY THAT WORKED FOR ME AT
ONE POINT CAME OUT OF THAT
THIRTY YEARS OF INDEPENDENT
STUDY I KNOW THAT THEY WERE
EDUCATED. THIS SO HOW DO- IS
THERE ANY FLEXIBILITY YOU COULD
GIVE IN THOSE SITUATIONS AS WE
LOOK AT GOING FORWARD WITH THIS
PROGRAM. I CAN ATTEMPT TO.
ANSWER THAT QUESTION AS I THINK
I UNDERSTOOD IT- I WOULD I WOULD
JUST SAY YOU KNOW GOING BACK TO
THE SPRING AND JUNE LIKE YOU
SAID WHEN THE BUDGET WAS SIGNED-
YOU KNOW THAT WAS IT WAS A JOINT
EFFORT RIGHT BETWEEN. THE
FINANCE OF THE LEGISLATURE
UNCERTAINLY CONSULTATION HEAVILY
WITH. CITY STAFF AND- AT THE
TIME RIGHT WE DIDN'T HAVE THE
FORESIGHT TO KNOW THAT DELTA WAS
GONNA COME AROUND CERTAINLY NOT
NOW OMICRON. AND I THINK PART OF
THE CONCERN WAS YOU KNOW REALLY
RAMP BETWEEN BEEFING UP THE
EXISTING INDEPENDENCE WHAT STUDY
STRUCTURE BECAUSE WE DID
ANTICIPATE SO MANY MORE STUDENTS
AND SO MANY MORE ELEAZAR.
NEEDING TO USE THAN IN YEARS
PAST AND SO THAT WAS THE- I
THINK THE MAIN THRUST BEHIND ON
SOME OF THOSE CHANGES- CERTAINLY
HINDSIGHT IS TWENTY TWENTY SO WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE BEEN
DIFFICULTIES IN PRACTICE AND- WE
HOPE THAT OUR- GOALS AT THIS
TIME- WELL ADDRESS AND CLARIFY
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES- BUT
THAT'S- YOU KNOW REALLY THE BEST
THAT I CAN SAY AT THE MOMENT
MOVING FORWARD. AND THEN LET ME
MAKE A COMMENT WHICH IS IT I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT
IT. I JUST HOPE YOU LISTEN TO
THIS CONVERSATION AND OTHER
CONVERSATIONS AS WE HEAD TOWARD
THE MAY REVISED TO DECIDE THAT
IF YOU NEED TO TWEAK IT OR DO
OTHER THINGS IN RESPONSE TO
CONCERNS THAT ARE RAISED. YOU
WILL CONSIDER THAT SO THAT'S-
THAT'S ALL WE CAN HOPE FOR I
THINK JUST GIVEN WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW. LET ME ASK MY
COLLEAGUES IF THERE ANY
QUESTIONS SENATOR MEANT DO YOU
HAVE A QUESTION. ON THIS YEAR
SENATE REMAINS. FIVE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TO. I THOUGHT IT WAS
VERY. INSTRUCTIVE TO HEAR- THE
LOCAL. REPRESENTATIVE IN
PARTICULAR. I JUST HAD A
QUESTION FOR THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCES START. I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE I UNDERSTOOD- THE
SCOPE OF THE SYNCHRONOUS STUDY.
CHANGES THAT YOU'RE MAKING.
WOULD THAT ALLOW ANY STUDENT FOR
ANY REASON TO SUBSTITUTE
SYNCHRONOUS STUDY FOR IN
CLASSROOM INSTRUCTION. EIGHT
WITH THAT OR IS THAT LIMITED
TAKE TO COPE AND RELATED ITEMS.
RENDON SET DIRECTED TO SOMEBODY
APARTMENT OF FINANCE OKAY. I
THANK YOU FOR CONFIRMING
EDUCATION I CAN I CAN ANSWER
THAT- SO IF I UNDERSTOOD
CORRECTLY I'LL JUST REPEAT IT
REAL FAST SO CORRECT YOUR
QUESTION WAS WITH THE ALLOWANCE
OF SYNCHRONOUS INSTRUCTION TO
COUNT TOWARDS- INSTRUCTIONAL
TIME. CHALLENGE FOR BOTH
STUDENTS WHO MIGHT BE AN
INDEPENDENT STUDY DUE TO COLD
EXPOSURE OR COLD AND YOU KNOW
HOUSE TIVITY. OR JUST
INDEPENDENT STUDY STUDENTS IN
GENERAL. YOUR QUESTION IF THAT'S
THE QUESTION. YES THE ANSWER
WOULD BE IT ARE THE ANTENNAS I
WOULD COMPLAIN ABOUT SO ANY
STUDENT WHETHER THEY'RE
INDEPENDENT STUDY FOR YOU KNOW
JUST THAT THAT'S THE STUDENT AND
THE AND THE PEOPLE'S CHOICE. OR
IF IT WERE YOU KNOW BY FOR SO TO
SPEAK DUE TO COMBAT- EITHER ONE
THAT THE INTENT WOULD BE THAT.
THE SAME STRUCTURE BE ALLOWABLE
IN IN EITHER INSTANCE. THANK YOU
ADDED THIS IS A FOLLOW UP- I
MAYBE I MISSED THIS MATERIALS WE
HAD BUT YOU SEE INTENT THAT THIS
WOULD BE A TEMPORARY. MEASURE IN
RESPONSE TO SOME OF THE COVERT
ISSUES OR IS THE IDEA THAT THIS
WOULD BE A LONGER. RANGING.
CHANGE IN OUR POLICIES. AT THE-
IS IT IS AN ONGOING IT'S A
PERMANENT CHANGE OUR ENGINE AND-
AND I GUESS AND AS A FOLLOW UP
TO THAT LIKE. YOU KNOW BECAUSE I
THINK ABOUT THIS IS WE'VE GOT
COVERT PROBLEMS AND THEN WE HAVE
LONGER TERM ISSUES AND- I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE-
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN WHAT IS
RELATED. TEMPORARILY TO COVET.
AND WHAT WOULD MAYBE IN FIVE
YEARS IS GOING TO BE BEHIND US
AND THEN WHAT. IS SORT OF MORE
PERMANENT STRUCTURAL. HAVE YOU
YOU KNOW IS STUDIED THE IMPACT
THIS IS GOING TO HAVE ON
TRADITIONAL INDEPENDENT STUDY
STUDENTS. ARE HOW THIS IS GOING
TO IMPACT THE DIFFERENT ELEAZAR
ACROSS THE STATE. SO I JUST WANT
TO UNDERSTAND SIR WHAT THIS
SEEMS LIKE A FAIRLY AMBITIOUS
CHANGE. IF IT'S IF IT'S MEANT TO
BE PERMANENT. THEY COULD HAVE A
LOT OF COLLATERAL IMPACTS AND I
YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW HOW I WANT
TO WEIGH IN ON THIS I REALLY
DON'T HAVE ANY OPINION ON IT
BUT- IT STRIKES ME THAT. YOU
KNOW SOMETIMES WE MAKE CHANGES
IN RESPONSE TO TEMPORARY
PROBLEMS. I AND WE CREATE BIGGER
PROBLEMS. WITH THOSE AND I WANNA
MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT DOING THAT
HERE. JERK I MEAN I THINK YOUR
YOUR COMMENT AREAS- WELL WELL
TAKEN UNDERSTOOD. I THINK FROM
OUR- POINT OF VIEW- THIS IS WHAT
WE FEEL IS THE BEST. CHANGE
MOVING FORWARD BUT- YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY LIKE I SAID IN MY
PREVIOUS COMMENT RIGHT HINDSIGHT
IS TWENTY TWENTY- WHICH I THINK
IS KIND OF WHAT YOU'RE GETTING
OUT RIGHT TRYING TO GET AHEAD OF
THOSE. THOSE THINGS- AND
CERTAINLY IF IT WERE TO COME IN
THE FUTURE- THAT THERE WERE TO
BE YOU KNOW CHANGES NEED TO
SCALE BACK THIS OR SOME OTHER
PIECE. I MEAN THAT IS ALWAYS A
POSSIBILITY- STATUTE CAN BE
ALTERED RIGHT- BUT AT THIS POINT
WE FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH BUT
THIS APPROACH. SURE I GUESS I'D
FOLLOW UP AND JUST SAY YOU KNOW
STATUTES CAN BE ALTERED BUT IF
WE KNOW THERE'S A PROBLEM UP
FRONT MAYBE WE SHOULDN'T. MAKE
THE CHANGE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
PRETTY GOOD GIVEN THE SHORT TIME
FRAMES WITH WHICH STUDENTS
LEARN- YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT
THERE'S PLENTY OF DATA IS A
FORMER TEACHER MYSELF THAT- IT'S
FAIRLY CLEAR THAT IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION IS. LIGHT YEARS.
MORE VALUABLE THAN SYNCHRONOUS
STUDY. AND ALSO GONNA STUDY MAY
BE APPROPRIATE FOR- THIS TIME A
COVERT I DO HAVE CONCERNS AROUND
THIS. I ALSO CONCERNS ABOUT
EQUITY ISSUES THAT MIGHT BE
RAISED AS WE EXPAND INDEPENDENT
STUDY. I WHAT'S THIS GOING TO DO
FOR DIFFERENT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ACROSS THE STATE I REALLY HAVE
NO SENSE OF THAT I THINK. IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT YOU GUYS
STUDY THIS BEFORE WE- MOVE AHEAD
WITH IT WITH THE C. CHANGE THAT
COULD REALLY DRASTICALLY ALTER-
INSTRUCTION. I WANTED TO OPEN IT
UP TO ANY OF THE LOCAL-
REPRESENTATIVES THEY MIGHT HAVE
OPINIONS ON THIS. I DO YOU HAVE
THOUGHTS ON WHAT THIS MIGHT DO
TO YOUR- ALLEY AS AND SCHOOLS.
IF WE WERE TO JUST OPEN UP A
PANDORA'S BOX HERE INDEPENDENT
STUDY TO EVERYBODY OF FORGETTING
COVERT FOR A MOMENT BUT- IN THE
LONG RUN. WELL THE STUDIO CO OF
A YEAR IN IT AND IT'S NOT THERE
WHEN OUR HEARING WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO KNOWN. SORRY HE'S ALRIGHT
HOLD WILL TAKE ON WHICH ISN'T
TOTALLY. OF IF ANY OF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO RESPOND TO SENATOR.
MEN'S QUESTION PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS A DOCUMENT ABOUT OKAY IF
I COULD BE. YOU'RE FREE SO IS
THE QUESTION WHAT WOULD IT DO TO
OUR SCHOOL DOES AND WE WERE
INPUT A K. TWELVE INDEPENDENT
STUDY WHICH IS WHAT I'M- HEARING
DISCUSS. WELL IF WE WERE TO
PERMANENTLY IS SO I'M JUST
SAYING FOR KOBE THE SEEM TOTALLY
APPROPRIATE. BUT BEYOND KOBE
LIKE THIS IMAGINE A FUTURE IF WE
CAN WORK OVER NO LONGER IS A
PROBLEM- WHAT WOULD BE THE
IMPACTS ON. YOUR SCHOOLS. IF WE
WERE TO CREATE A PERMANENT
CHANGE THAT ALLOWS A
SUBSTITUTION OF THINKERS STUDY
FOR IN PERSON INSTRUCTION FOR
INTENDED STATE PURPOSES. YEAH
JUST OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD I'M
DEFINITELY SEEING THAT WHAT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER I THINK IT WAS
CALLIMACHUS UNDER WHO MENTIONED
THE IMPACTS. PARTICULARLY FOR
THE YOUNGER STUDENTS WE KNOW
THAT THAT HAS CREATED A HUGE
DISPARITY IN LEARNING- THE WAYS
THAT WE TEACH IN ELEMENTARY
GRADES BUT I HEARD.
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN'S
COMMENTS EARLIER ABOUT READING
AND LANGUAGE LEARNERS- I THINK
IT WOULD DEFINITELY CREATE THAT
COSTS US SECOND SCHOOL SYSTEM
WITHIN THE SCHOOL SYSTEM. THAT
WOULD CREATE A WHOLE NEW LEVEL
OF TEACHER SKILLS KNOWLEDGE AND
ATTRIBUTES. NEW CURRICULA-
DEVICES INTERNET CONNECTIVITY IS
INITIALLY IN SANTA BARBARA FOR
EXAMPLE HAVING THEM BOTH AND NOT
JUST AT THE SCHOOL BUT AT HOME
FOR CHILDREN- THE HELP THAT THEY
WOULD GET AT HOME IS IT WOULD
CREATE ANOTHER LEVEL OF. OF AN
INSTRUCTIONAL PROGRAM IN MY
OPINION. JUST TOP OF MY HEAD
THINKING. OKAY THEN- DESIGN THAT
ARE HEADLINES YOU SO MUCH.
ANYBODY ELSE ANY QUESTIONS
BEFORE WE MOVE ON. FROM I'M
GONNA MAKE ONE ADDITIONAL
CLOSING COMMENT AND I MADE THE
COMMENT ABOUT. AND BY THE WAY IT
DID TO THE- COMMENT ABOUT A
TWENTY TWENTY HINDSIGHT
HINDSIGHT IS TWENTY TWENTY- WILL
HAVE HINDSIGHT FOR THREE OR FOUR
MONTHS OF THE ADDITIONALLY AT
THE TIME OF THE MAY REVISE AND I
HOPE THAT I THOUGHT THAT IF
THERE ARE. ADDITIONAL
REFINEMENTS THAT EMERGE AS A
RESULT OF THAT THEY WILL BE
CONSIDERED. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT HAPPENED LAST YEAR
MATCH TO COMMENT I WANT TO MAKE
. IS THAT WE DISCUSS THIS IN
OPEN SESSION AND- WITH MANY
STAKEHOLDERS SO THAT SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION WAS
REFLECTING OUT TO ITS
CONSTITUENCY. OF THE SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR FOR REFLECTING OUT
CSEA AND WE HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE HERE TODAY WAS
REFLECTING OUT C. F. T. C. T. A.
N. IT WAS EXASPERATING. TO HEAR
OCCASIONALLY AFTER IT WAS ALL
DONE THAT PEOPLE DIDN'T LIKE
SOMETHING WHEN. THERE WAS A
CHANCE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROCESS TO REFLECT THEIR VIEWS
BEFORE THE DECISION WAS MADE.
AND SO I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE
ANYBODY THAT'S LISTENING. ARM TO
DO THAT THIS YEAR BECAUSE THE
TIME. TO HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT
THIS IS NOW BETWEEN NOW AND MAY
AND MAKE SURE. THAT IF PEOPLE
HAVE ISSUES THEY ARE REFLECTED
CLEARLY TO US IN IN CASE WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO TAKE THEM INTO
ACCOUNT TO DO THINGS. THAT WOULD
BE REALLY HELPFUL AND I KNOW
LAST YEAR. THE REAL PROBLEM IN A
AND IT'S ACTUALLY STILL
CONTINUING. IS THE PANDEMIC IS
UNPREDICTABLE AND IT CHANGES
REGULARLY. AND WE REALLY FOUGHT
. WELL WE WERE GOING TO MOVING.
A FAIRLY UNCONDITIONAL OPENING
AND THEN HERE CAME DELTA AND
THEN HERE CAME ON THE FRONT END.
AND THEY WROTE CHANGE THE WAY OF
THE LAND FOR WHAT TO AND THEN WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S STILL COMING I
HOPE. THAT SENATOR MAN SAID IT
IS QUESTION THAT THERE IS A TIME
THAT WE MOVE PAST THIS AND WE
CAN DECIDE WHAT'S IMPORTANT HOW
TO OPERATE. LARGEST ENCOURAGE
EVERYBODY TO WHYY AND WHEN THE-
DECISION IS BEING MADE. AN EVEN
THOUGH OUR HEARINGS GO LONGER.
WE JUST HAD SOMEBODY FROM.
ARCADIA AND SANTA BARBARA
PARTICIPATE WITHOUT HAVING TO
COME INTO THE CAPITAL AND TRAVEL
ALL THE WAY HERE TO DO SO. WE
ARE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU THIS WAS
A VERY HELPFUL. ISSUE ON THE
HEARING WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
ISSUE THREE WHICH IS THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
OVERVIEW AND STRUCTURE AND I
HAVE TO LISTED WITNESSES OUR
PANELISTS AND RADIO FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND CANNED
COUPON FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WILL MOVE FIRST
TO TWO PARENT. MORNING IN GERMAN
MEMBERS IN AN AREA MARTIN
FINANCE SO I'M BACK SCENTING
WITH A VERY BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROP
NINETY EIGHT MINIMUM GUARANTEE
CALCULATION AND SOME OF THE K.
TWELVE BUDGET PACKAGES- BUDGET
PACKAGE BOZELL'S. SPECIFICALLY
COMPARED TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ENACTED LEVELS
REVENUES OVERALL HAVE INCREASED
NEARLY FORTY BILLION DOLLARS
ACROSS A THREE YEAR PERIOD AT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. WITH TEST
ONE PROVISION NINETY OPERATIVES
EACH YEAR THE GUARANTEE DOES.
CALL FOR ABOUT 38% START USING
THIRTY EIGHT CENTS OF EVERY
DOLLAR OF THAT INCREASE TO GO
TOWARDS K. FOURTEEN EDUCATION
PLUS LOCAL PROPERTY TAX REVENUES
. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
GUARANTEED TOTAL IS AT NINETY
FIVE POINT NINE BILLION DOLLARS
A TWO AND A HALF BILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE OVER ESTIMATE FOR THAT
YEAR AT THE BUDGET ACT. NINE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO WE
GUARANTEE IS UP FIVE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS ALTHOUGH THE
ENACTED LEVEL IN JUNE FOR A
TOTAL OF NINETY NINE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS. AN INCREASE OF
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE ABOUT
EIGHT POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
OVER THE ENACTED LEVEL FOR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AT THE
BUDGET AX THAT'S A YEAR OVER
YEAR INCREASE EIGHT POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS GOING FROM
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AT THE
BUDGET ACT. TO WHERE WE NOW
ESTIMATE TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
TO BE. FOR A TOTAL MINIMUM
GUARANTEE CALCULATION OF A
HUNDRED AND TWO BILLION DOLLARS
TO PROPAGATE OBVIOUSLY A
UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNT OF FUNDING
FOR K. FOURTEEN SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. TWENTY TWO
ABOUT TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
POINT NINETY EIGHT TOTAL FUNDING
AMOUNT DOES RESULT AS WELL IN AN
UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNT OF. OUR K.
TWELVE PER PUPIL FUNDING AT JUST
OVER FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
FIFTEEN THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY ONE DOLLARS. PER K. TWELVE
EIGHTY EIGHT TO BE EXACT.
SWITCHING GEARS TO PROPOSITION
TWO AND THAT WAS NINETY RAINY
DAY RESERVE THAT WAS ESTABLISHED
AS PART OF PROP TWO IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
DOES ESTIMATE THAT DEPOSITS WILL
NOW BE REQUIRED IN ALL THREE
YEARS THE BUDGET WHEN NOW. THREE
POINT ONE BILLION IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND THREE POINT SIX
BILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. OF WHICH ARE
INCREASES OF ONE POINT TWO
BILLION NINE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
MILLION RESPECTIVELY ABOVE THE
BUDGET ACT AMOUNTS THAT WERE
ESTIMATED IN THAT IS BECAUSE- TO
DOES HAVE A TWO YEAR TRUE UP
MECHANISM. FOR THAT RESERVE
WHEREBY WE ARE REQUIRED TO RE
ESTIMATE A COUPLE YEARS- IN
ARREARS WHAT THOSE DEPOSIT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN ASSESSED
FACTORS CHANGE. WITHIN WITHIN
THE GUARANTEED WITHIN THE STATE
. AND THEN IN TWENTY THREE AS
WELL WE ESTIMATE AN ADDITIONAL
POSITIVE THREE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS BEING REQUIRE BURKE TOLD
RESERVE BALANCE OF NINE POINT
SEVEN BILLION. A SIMILAR TO THE
DEPOSIT SO WE ESTIMATED AT THE
BUDGET ACT BUT THEY DO RESULT IN
THE 3% OF THE CONTROL SHARE OF
THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE. BEING MATT WHICH THAT
PARTIAL WHEN THIS MAN DOES NOT
TRIGGER THE SWEDISH RESERVE
BALANCE PERSONS SEES ME THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICT RESERVE CAPS-
REQUIRING THEM TO BEGIN TO EAT
HERE TO THOSE BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. DOES
PRIORITIZE THE LION SHARE OF
FUNDING TOWARDS EXISTING ONGOING
PRIORITIES AND PROGRAMS SUCH AS
THE LCF WHICH WE'LL HEAR ABOUT
THAT MORE IN A LATER PANEL-
EXPANSION OF THE EXTENT OF THEIR
INJURIES PROGRAM. OF THREE POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
FUNDING. FOR THAT PROGRAM UP TO
FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION. OTHER
KEY INVESTMENTS TO SPEAK ABOUT
FOCUS ON TRADITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN EXPANSION
INCREASING ACCESS UNIVERSAL
SCHOOL MEALS THE INCREASING
SPECIALIST SPECIAL EDUCATION
BASED FUNDING. AND CREASING A
STATE SCHOOL RATES THE MAJOR ONE
TIME INVESTMENTS I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT. BOTH FOCUS ON
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH ONE AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS ARE
PROPOSED FOR READING SCHOOL BUS
FLEETS AND ARE HELPING. CENTRIC
BREASTS- MORE GENERAL JAMES
CATION ISSUES AS WELL- AS WELL
AS A FORTY FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR KITCHEN INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS ARE SIMILAR TO A
PROPOSAL THAT WAS INTRODUCED
LAST YEAR. AS WELL. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES PROPOSE A
REVENGE OF THE TEST. ONE
PERCENTAGE OF PROFITS JUST
NINETY EIGHT. OUR FOR THE
ESTIMATE INCREASE COSTA
ADDITIONAL. THAT WILL BE
ENTRANCE CAN. INTO TWO TWENTY AS
A RESULT THE UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
EXPANSION THAT IS SET TO BEGIN
IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE THAT COST
IS CURRENTLY ESTIMATED AT SIX.
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS NO IT WILL BE ADJUSTED
AND REVISED HIS ACTIONS BECOME
AVAILABLE FROM THE FARM
EDUCATION BASED ON ACTUAL
ATTENDANCE DATA SIMILAR TO HOW
WE RECONCILE THE LCS OF
CALCULATION. AT LARGE AS ACTIONS
BECOME AVAILABLE SINCE IT IS A
CONTINUOUS OPERATION. WELL NOT
CONSTITUTIONALLY REQUIRED- THIS
PROPOSAL TO REVENGE THE
GUARANTEE IS CONSISTENT WITH
PAST PRACTICE TO IT JUST NINETY
EIGHT TRIANGULATION TO ACCOUNT
FOR. PROGRAMS AND FUNDING THAT
MAY MOVE INTO OR OUTSIDE OF THE
GUARANTEE RELATIVE. TO NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY SEVEN LEVELS.
THAT I WILL CUT OFF MY COMMENTS
FOR NOW BUT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS WE HAVE. MISTER BOND
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CAN FIND
WITH THE ANALYST OFFICE OUR
COMMENTS ARE SUMMARIZED IN A
SHORT ANALYSIS BE PUBLISHED IN
HARD COPY A FEW DAYS AGO ALSO
AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE I THINK
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GAVE
YOU A GOOD OVERVIEW OF THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET SO I WILL JUST
FOCUS ON A FEW HIGHER LEVEL
COMMENTS. REGARDING THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE IN THE MAJOR STORY
THIS YEAR REALLY IS ABOUT A
STATE GENERAL FUND REVENUES ARE
THE STATE SOONEST HAS SEEN A
SURGE IN A COUPLE OF KEY AREAS A
DRAMATIC REBOUND IN RETAIL SALES
RECORD HIGH CORPORATE EARNINGS.
GROWTH AND EMPLOYERS PAYROLLS
AND ALL OF THOSE DEVELOPMENTS
HAVE PUSHED REVENUE ESTIMATES
ARE FAR ABOVE WHERE THEY WERE
ESTIMATED TO BACK IN. JUNE OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. PROPOSITION
NINETY GUARANTEE IS UP NEARLY.
FORTY CENTS FOR EACH DOLLAR
HIGHER REVENUE- REGARDING THE-
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT RESERVE
AND THOSE DEPOSITS IF YOU TURN
TO PAGE THREE OF OUR- ANALYSIS.
THE CAP ON HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
RESERVES WE ESTIMATE WITH THE
FACT HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE MEDIUM
AND LARGE DISTRICTS BOB THAT CAP
LIMITS THOSE DISTRICTS TO.
GENERAL PURPOSE RESERVES OF NO
MORE THAN 10% OF THEIR ADOPTED
BUDGETS ARE THOSE DISTRICTS
COULD I TAKE SCHOOL BOARD ACTION
TO DESIGNATE THOSE WITH SERVICE
FOR SPECIFIC PURPOSES I SEEK AN
EXEMPTION FROM THE COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION. OR SPEND
DOWN THOSE RESERVES. I PRINT A
PAGE FOR WE THINK B. R. REVENUE
ESTIMATES UNDERLYING THIS BUDGET
ARE REASONABLE. IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO- EVEN INSPIRATION
GENERAL FUND ESTIMATES ARE A
LITTLE OVER NINE BILLION BELOW
ARE NOVEMBER ESTIMATES. THAT'S
STILL WELL WITHIN THE RANGE OF
WHAT'S PLAUSIBLE ALTHOUGH THERE
IS MAYBE A MORE LIKELY THAT THE
NOT PROBABILITY REVENUE
ESTIMATES FROM UP A LITTLE BIT
BY NAME. IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE- THE ADMINISTRATION IS
NEARLY TEN BILLION HELLO ARE
NOVEMBER ESTIMATES BUT THE
MAJORITY OF THAT DIFFERENCE IS
REALLY RELATED TO SOME OF THE
SPECIFIC TAX PROPOSALS IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET ADJUSTING FOR
THOSE. ARE UNDERLYING REVENUES-
IN THAT YEAR ARE IS REALLY WE'RE
REALLY CLOSE. WHAT THE B. X.
THAT REVENUE ESTIMATES CHANGE
THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE WHAT INCREASE OR
DECREASE ABOUT FORTY CENTS FOR
EACH DOLLAR OF HIGHER LOWER
REVENUE- THAT REFLECTS THIS
FORMULA IN THE STATE
CONSTITUTION ON THIS. TEST ONE
OF THAT GUARANTEES SCHOOLS
INFINITY COLLEGES A MINIMUM
SHARE OF GENERAL FUND REVENUE.
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S ALSO A
SIGNIFICANT UNCERTAINTY RIGHT
NOW ABOUT STUDENT ATTENDANCE
LEVELS BOTH IN THE CURRENT YEAR
AND IN THE YEAR THAT WAS A AND-
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT THAT. EVEN A VERY
LARGE ATTENDANCE DECLINE- IN
EITHER OF THOSE YEARS ARE BOTH
OF THOSEYEAR IS- WOULDN'T
RESULT IN A LOWER PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE. I GIVEN
THAT MINIMUM. REQUIRED
PERCENTAGE OF GENERAL FUND
REVENUE THAT NEEDS TO BE SET
ASIDE FOR SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. I KEPT IN THE SPECIFIC
SPENDING PROPOSALS PAGE FIVE. OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAS NEARLY
EIGHTEEN BILLION IN NEW- THE
FOURTEENTH SPENDING. NEARLY
ELEVEN BILLION A BATCH IS
ONGOING AND MORE THAN SEVEN
MILLION IS ONE TIME. AND WE TEND
TO THINK OF THOSE PROPOSALS IS
REALLY FALLING INTO FOUR MAJOR
BUCKETS. THAT BUDGET CONTAINS
FIVE POINT THREE BILLION BY
RELATED TO FUNDING PREVIOUS
COMMITMENTS THESE ARE PROGRAMS
EXTENSIONS IN AUGMENTATIONS THAT
WERE SCHEDULED TO OCCUR OVER A
MULTI YEAR PERIOD- INCLUDED IN
THE JUNE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AGREEMENTS. THE BUDGET CONTAINS
FOUR POINT ONE BILLION FOR COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENTS IN
ATTENDANCE CHANGES. TALK. ABOUT
THOSE A LITTLE BIT MORE IN THE
NEXT PANEL. THE BUDGET ALSO CAN
TWO POINT THREE BILLION FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE ON THE BIGGEST
COMPONENT OF THAT WITHIN THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT BUDGET
IS THE SCHOOL BUS. REPLACEMENT
BROWN'S ALSO INCLUDES KITCHEN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FOR
MAINTENANCE FUNDING FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND THEN
FINALLY THERE'S ABOUT SIX
BILLION- IN OTHER PROPOSALS
THAT. I DON'T REALLY FALL INTO
ANY OF THOSE OTHER CATEGORIES.
AGE SIX IS JUST A LIST OF THE
MAJOR KICKOFF OPPOSE ALSO ONE
TIME AND I'M GOING. EIGHTY SEVEN
IT HAS MAJOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROPOSALS THAT YOUR GENDER HAS
MORE DETAILS ON SOME OF TOSE
AND YOU'LL COVER ALL OF THEM AND
SUBSEQUENT PANELS OR SUBSEQUENT
HEARINGS I WANT SPEND TOO MUCH
TIME. FOCUSING ON THOSE BY
TURNING TO PAGE EIGHT I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT THE STATE HAS
REACHED A FAIRLY IMPORTANT
FISCAL MILESTONE IN WHICH IT
COULD. MOST LIKELY WHETHER A
MILD RECESSION WITHOUT. AND THAT
KIND OF BUDGET RESILIENCE REALLY
REFLECTS TWO FACTORS THE FIRST
IS THE BALANCE OF THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT RESERVE
NINE POINT SEVEN BILLION NEARLY
10% OF THE GUARANTEE- THE OTHER
IS THAT THE BUDGET DOES NOT
COMMIT ALL OF THE ON GOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FUNDING
TO ONGOING. PROPOSITION NINETY
PROGRAMS SO THAT CREATES A
CHRISTIAN BUT LET'S THE STATE
ADDRESS PRODUCTIONS MINIMUM
GUARANTEE MORE EASILY. AND TO
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF THE KIND
OF RESILIENCE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. IF THE STATE HI
PATHETICALLY WORD TO EXPERIENCE
A YEAR OVER YEAR GENERAL FUND
REVENUE DECLINE OF TWENTY
BILLION IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. IN REVENUE WHERE TO STAY
AT THAT LEVEL IN TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE AND THEN RECOVER IN
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX- THE
STATE OULD. FIND AT THE
GUARANTEE. AND WOULD NOT NEED TO
MAKE REDUCTIONS. TO PROGRAMS.
BECAUSE THEY CAN USE THEIR
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT RESERVE
ON THE ONE AND- BUDGET QUESTION
TO. GET THROUGH. THAT THOSE TWO
DOWN YEARS. WE THANK US OF THE
ON GOING PROPOSAL ARE RECENT
ESPECIALLY THE ONES TO KEEP AT.
YOUR LIFE BUILDING ON EXISTING.
AND MY PREVIOUS. FROM THE
COMMUNITY. I'M GOING PROPOSALS
NEW ISSUES- YOU'LL BE HEARING
MORE ABOUT THAT FROM. SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN SUBSEQUENT HEARING
THIS- UNLIKE PREVIOUS YEARS THE
STATE APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT IS A
SIGNIFICANT FACTOR IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET. ADMINISTRATION
ESTIMATES THAT ACROSS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO STATED POINT SIX BILLION BOB
IT'S LIMITS. AND AS YOU KNOW
WHEN THE TATE. RECEIVES EXCESS
REVENUES IT HAS THREE MAIN
OPTIONS FOR ADDRESSING THAT. CAN
REDUCE STATE TAX REVENUE AS IT
CAN ENGAGE IN ADDITIONAL
SPENDING ON PURPOSES ARE EXEMPT
FROM THE LIMIT LIKE
INFRASTRUCTURE STATE EMERGENCIES
WORK AND PUT THE EXCESS REVENUES
FIFTY FIFTY AFTER ONE TIME
PAYMENTS THIS WASN'T TOO MANY
COLLEGES THE HALF FOR TAX.
REBATES AND THE REASON I BRING
THIS UP IS THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT AFFECTS
SOME OF THE CHOICES YOU CAN
MAKE.OR FORTUNATE IF YOU CAN DO
AND TRY TO HELP THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED FOR EXAMPLE. THE
LEGISLATURE THE LEGISLATURE
SHIPS FUNDING AWAY FROM SOME OF
THE GOVERNOR'S INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSALS THAT MEANS THE STATE'S
GOING TO BE EVEN MORE. BOB ARE
THERE A LOT OF ITS APPROPRIATION
LIMITS YOU NEED TO MAKE SOME OF
THOSE OTHER CHOICES ALONG WITH
THAT. ACCORDING TO THE FINAL
PAGE. OF OUR- HANDOUTS NOW WE
HAVE TWO OVER ARCHING
RECOMMENDATIONS REALLY TO GUIDE
SOME OF THE- COMMITTEE
DISCUSSIONS. ARE THE FIRST WOULD
BE TO FIND FEWER NEW INITIATIVES
ARE THAN WHAT THE GROUP BUDGET
PROPOSES. DISTRICTS FACE SOME
CONSISTING OF A CONSTRAINT ON
THEIR PASSAGE IMPLEMENTED
ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS IN THE
COMING YEAR. THOSE INCLUDE
STAFFING DISRUPTIONS RELATED TO
THE PANDEMIC- AS WELL AS
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT FUTURE
ENROLLMENTS AND THE MAN FOR THE
PROGRAMS DISTRICTS ARE ALSO IN
THE MIDST OF IMPLEMENTING. PLANS
TO SPEND MORE THAN TWENTY
BILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDS CAN TO
IMPLEMENT A NUMBER OF.
ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS. THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET-
WE THINK BUDGET WHATEVER MORE
NEW PROGRAMS THAT NEXT. SO MUCH
SO WE'RE- DISTRICTS STRUGGLED.
ALL OF THOSE FINISH AND- OF.
RELATED TO THAT. CONCERN
RECOMMEND USING THE UP COMING
HERE TODAY AND PRIVATE THE- THAT
ADDRESS THE MOST CLEARLY DEFINED
PROBLEMS AND THAT ENTAILS ASKING
THE ADMINISTRATION TO PROVIDE
EVIDENCE. AND EXPLAIN WHAT THE
UNDERLYING ISSUE IS HOW IT IS
NOT FUNDING. WOULD ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE AND- TAKING CARE TO ENSURE
THAT. IT IS NOTHING THAT'S
PROVIDED DOES NOT FRAGMENTS. OF
THE STATE EXISTING PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES. FOR EXAMPLE THIS
BUDGET HAS A COUPLE OF WORKFORCE
PROPOSALS. AND WE SUGGEST NOT
CREATING NEW PROGRAMS IN THAT
AREA AND YOU UNDERSTAND SOME OF
THE CONCERNS. BOB WHAT THE
EXISTING PROGRAMS AND WHETHER
THOSE PROGRAMS ARE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS. POSSIBLE
WITHOUT SOCIETY HAVE BEEN TAKING
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THANKS TO BOTH OF YOU AND I
KNOW THAT. WE HAVE TO MOVE ON IN
A FEW MINUTES SO THAT WE CAN
HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO DO THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA AND I
THINK THAT IS THE PLACE THAT
WE'LL TALK ABOUT- THE ADA
PROPOSAL AND DECLINING
ENROLLMENT. I HAVE ONE QUESTION
THAT'S GLOBAL JUST TO CLARIFY
THINGS AND MAYBE FOR AREN'T
READY YET AND IT'S- YOUR JUST
GAVE US GREAT INFORMATION BUT
WHAT WE TRY TO SYNTHESIZE ONE
HEADLINE WHICH IS. WHAT THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT IS
AVAILABLE FOR EACH. OF BUCKET SO
AS BEST I COULD TELL IT'S THREE
POINT ONE BILLION INTO THE RAINY
DAY FUND. IT'S EIGHT POINT TWO
BILLION IN PROP NINETY EIGHT AND
BASS FUNDING. AND WHAT WAS
UNCLEAR TO ME WAS HOW MUCH ONE
TIME MONEY THERE WAS THERE'S
ALMOST SIX POINT TWO BILLION AND
RECOMMENDED PROGRAMS. WITHIN
THAT BUCKET BUT I WASN'T CLEAR
FACTS THE TOTAL AMOUNT THAT'S
AVAILABLE SO IT'S- IF IT'S- A
THREE POINT ONE RAINY DAY EIGHT
POINT TWO BASS WHAT'S THE ONE
TIME. NUMBER TOTAL AVAILABLE
FUNDING. RIGHT SO I CAN. TAKE A
QUICK STAB AT THAT I KNOW IT
IT'S CONFUSING PARTICULARLY WITH
WITH THE- RAINY DAY FUND
DEPOSITS- IN EACH YEAR BECAUSE
THOSE ARE YOU KNOW WE COUNT
THOSE AS NO THERE ARE NO THERE'S
SOME SORT OF SETTLE UP THERE
THAT CONFUSES IT BUT I'M STILL
JUST FOCUSED ON NEXT YEAR FROM
NOW. AND I KNOW THE BE SETTLE UP
FOR EVERYTHING AT SOME POINT BUT
WE HAVE DECISIONS TO MAKE AND
I'M JUST WONDERING WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS AVAILABLE IN EACH
BUCKET. RIGHT SO OUR OUR BUDGET
DOES PROPOSE. JUST NORTH OF SIX
BILLION DOLLARS IN IN ONE TIME
FUNDING AND THEN WE HAVE- SOME.
ONGOING FUNDS IN ADDITION TO
THAT THAT WE THAT WE USED TO.
FINE ON FOR A- ONE FOR ONE TME
PRIORITIES SO I THINK THE
NUMBERS YOU CITED ARE ARE
CORRECT DOES THAT MEAN I'M SORRY
TO STICK TO THIS BUT DOES THAT
MEAN IT'S A REALLY SIX POINT TWO
ROUGHLY AVAILABLE IN ONE TIME
MONEY THAT'S WHAT THE NUMBER IS
OF TOTAL AVAILABLE AND ONE TIME
UNDER PROP NINETY EIGHT. THE
TOTAL OF PROGRAMS THAT ARE
RECOMMENDED. IN CHARGED IT'S A
LITTLE LATER IN OUR GENDER HERE
IS SIX. POINT ONE SIX NINE
BILLION AND I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND IS THAT THE TOTAL OF
ONE TIME MONEY THAT IS AVAILABLE
OR IS THAT A DIFFERENT NUMBER-
SO DONT NUMBER WHAT INCLUDES
SOME FUNDING SOMEBODY WONDERING
THAT'S FROM THE ON GOING I'M
RUNNING ALONG. WITH HIM BECAUSE
WE DO WE LIKE TO HAVE THAT
CUSHION. OKAY YOU YOU VERY
CLEARLY CONFUSED AT. IT AND SO
WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO AS WE HEAD
TOWARD MAY. I'M TRYING T LOOK
AT WHAT THE TOTAL AMOUNT IS
THAT'S AVAILABLE. THE A. N. IT'S
EIGHT POINT TWO BILLION BASE
THREE POINT ONE BILLION GOES
INTO THE RAINY DAY. WHAT'S LEFT
IN ONE TIME MONEY AND YOU DON'T
HAVE TO ANSWER IT NOW BECAUSE I
HAVE A SNEAKING SUSPICION YOU
DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER RIGHT NOW
BUT IF YOU COULD GET YOUR HOUSE.
PERHAPS- IT KEVIN CAN MAY BE
ABLE TO HELP ME OUT HERE AS WELL
. PER USUAL. YEAH SO I CAN
RESULT ON TO PLEASE RESPOND TO
ERIN'S HOPE. YEAH YOU MISTER
GENERAL MY BEST DIDN'T DOES
SPEND ALL OF THE MONEY THAT'S
AVAILABLE THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GUARANTEE FOR PROGRAMS
THERE ISN'T ANY AMOUNT WITHIN
THE GUARANTEE THAT'S NOT SPENT
FOR SOMETHING IN THEIR NEW
PROPOSAL OR A REQUIRED
ALLOCATION LIKE THE PROPOSITION
AND YOU DESERVE DEPOSIT. SO THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF NEW PROGRAMS A
SEVENTEEN POINT SEVEN BILLION-
THE GOVERNOR- PROPOSES- THE
SPLIT IS TEN POINT SIX BILLION
FOR ONGOING AUGMENTATIONS AND
SEVENTEEN SEVEN POINT TWO
BILLION FR ONE TIME BY ABOUT
ONE BILLION OF THE ONE TIME
PROPOSALS COULD BE CONVERTED TO
ONGOING AT THE LEGISLATURE CHOSE
TO DO THAT- AS AARON SAID THERE
IS- REASONS NOT TO DO THAT.
BECAUSE THAT WOULD REDUCE YOUR
BUDGET QUESTION BUT ESSENTIALLY
I THINK THE WAY I THINK ABOUT IT
IS THAT THERE IS SIX POINT TWO
BILLION OR SO THAT HAS TO BE
SPENT THAT CAN ONLY BE CENTER ON
GO FOR ONE TIME AND IT'S AN
ADDITIONAL BILLION IN ONGOING
MONEY THAT SPENT ON ONE TIME.
PURPOSES AND THEN THE REST. TEN
POINT SIX BILLION IS ALL ONGOING
MONEY SPENT ON ONGOING
ACTIVITIES. I THINK UP DISCUSS
ON OFF I THINK THAT'S HELPFUL-
THE END YOU KNOW YOU OPEN THE
DOOR AND ONE OTHER THING AND WE
HAVE TO MOVE ON SO I DON'T WANT
TO GET LOST IN THE WEEDS AND YOU
OPEN THE DOOR SAY NEW FOR FUND
THE NEW PROGRAMS BUT IT'S THAT
THAT OPENS THE DOOR ABOUT
WHETHER THERE'S THINGS WERE NOT
DOING OR TAKING MONEY THAT WE'RE
NOT DOING AND MOVING IT TO NEW
PROGRAMS AND SO THAT'S NOT THE
TOTAL AMOUNT NECESSARILY THAT'S
AVAILABLE YEAR TO YEAR. IN A
DIFFERENCE AND SO I'M GONNA
ENDED HERE OR ELSE WE WILL SPEND
FOR A WHILE BUT I THINK AS WE
HEAD TOWARD. MAY WE JUST WANNA
HAVE A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF
YEAR TO YEAR. WHAT THE CHANGES
IN YEAR TO YEAR WHAT'S AVAILABLE
AND OF COURSE WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE THE DEBATE ON ALL THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS. ARE BUT I
THINK HAVING THE GLOBAL SENSE OF
WHAT'S IN THERE IT IS COULD BE A
THING THAT'S GOING TO HELP US.
SO ANYWAY. IF THAT REQUIRES AN
OUT OF HEARING ADDITIONAL
SUPPLEMENTAL INFORMATION WE
WOULD APPRECIATE IT. SO WHAT ME
JUST ASK MY COLLEAGUES IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS HERE.
SENATOR MATT I HAVE A QUESTION
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME. IS THAT
MAKE THIS STATEMENT- THAT I
WOULD ECHO. AND LOG THE L. A.
O.'S COMMENTS- I HAD SIMILAR
CONCERNS PARTICULARLY WITH. THE
FAIRLY MASSIVE EXPANSION OF
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
PROGRAM AND I WAS CONCERNED.
THAT THIS WOULD EFFECTIVELY
CREATE SOME SIGNIFICANT ONGOING
LIABILITIES FOR THE STATE THAT.
WE HAVE NOT REALLY FACTORED IN
SO THAT WAS JUST SOMETHING THAT
STUCK OUT TO ME BUT IT DID SEEM
LIKE WE'RE ADDING A LOT OF NEW
OBLIGATIONS- WITHOUT JUSTIFYING
WHY THESE. WERE NEEDED AS
OPPOSED TO JUST INCREASES AND-
YOU KNOW PROP NINETY FUNDING
BUT- I THINK YOU WERE GOING TO
THE STORE BUT THE CLINIC. THE
NEXT. OKAY I'M I'M SORT TO
SECOND PLACE YOUR- AND- SENATOR
OVER YOUR ANY COM. OKAY AND I
THINK YOU FOR WHAT YOU MAY JUST
HAVE BEEN A ME HOPING TO TALK
ABOUT THE AND TO EIGHTY EIGHT IN
THIS ITEM IS COMING UP TO.
THANKS FAR WE PREFER BOTH OF YOU
- AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO.
OUR LAST ISSUE ISSUE. REDUCE OF
OUR SOME TIME FOR WE HAVE TO WE
THAT A QUARTER TWELVE FOR PAR
COMMENT. BUT I KNOW THIS IS A-
SO. MATTER THE LOCAL CONTROL.
FOR DOES AT FIFTEEN OF YOU HERE
AKRON AFTER- IN OUR PANELISTS
MICHAEL. FROM THE- FIFTH CRISIS
IN MAY IS. TEAM GRAHAM FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MICHAEL
AFFAIRS FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND MERRY
NICELY FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. AND IF IT TURNS OUT
THERE'S OTHER PEOPLE
SUBSTITUTING IN WE'LL JUST
HANDLE IT WHEN THEY GET HERE AND
WE'LL START WITH MICHAEL FONG.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. GOOD
MORNING SHARES AND SANDERS- MY
PLEASURE TO WITH YOU MICHAEL
FINDS COULD CHECK OFFICER OF THE
STATE STREET CRISIS IN NINETEEN
SYSTEM SPEAKING. I'M GOING TO.
MY OUT ON THE WE WANT TO THROUGH
THE HIGHLIGHTS OF THAT HERE OUT
ALONG THE WAY- THEY'LL BE A
LITTLE BIT- ON- THE GOVERNOR'S
BY AND HOW THE JUST. A DISTRICT
SHOULD ARAMBULA THE PROPER-
FIRST POSSIBLY- AND HOW IT WOULD
BE- GENERALLY SPEAKING ALSO YOU
CAN ACROSS THIS- AND IN MY WORK
WE'LL SEE YOU AT ALL. NEWS
TRYING- ONLY TO GET BETTER- THE
GOVERNOR BUT WHEN YOU FACTOR IN
GOVERNOR'S CAMPAIGN BUDGET- WE
DO HAVE A DIDN'T IN OHIO THOSE
AS WE- THE FOR PAGE OF THE
HANDOUT THAT I WOULD REACHING
THE A SLIGHT. FORTY SHOULD
RESTORE QUAL MAYBE- A REPORT
YOUR CASE. AS THE COMMUNITIES
AWARE- THAT STARTS YOU JULY.
WHEN A LOCAL. WITH THEIR- BUT
SHOULD EARNS DISTRICTS ABOUT TO
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS WILL
REVIEW. WORKING WHICH IS UP
THROUGH OCTOBER DIæN DECEMBER
SECOND REPORTING THROUGH JANUARY
DONALD MARCHING ABOUT POINT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT SOME SURPRISE
THAT HISTORIC MISSION- HAS
POSITED QUALIFIED OR NEGATIVE.
SOMERS ROLE IN CVR SERVED IN THE
SMALL TOWN OFFICE AND DISTRICTS
- IS TO. SIMPLY CAN OR NOT
CONFIRM OFFICER. AND SO ABOUT
PROCESS IS COMPLETED AND THE
DATA I SHOWING FROM- STOP YEAH
AS YOU COULD ON THIS IS CHART
AND YOUR TO THE LACK THREE A BAR
. WE BACK UP YEAR TO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE FIRST A ROOM WITH
TWO WALL DISTRICT. THREE EIGHTY.
REPORTED LAST WITH A FIFTY AND
THAT SHOULD BOTH NUMBER ARE IS A
DIRECT REPLY OF LAST YEAR AND
AGAIN TWENTY ONE ONES PROPOSAL
AND THE ELEMENTS OF PROPOSAL
THAT WORK INTO DISTRICT OUR
ORANGE PLANNING. AS WE PROGRESS
FORWARD TO THIS- WE SHOULD AT
TWENTY THREE. AND THREE NAY AND
FOR BOTH OF THE YOU- IN JUST A
BEFORE I DO THAT WELL I WANT TO
CHECK BACK THE BUDGET PROCESS
THE IN STRONG TOMORROW- THIS ALL
WE HAVE TO DO SPOKESMAN LOS
ANGELES. WHO HAVE THEIR
PULMONARY DESTROY BY COUNTY SHE
- THAT WOULD BE THE SAME GROUP
LONG OUR- AND THE ONLY WOULD
UNIFY SCHOOL THE SO NOW BEEN.
BOTH BUDGETS WERE- WERE. THE
REPORT JUST LIFE WILL BE DIVE ON
HIS QUALIFY IN REPORTS TO
TWENTY. BOB DESTROY- MAC IN A-
THESE AND R. ALONG STUDENTS-
RATIONAL FOR ALL- SEVERITY IS
WHEN YOU HAVE TO KIDS QUALIFY
REPORTS AND WE CAN DO DIVE. INTO
A GOING ON THERE YOU CAN SEE
THAT THERE ARE JUST WOULD THREE
MORE CONSTRUCTING REPORT ONE
EIGHT FOUR THAT WOULD BE- SHE'S
UNIFIED SCHOOL IN SAN DIEGO AND
ONE OF MY WHICH SHOULD- UNIFIED
SCHOOLS. EIGHT OF THE TWENTY AS
YOU SEE ON THE SITE. ARE THIS IS
THE FIRST WALL GROUP- AND THAT
IS NOT- EXACTLY. ONLY WHILE
LOLITA ACTUALLY WENT CASH
NEGATIVE IN OCTOBER HAS BEEN
SUFFICIENT CASH TO MEET PAYROLL-
AS OPPOSED TO COMING IMMEDIATELY
TO THE LEGISLATURE FORTY BAIL
OUT OF THE RETURN TO COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT WHO PROVIDED
SUFFICIENT CASH RESOURCES FOR
ONE JUNIPERO. CONTINUE TO BILLS
THROUGH JANUARY- AND AT THIS
POINT BY THE DISTRICT IS STABLE-
ARE YOU HAVE TOPIC WE WERE
CAMPED IN WITH DOCTOR LEE
SIGNIFICANT ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
BUDGET STARTING JULY ONE- AND
THEY ARE ON TRACK TO DO THAT. WE
THE- DISTRESS IN READING IS NOT
OVER YET AS WE ARE CURRENTLY
FORECASTING CASH MAYBE WE CAN IN
JUNE- AND WE'RE WORKING ON A
SOLUTION FOR THAT RIGHT NOW
WITHOUT THE NEED FOR A STATE. OF
EMERGENCY CORPORATION. THE
SECOND DISTRICT ALL SMALL BUT
SACRAMENTO COUNTY BURKE CHAU-
JOY. OF SCHOOL DISTRICT- THIS IS
GIVEN A- DISTRESSED AND CHARTERS
. SHOULD CHARGE THAT WITHIN THIS
BUT AS FAR OF THIS DISTRICT- AND
THAT SCHOOLS EXPERIENCE YOU
DESTROY LOS OR MY- AS FIFTY THIS
THIS RANGING AND THIS USE ALSO
DOCTOR SPEND. WILL NEED THOSE
USER WE ARE ABOUT TO THEIR ON
BEHALF. AND WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSALS ABLE LEADER
THEY WILL CLOSE THE REMAINING.
GAP BOB FOR THE NEXT YEAR A
LIKELY SECOND ROUND BEING
REMOVED FROM MAYBE CERTAINLY
QUALIFIED MAYBE EVEN AS EARLY
CHAU ARE ALWAYS POSSIBLE. SENSES
I INDICATED WHEN THEY'RE LOOKING
AT THE ENORMOUS COURTS HAVE THE
OPTION TO CONCUR OR NON CONCUR
WITH THE DISTRICTS OBSERVATION
ONE ACCOUNT THERE'S NOT. GOING
TO PRETEND IS NOT FOR ALL THAT
GALLERY IN CERTIFICATION WILL
HAVE ONE OF THOSE IN DECEMBER
DISTRICTS A POSITIVE
CERTIFICATION COUNTY OFFICE DID
NOT AGREE AND CHANGED IT TO
QUALIFY THAT WOULD BE CALAVERAS
UNIFIED IN CALAVERAS COUNTY-
SUBSEQUENT IN PERSON DIGITAL
PROOF OF COFFEE FARMING IT
REMAINED. THAT WAS NOT INCLUDED
IN THEIR FIRST IN OUR
PROJECTIONS AND- COST MORE THAN
WHAT THE ESTIMATED SHIP. WE HAVE
CONFIDENCE AT THIS POINT DON'T
TAKE THE MASTER CORRECTIVE.
ACTION IN COMING MONTHS. SO I
EIGHT- IDENTIFIES THE OCT PLANS
YOU PROJECT SHALL WHEN WAS HOW
SIX GEN LAST. FALL WITH REGARD
TO DISTRICT LET ME SHOWING-
MEDIA SIGNS OF DISTRESS. HE'S OF
AT THE OR SECOND PANORAMIC THE-
AGENCIES DO YOU HAVE YEAH. TWO
DOZEN IT JUST LACK GOING TO. IN
IMMEDIATELY. A. YOU SHARKS FONG
ON SLIDE EIGHT TIERED SHOWING
THE RESEARCH HAS OF THAT. WHAT
IS- SO IN IN THE HALL THIS PAST
. IS THAT WE HAVE- DISTRICTS.
WELL WHICH IS NOT HIGH- WE ARE
YEARS OR TE ARE QUESTION
COMPLETE THIS WILL BE. JUNE
WHERE THE DATA THAT IS FOR HERE
IN THE TO ONE TWENTY TWO BAR IS
FROM EARLY DECEMBER. THERE'S A
VARIETY OF BOTH BUDGET AND NON
BUDGET. ISSUES ARE IN PLAY IN
THESE DISTRICTS- MAYBE
LEADERSHIP MAY BE- LACK OF
INTERNAL CONTROLS IT MAY BE A
LACK OF ADEQUATE REPORTING TO
THEIR COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
SOLUTION FOR IDEA. OF REASONS
FOR THESE DESIGNATIONS AND WE
ARE ENGAGED. ONE ALL BUT ONE OF
THESE AND WE WILL BE IN THAT
DISTRICT ARE ACTUALLY ALL THAT
YOU WILL BE IN ONE. OF THOSE UP
HERE SHORTLY. NINE IS ACTIVE
WHERE ONE IS A LITTLE BIT IT'S
AND STEPS OF FOR THE COPPER.
THAT WE IN THE FIND. WILL HAVE A
YOUR MONITOR. THE NEXT SOLVENTS
TREND. OF MULTI YOUR- DO SHOW
SOME TRAINS BOB. GOVERNOR'S
TENTH BUDGET SPECIFICALLY CENTER
TO YOUR QUITE AMONG AGO WITH
SIGNAL DELEO ABOUT THE MESSAGES
CORPORATE- SENATE BEING AUGUST
ACTUALLY CALL POLICE NOW
INVESTMENT IN THE GOVERNOR'S.
AVERAGE YEARLY FROM. ANY IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION BASED ON THE
SO THREE CORPORATE ALLEN. A LOAN
WILL CHANGE THE TREND FOR ABOUT
HALF OF THE CALL DO SUGGESTED
FIVE TURNED. EIGHT NUMBER ONE IN
THE NAVY DISTRICTS WEST CONTRA
COSTA UNIFIED WE ARE MOST LIKELY
TO GET- COUNTY QUALIFY WITH MY
POSITIVE WANT FACTORED
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS IN JUNIOR
MULTI YEAR FINANCIAL. PLANS THE
MOST FREE CONDITION AMONG UNIONS
ONE QUALIFY STATUS IS DECLINING
IN. BONTA YOU FOR APPRECIATE
RELATED THAT AS ABA SO WE
EXPERIENCE DECLINING AVERAGED
CAN REVIEW WHY SHOULD HAVE TO
KIDS SIR AND ONE IS THE
ATTENDANCE SO IS. DID MANAGE- WE
ARE IN AN ENVIRONMENT HAVE BEEN
FOR- WELL OVER A DECADE ALMOST
TWO DECADES OF DECLINING
ENROLLMENT. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FORECASTS THAT TRYING TO
CONTINUE FOR THE NEXT SEVERAL
DECADES THIS IS NOT A NEW. ISSUE
FOR SHE WHAT IS EW BOB AS THE
COMMITTEE IS WELL AWARE VISIT
THE PANDEMIC. SOLAR IN THE RATE
OF DECLINE NUMBER ONE. AND
NUMBER TWO IS THAT WORKS HERE
AND SHE BARELY DRAMATIC.
DECREASES IN ATTENDANCE RATES
FROM THE MID NINETIES AND LOW
NINETIES AND EIGHTIES BOB AND
MANY MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. YOU REDUCE
A THIRD. IN OUT OF HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT COMPUTER IT. IS
REASON AND STRONG HELP PRO. WHAT
IT DOES. WITH IT SHOULD SAY.
MANY MANY DISTRICTS FACING A
WHAT WE WERE CALLING IT CLIFF ON
JULY. THEY WOULD- ERASED A
DECLINE IN FUNDING YOU YEAH.
FROM THERE DECLINES THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS BOB PADA GAME ON
JULY. TWENTY TWO WHAT THE
GOVERNOR SPOKE DOES IS CHANGES
THE CHARACTERISTIC BACK CLICK TO
MORE OF A GRADUAL SLOPE. YEAH WE
DISTRICTS TIME TO REACT- CHU YOU
WANT THOSE. EARLIER MATIC
CHANGES IN ABA BIBLE REASONS-
THE GOVERNOR'S APPROACH USES
EXISTING DATA WHICH IS REALLY
IMPORTANT- CONSISTENT KNOWN DATA
AND PROCESS. BY USING RESISTING
ABA IT IS OPERATIONAL IT CAN BE
OPERATIONALIZED. ARE RELATIVELY
SIMPLY- IT IS ALREADY SUBJECT
AUDIT CONTINUE TO BE SUBJECT ON
IT SO IT DOESN'T- WE DON'T
INTRODUCED A NEW AUDIT
REQUIREMENTS THAT PROCESS IS I
INDICATED ADVICE TIME- I'M
LIFEGUARDS JUSTIN. GREATER OF
ONE YEAR OR PRIOR YEAR WHICH
GIVES YOU ONE YEAR TIME IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT FOR DISTRICTS TO
REDUCE THE COST EQUAL TO THE
REVENUE. IN JUST ONE YEAR. THERE
VERY FORTY ENGLISH CERTAINLY
DISTINCT FROM SOME LEGISLATING.
ARE THERE ON THE TALK. IS IT NOT
PER. PROBLEM SINCE WITH- FONG
AFRO EQUATION DO A DOCTOR ENERGY
DISTRICTS THAT ARE STILL GROWING
- IN THE IN THIS. FARM BY A
GROUP OF THE OUT OUR COMPONENTS
YOU FORM. THOSE OF. WHILE YOU
TO. THE HIGHER NUMBER OF.
ADDITIONAL THAT WE SHOULD THE-
INCLUDE OUT IN DISTRESS AROUND.
ONE TIME IS. HIT ALL THE ONE
TIME MONEY THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THAT THE GOVERNMENT ABOUT CAL
SCHOOLS IS. SOME OF THEIRS
DEFICIT. AND SO AS THE FAX IT.
FOR EXPAND THOSE WANT FINE- WILL
BEGIN TO SEE DOES PRE EXISTING
STRUCTURAL DEFICITS COME BACK IN
JUNE WHY. I'M BEING THOSE
OUTLIERS VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE. EMPLOYER- SHE'S A PENSION
ISSUES THE ARE SO UP WITH THE
TREND AS WELL- ANSWER IN YOUR ON
THE COSTS THIS BUT- WHETHER IT'S
FOOD YOUR FOR. THE OPRAH TO. SO
COSTS OF THE ARE IN. BY. BRIEFLY
ON SLIDE AND I OUT NOT ON AB.
FORTY FOR. THESE ARE FOR YOU'VE
GOT. AND MISTER FUN ARE REALLY
HAD TO INTERRUPT BUT- WE DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF TIME LIFE FOR THE
DISCUSSION AND THE OTHER.
ANALYSTS AND IF YOU CAN YEAH IF
YOU HAVE ANYTHING ELSE IMPORTANT
ON A SET POINT SAID YOU HAVE MY
HAND OUT AND I'LL STOP WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS F.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS NEXT TO
SELENA. GRANT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK YOU
IN A GREAT OF FINE IT FUNNY GOOD
MORNING AGAIN. AND MEMBERS- I'LL
BE PROVIDING A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE GOVERNORS. OF BUDGET MAJOR
K. THROUGH TWELVE SPENDING
PROPOSALS BEGINNING WITH THE L.
C. FF SO. IN THE BUDGET YEAR THE
LCF GREW BY TWO POINT ONE
BILLION AND THAT COMPARES THE
BUDGET YEAR TO THE REVISED
CURRENT YEAR. OVER WHERE WE
KNOW- NOW THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO LANDED ADMINISTRATION IS
PROVIDING AN ADDITIONAL. TWO
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS AND
THAT'S MOSTLY A REFLECTION OF
THE FIVE POINT 33% COLA. TO
SIGNIFICANT AND IN SPITE OF THAT
EDA DECLINE THAT WE ARE
PROJECTING AND ON THAT ADAT
KLEIN IS. FOR ALL CFS ONLY- AND
AS MENTIONED BY MR FINE EARLIER
THE ADMINISTRATION. HAS
RECOGNIZED AT THE MOMENT
DECLINES- HAVE BEEN IMPACTING
DISTRICTS IN RECENT YEARS AND
EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC- WITH
THE DECLINING BIRTHRATES. SO IN
LIGHT OF THIS THE BUDGET
PERMANENTLY AMENDS THE LCF
CALCULATION TO PROVIDE. THE
GREATER OF A SCHOOL DISTRICT'S
CURRENT YEAR PRIOR YEAR OR THE
AVERAGE OF THREE PRIOR YEARS
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE. AND
THAT FORMULA CHANGE- IS INTENDED
TO HELP INSULATE DISTRICTS FROM
SUCH LARGE YEAR TO YEAR SWINGS.
THAT MANY ARE ANTICIPATING IN.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
BEYOND IF NO ACTION IS TAKEN. WE
ON COSTA. WITH THIS CHAIN IS
ESTIMATED AT ONE POINT TWO
BILLION. FOR A TOTAL OF THREE
POINT THREE BILLION INCREASED
THE LCF RELATIVE TO THE BUDGET
ACT. AND THEN- IN ADDITION TO
THE COST INCREASE PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED- WITH THE INCREASED
I'LL SEE IF I FUNDING FROM
TAKING EXPANSION THAT MY
COLLEAGUE. MISTER HURT HER READY
UP MENSCH MENTIONED THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. ALSO PROPOSES
A SEPARATE THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THREE MILLION AND PROP
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR T.
K. AND TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
AND THAT WILL HELP ELEAZAR
REDUCE ADULT TO STUDENT RATIOS
TWO ONE ADULT TO TWELVE PUPILS
PER TEACHER A CLASSROOM AND THAT
IS PURSUANT TO STATUTE. FINALLY
I WANTED TO BRIEFLY MENTIONED
THAT IT WAS BROUGHT TO OUR
ATTENTION THAT THERE WAS AN
ERROR IN OUR BIG BASS LINE
PROPERTY TAX ESTIMATES USED FOR
LC ABAFT. THAT TOTALS
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION ACROSS THREE YEARS AND
COSTS THAT WERE INADVERTENTLY
NOT REFLECTED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. HOWEVER THIS WILL NOT.
HAVE RESULT IN ANY IMPACT
ELEAZAR NOR WAS THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT. GUARANTEE
CALCULATED INCORRECTLY- AND WE
WILL DEFINITELY REVISED THAT IS
PART OF THE MAY REVISION. I'M IN
THAT CONCLUDES MY PRESENTATION
AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WHO WILL MOVE
TO MICHAEL R. FERRIS FROM THE
TELESALES OFFICE. THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORNING AGAIN MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
CONFIDENCE IN THE L. L. GANCE-
WE RECENTLY PUBLISHED A POST AND
PRINT ON OUR WEBSITE FOR YOUR
REFERENCE THAT COVERS THE- K.
FOURTEEN COAL AS WELL AS A
PROPOSED ATTENDANCE DISMANTLE
THE OFFENSE. I THINK MISS GRANT
AND MR FIND GIVE A GOOD SUMMARY.
SO JUST KEEP OUR COMMENTS HERE
AT A HIGH LEVEL- REGARDING THE
COLOR WE UPDATED OUR ESTIMATE
USING RECENTLY RELEASED FEDERAL
DATA. WE FOUND THAT THE COLOR IT
WILL LIKELY BE 1% HIGHER AND ME
AND THE FIVE POINT THREE THREE
PERCENT. BUT IN THE BUDGET
SPECIFICALLY. BETWEEN THE
COLORING FOR TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE WILL BE CLOSER TO SIX
POINT SEVENTEEN PERCENT.
REFLECTING A HIGHER INFLATION IN
RECENT MONTHS- COMPARED TO WHAT
IS IN THE BUDGET DOES HER COLOR
WOULD TRANSLATE TO A FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR MILLION. FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE
TO OVERALL CFF. ANDY FIFTY SIX
MILLION INCREASE FOR K. TWELVE
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS. OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL RELEASE
THE FINAL DATA USED TO CALCULATE
THE COLON APRIL SO. IS SUBJECT
TO CHANGE. OCT PEROT GUARDING
THE- ADJUSTMENTS DEFINING MOMENT
- WE RECKON THE ALLEGE. APPROVED
GOVERNOR PROPOSAL. BETWEEN
DIFFERENT. WOULD ADDRESS FOR
TEMPERANCE. ABOUT DROPPED IN
FRONT DUE TO THE- OF HARMON'S
POLICY EXPIRING THE BUDGET YEAR.
WHICH HAS BEEN EXACERBATED FROM
THE CHALLENGES DISTRICTS THAT
FACE FROM THE PANDEMIC. WOOD
MISTER FINE- DESCRIBED AS THE
FISCAL CLIFF AND HIS COMMENTS.
YES THINK THIS PROPOSED IS A
GOOD FOR THE LONG TERM. FOR THE
SAME REASONS MISTER PRIME OUT IN
HIS COMMENTS. WELL THINK THE
PROPOSAL COULD PROMOTES FISCAL
STABILITY FOR DISTRICTS WHO HAVE
BEEN EXPERIENCING IS A FAMILY
PLANS. ENROLLMENT BY SOFTENING
DECLINES IN FUNDING- THIS WOULD
ALLOW THEM MORE TIME TO ADJUST
AND RIGHT SIZE THEIR EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMMING FOR THE REMAINING
STUDENTS. ADDITIONALLY UNDER
UNDER THIS PROPOSAL DISTRICTS
THAT ARE GROWING WILL CONTINUE
TO RECEIVE INCREASES AND THEY
ALSO HAVE A FUNDING FOR THE
STUDENTS. WE WOULD NOTE THAT
THESE CHANGES WOULD ONLY BE MADE
CELLS YES OF FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. AND NOT FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS. THE GOVERNOR DOES NOT
PROPOSE ANY SPECIFIC US IF OF
CHANGES FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS. BUT
IN THE CASE OF THE MINISTRATION
WILL EXPLORE OPTIONS IN THE
SPRING. FOR AN ATTENDANCE.
ADJUSTMENT FOR THEM- WE THINK
THE GOVERNOR'S TRY TO STUDY.
ATTENDANCE OF. AS THIS WOULD
HELP I DON'T VERY OPTIONS THE
LEGISLATURE TO- HOWEVER UNLIKE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CHARTERS. WITH
THE PROSPECT OF IMMEDIATE
FUNDING REDUCTIONS BASED ON
ATTENDANCE DECLINES. AT THE
EXPERIENCE IN THE CURRENT YEAR
TO THE PANDEMIC. ON WHICH ARE
THE SAME ISSUES THAT DISTRICTS
UP BASED. ON THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER PROVIDE.
PROVIDING SOME TYPE OF TEMPORARY
JUST MEANT TO OFFSET FUNDING
DECLINES IN THE CURRENT YEAR-
ONE OPTION COULD BE TO ALLOW
CHARTER SCHOOLS TO RECEIVE
FUNDING BASED ON THE GROUP AND
THEN THE GOOD THING THIS FOR
ANOTHER YEAR. THIS WITH A
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION. MORE TIME TO
EXAMINE LONGER TERM
ALTERNATIVES. ALL THAT CONCLUDES
OUR COMMENTS. HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
. AND THEN WILL MOVE TO MARRIED-
NICELY FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. THANK YOU MMHM
THEY'RE HANDLED KEEP MY REMARKS
BRIEF- SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT- AS THE S.
B. I SHARED IN HIS OVERVIEW WE
ARE THANKFUL THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS KEEPING
EDUCATION AS A KEY PRIORITY IN
THE BUDGET AND PANDEMIC
CONTINUES TO CREATE
EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGES FOR OUR
STUDENTS FAMILIES AND EDUCATORS
ARE DISTRICTS ARE FACED WITH
SOME SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
DURING THESE VERY DIFFICULT
TIMES. WE HAVE GENERALLY HER
CONCERNS AROUND GROWING PENSION
COSTS A STAFFING ALSO REMAINS A
HUGE CHALLENGE IN THE FIELD AND
THEY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT BEING
ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENT
PROGRAMS UP WHILE TRYING TO
ATTRACT QUALIFIED STAFF AND OF
COURSE THERE ARE CONCERNS AROUND
ENROLLMENT AND EIGHTY EIGHT IN
LIGHT OF THE PREVALENCE OF
OMICRON WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO KEEP THESE ISSUES IN MIND
WHEN EVALUATING THE HISTORICAL
LOOK AND OTHER LCF RELATED
NEEDS. I HAVE WITH ME ELIZABETH
YOUR STEAM DIRECTOR OF CDC'S
SCHOOL FISCAL SERVICES TO ASSIST
IN ANSWERING QUESTIONS. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ARE WE
APPRECIATE ALL THESE
PRESENTATIONS AND- LET ME LEAD
WITH A FEW QUESTIONS OF FIRST.
THIS IS A FOLLOW UP TO SOMETHING
THAT WAS MADE BY MS GRANT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ARE YOU
MENTIONED- A SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR JUDGMENT IT
NEEDED TO B MADE FOR SOMETHING
QUESTION INCLUDED NEW LISTED ALL
THE THINGS THAT IT WOULDN'T
AFFECT OUR WHAT WOULD IT AFFECT.
I MEAN WHAT WILL BE THE NET
EFFECT OF READJUSTING THAT
CORRECTLY. DID YOU WANT ME TO
RESPOND YES PLEASE. OKAY IT
DOESN'T HAVE IT HAS LIKE I
MENTIONED NO EFFECT ON ELEAZAR
IT JUST IT'S WITHIN THE
GUARANTEE SO THE WAY THAT WE
DISTRIBUTE OUR FUNDING WILL HAVE
TO BE REASSESSED- THE AMOUNT
AVAILABLE TO- NEW AND ONGOING
PROGRAMS WILL HAVE TO BE
RECALCULATED BUT IT'S
RECALCULATED ANYHOW WHEN WE GET
THE REVENUES AT THE MAY REVISION
. I GUESS WHAT I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS IT BECAUSE OF
THIS IS THAT RECALCULATED DOWN
OR IS IT RECALCULATED UP I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THAT
EFFECTIVE THIS. SURE NO IT'S I
UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION SO MAYBE
IT LEMME COUNTED IN TWO WAYS-
AND AREA BERMAN FINANCE AGAIN-
SO BURKE FOR ONE LIKE- LENA
MENTION IN HER IN HER COMMENTS
THE CORRECT PROPERTY TAXES WERE
USED FOR PURPOSES OF CALCULATING
THE MINIMUM GUARANTEES SO THE
GUARANTEE WAS CALCULATED AT THE
CORRECT LEVEL SO THAT WILL THAT
WILL BE ADJUSTED ON THE NATURAL
JUST YOU KNOW BECAUSETHAT'S HOW
THE MAYOR VISION WORKS WE GET
UPDATED FACTORS BUT THAT'S
UNRELATED TO THIS. SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION THE L. C. A FAST COSTS
WERE CALCULATED ASSUMING SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION MORE AN
OFFSETTING PROPERTY TAXES ACROSS
THE THREE YEARS SO IF ONE WERE
TO ASSUME ALL OTHER THINGS HELD
CONSTANT WE NOW IN THE MAYOR
VISION WHICH WE KNOW WILL NOT BE
THE CASE BUT WERE THAT TO BE SO
THEN TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTIN WE
WOULD HAVE TO- REDUCE SPENDING
IN OTHER AREAS RIGHT OUTSIDE OF
LCF ASKED. TO ACCOUNT FOR THAT
COST THAT WAS NOT APPROPRIATELY-
ANTICIPATED IN THOSE THREE YEARS
AND SO IF ALL THINGS DID REMAIN
CONSTANT AND I KNOW THEY WON'T
BUT WE'RE JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND IF ALL THINGS DID
REMAIN CONSTANT THERE'D HAVE TO
BE A SCALE BACK OVER THREE YEARS
OF SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
SINCE OF WHAT THE PROGRAMMING
WAS IS THAT CORRECT. THAT'S
CORRECT CUMULATIVELY SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION ONLY. THREE
HUNDRED MILLION FROM THE ONGOING
POT IN TWENTY TWELVE THIRTY JUST
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND BECAUSE IT
JUST BY. WITH THE THING THAT
WOULD AFFECT SO I WAS TRYING AND
WHAT IT WATER. THAT'S VERY
HELPFUL NOW TO THE- DISCUSSION
OF THE POWER. OF THE AVERAGE
DAILY ATTENDANCE SAID AND THE
PROPOSAL HERE- AND I DON'T KNOW
MAYBE FINANCE WITH WITH- WITH
THE L. A. COMMENTING MISTER FINE
MENTIONED THAT THERE'S ROUGHLY
THREE HUNDRED DISTRICTS THAT ARE
GROWING AND IF IT TURNS OUT
THEY'RE GROWING AT A LEVEL. THAT
THEY'RE ABOVE BAR THE ROLLING
THREE YEAR AVERAGE UNDER
PROPOSAL IT WOULD BE MORE LIKELY
THAT THEY ALL WOULD CHOOSE TO
HIRE YEAR IT WILL FINANCE IS
THAT CORRECT. I WOULD IT IT'S
NOT SO MUCH A MATTER OF CHOICE
AS- AND THE PART OF IT TO
CONFIRM BUT WHEN FUNDED EDA IS
CALCULATED AND DETERMINED IT'S
JUST WHICHEVER ONE IS GREATER
PURSUANT TO STATUTE THAT'S WHAT
THEY WOULD RECEIVE SO IT'S JUST
TERM AND INDEPENDENT OF ANY
ACTION OF THE DISTRICT THAT'S
CORRECT AND THUS FAR WHEN WE HAD
THE TWO YEAR ROLLING AVERAGE
LAST YEAR. IT DID NOT TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE GREATER OF THE TWO
DID. NO CURRENT LAW DOES SO IT'S
HISTORICALLY BEEN THE GREATER OF
THE CURRENT OR PRIOR YEAR
REPORTED ADA. OKAY THEN I HAVE A
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT IT'S VERY
CONFUSED AND I WILL HAVE TO ON
CONFUSED- AND IT. IT'S THIS
ANOMALOUS SITUATION WHERE. THE
FIRE THAT RAGED THROUGH THE
MOUNTAINS BURNED DOWN 27% OF THE
HOMES IN A SCHOOL DISTRICT
BANNER HAD A CORRESPONDING LOSS.
IN ADA AND IT MANAGED TO SHOW UP
IN AN ADJOINING DISTRICT IT
DIDN'T BURN AND THEY WERE SMALL
IT WAS- A DISPROPORTIONATE
PERCENTAGE AND THEY FELT LIKE
THEY WERE NOT GETTING REIMBURSED
FOR THEIR HIGHER ADA AND SO I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE TELLING ME IS
THEY COULD HAVE CLAIMED THE
HIGHER ADA IN THE SECOND YEAR.
FOR THE PURPOSES OF THE OF
ALLOCATION. OR YOU HAVE BEEN
TELLING ME THAT SOMEBODY WOULD
PICK THAT FOR THEM UP VOTE RIGHT
AND THEM HAVING. IT SOUNDS LIKE
THAT MAY BE A BIT OF A UNIQUE
CASE- IF YOU'RE FREE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO ENGAGE WITH THEM TO THE
EXTENT THAT IT SOUNDS LIKE A
SITUATION I THINK. WE MAY HAVE
MET WITH SOME FOLKS ABOUT
ALREADY IN THE HOME ARE YOU HAVE
WITH THE DISTRICT THAT BURNS I
DON'T KNOW THE CHIU OF MET WITH
THE DISTRICT THAT THAT HAD THE
HIGHER. AMOUNT OF ENROLLMENT AND
I KNOW BECAUSE OF WHAT HAPPENED
WITH PARADISE THERE ARE CERTAIN
THINGS THAT ARE DONE IN PLACES
THAT HAVE SUCH A MONUMENTAL
IMPACT SCHOOL DISTRICTS OVER
TIME SO THAT THEY DON'T JUST
SORT THAT LOSS BUT ON I DON'T
KNOW WHAT HAPPENS IF THERE IS.
AN IMAGINE JUST HAVING BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE RESPONSE TO THAT
FIRED THE SCHOOL. ATTENDANCE
PROBABLY WENT UP DRAMATICALLY IN
CHICO WHAT WENT DOWN
DRAMATICALLY IN PARADISE I HAVE
NO IDEA IF THERE WAS AN
ADJUSTMENT MADE TO CHICO FOR THE
HIGHER. EIGHTY EIGHT AND THEN ON
A MUCH SMALLER SCALE THIS IS THE
SAME CIRCUMSTANCE. AND SO. I AM
HAPPY TO HAVE THE DISTRICT HAD
TO GAIN AN ORAL MUCH ENGAGED
WITH YOU IF THEY HAVEN'T ARE BUT
THAT'S WHY I WAS ASKING IF. THE
IF IN THE PREVIOUS TWO YEAR
ROLLING UNDER. THE EXISTING TWO
YEAR ROLLING ONE. IF HIRE YEAR
COULD BE. THAT'S ALL I WAS OF
GET AT AND IT'S LIKE THE WAS YES
WHICH I DO KNOW. WHAT I THOUGHT
. IT WAS AT NOW THEN LET ME A
THE ON NOT QUESTION. THIS THE-
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE APPLAUDING
THIS IS A THEY FEEL LIKE IT IT
GIVES THEM A HOLD HARMLESS IN
SOME WAYS. BUT DOESN'T IT JUST
CREATE A CLIFF THAT WERE MOVING
THE CLIFF ONE YEAR OUT AND IF
THERE'S NO CHANGES AT ALL A YEAR
FROM JUNE THIRTIETH THERE'S
GOING TO BE A DRAMATIC IMPACT TO
A LOT OF DISTRICTS. I DON'T KNOW
I WOULDN'T. THINK SO- I THINK AS
AS- MISTER FINE DETAIL IN HIS
PRESENTATION REALLY WHAT IT
DOES. IS IT KIND OF AVOIDS THE
SITUATION OF THERE BEING A CLIFF
ALTOGETHER I WOULD ARGUE
BECAUSE- TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
DISTRICT IS DECLINING AND
NEEDING TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THAT VARIABLE THAT INCLUDES THE
THREE YEAR. THE THREE PRIOR YEAR
AVERAGE- THAT IS IN AFFECTS
MOVING OUT WHAT OTHERWISE MAY
HAVE BEEN A FISCAL CLIFF SO
AWESOME ALL UP. TO ME REFINE THE
QUESTION BECAUSE MAYBE ON NOT
BEING CLEAR. I GUESS WHAT IT
DOES FOR THE THREE YEARS AND IT
DOES REFINE OR OR REMOVE THE
FISCAL CLIFF. IF WE WENT BACK TO
A. D. A. WITH NO ADJUSTMENT OR
NO ROLLING AVERAGE ON JUNE
THIRTIETH A YEAR FROM NOW
PROVIDING WE ADOPTED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. I AM
ASSUMING THAT THERE WOULD BE. A
WHOLE SERIES OF DISTRICTS THAT
WOULD GO DOWN IMMEDIATELY IN
THEIR ADA AT THE END OF THOSE
THREE YEARS. AND ONE ARM ASKING.
THAT I MEAN I DON'T KNOW IF THE
PRESUMPTION IS. OVER THE NEXT
YEAR AND A HALF CONFIDENCE AND
THAT SOMEHOW MAGICALLY EVERYBODY
GOES BACK TO TWO CANADIENNE IS
SOMEWHAT SIMILAR TO WHAT
HAPPENED. AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE PANDEMIC. BUT IT'S TO ME.
THE COULD BE WRONG BUT WON'T
HAPPEN THERE WILL BE LOWERED
REMEDY A LOT OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AFTER THE END OF A
THREE YEAR ROLLING THING. THAT'S
WHAT I'M REFERRING TO IS CLIFF.
EIGHT AND I AM JUST WONDERING IF
. OUR EVERYBODY JUST CELEBRATING
GETTING SAVED NEXT YEAR AND NOT
LOOKING AT WHAT THE LONGER TERM
IMPACT MIGHT BE IF THE THREE
YEAR ROLLING FANS AFTER THREE
YEARS THAT'S WHAT I'M DRIVING AT
. OKAY YEAH RIGHT RIGHT SO IT
SOUNDS I THINK LIKE MAYBE YOUR
YOUR ALSO COMMENTING JUST ON THE
LONGER TERM TREND WE ANTICIPATE
OF ENROLLMENT EVEN. EVEN WITH
OUR CURRENT ONE NOW HAVE YOU SEE
I DO I THINK THERE IS A LONGER
TERM TREND BUT COVETOUS
XCELERATED IN IN THE SHORT TERM.
AND WE ARE MAKING A DECISION NOW
TO DO THE ROLLING THING IF WE
AGREE BY THE TIME OF THE MAY
REVISE WERE AGREEING TO DO THE
THIRD YEAR ROLLING. MOST OF THE
SCHOOLS ARE SIX REALLY WANT THAT
BECAUSE IT PROTECTS THEM AND
THEN THEY'LL COME BACK THE NEXT
YEAR AND SAY HELP US BECAUSE OF
AN OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF THEM
WILL BE DROPPING IF THE ROLLING
AVERAGE HAPPENS. I'M JUST ASKING
IF WE SHOULD HAVE A VERSION OF
THAT CONVERSATION NOW THAT THAT
THAT IS THE ISSUE BECAUSE WE ARE
MAKING THE DECISION FOR THE
THREE YEAR ROLLING AVERAGE IN
THIS BUDGET PROCESS. SO A. N. A
DON'T GET ME WRONG I DON'T HAVE
A SOLUTION- BUT I THINK A DENTAL
FONG THE PROBLEM WOULD LEAD TO A
DISCUSSION THAT MIGHT LEAD TO A
SOLUTION IF WE THINK THERE'S
SOMEWHERE THERE AND IT IS REALLY
WORTHY. OF HAVING A DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE LONG TERM ISSUE AT
SOME POINT IN THIS BUDGET
PROCESS SO IN. AN ARM I DO SEE
PEOPLE COMING ON FROM THE L. A.
O.'S OFFICE AND HEAD AND ERIN
WE'VE HAD YOU ON THE SPOT IT
DOES THE L. A. O. HAVE ANY
COMMENT TODAY WOULD LIKE TO MAKE. ABOUT THE SITUATION IS- EDGAR. BOTH OF THE THREE ARE THE
CORRECT I'LL JUST THINKING THAT
UNITED IS DEFINITELY A PURPLE
THAT IS- ALL THE CHANGES IF NOT
INTENDED TO FOR THIRTY THREE
MCCARTY. THERE IS A CLIP THERE'S
A STATE DECLINE OVER THE PAST IS
THE RESULT OF WHAT'S GOING ON IN
IN ATTENDANCE IF CAL SCHOOLS. WE
THINK THAT FOR LOW WE THINK OF
STRENGTH OF A PROPOSAL IS THAT
WE DON'T THINK THAT WE SHOULD BE
. BACK UP WHERE DOES THE TO BE
ALIGNED WITH OUR PROGRAMS AND
THE NUMBERS TO THAT ARE IN
SCHOOL. THE LONG TERM COME A OF
THEIR OF THEIR NUMBER WAYS TO
ADDRESS THAT ONE THING IS ASK
TENANTS MICHAEL CAN. OF
PRESCHOOLERS BECAUSE THE MINIMUM
IS GROWING OUR IT'S GOING BASED
ON J. FUND REVENUES FORTY ZERO
FUND REVENUES YOU THINK KEY
SOLUTION TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
. THAT HAVING THE WORST WERE THE
MINIMUM CARE GROW MEANS THE
THERE IS A DISK. FUNDING TO YOU
COULD PROVIDE INCREASE OFFICE
FOR A FAMILY OF BE FACED WITH
FIRST OVERSTAFFED WITH THE FIRST
STONE THE FIFTH TRYING TO
ATTRACT ISSUES IT DOESN'T
ADDRESS COMPLETE FOR SOME. ARE
HIRING SIGNIFICANT DECLINE- BUT
WE DO THINK KNOW OVER THE LONG
RUN TO TODAY BUT IT DOES MAKE
SOME THIRTY ALIGNED WITH THE IN
TO WHEN. THERE'S A NEW DROPS.
TWENTY DIFFERENT TACK AFTER THEM
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL SO THAT'S
PART OF WHY WE ARE LIKE PRISON
PROPOSAL THAT IT IT SOUNDS. KIND
OF SOFTEN THE IBM BUT IT DOESN'T
THAT OVER LONG RUN DISTRICTS TO
OPT IT MAKE ONLINE LET ME TO
ARMS THE OTHER TWO FROM THANK
YOU AND- IF MR FOR HIS BODY
LANGUAGE. IN LIEU OF TEST SO A
CO HE'S BEEN OR IS HEAD AT. KIND
OF THUMBS UP FOR DOWN OF ROMAN
OF VERSION OF. RESPONDING TO
PEOPLE COMMENTS FROM THEN LET ME
ASK IT AND ON UPON BECAUSE I
KNOW WE THE WHIMS AMOUNT OF-
TIME FOR THIS I'M TRY TO GET
THESE AND THE ALEJO.
THE SIMPLE
FACT THAT JUST LET YOU KNOW WHAT
THE GUARANTEE WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO SEE IF I. NUMBERS WOULD BE IF
YOU ADDED IF YOU USE THE MOMENT
BETTER. I THINK- AND IN GENERAL
DIRECTED ATTENDANCE AND TO BE A
LITTLE BIT LOWER THAN. THE
GENERAL MATHS SO YOU WOULD
EXPECT THAT WOULD BE A LITTLE
BIT HIGHER. COSTS WOULD BE
HIGHER THAN MEANS AND IF YOU IF
WANT HIGHER AND IT WAS BECAUSE
THE- ADA'S REFERRED TO AS PART
OF THE GUARANTEE IN OUR- IN OUR-
AGENDA. IF. IT WEREN'T HIGHER.
IT WILL BE ASSESSED BASED ON THE
NEWS. WITHIN THE- OF THAT'S
AVAILABLE WITH THE GARY A SECOND
. THAT'S RIGHT TO JUST THE IT
DOESN'T CHANGE THE GIVE.
MATURITY WITH THE PEOPLE THE
TIME THAT WOULD JUST BE A MATTER
OF WITHIN THAT THE OF MONEY TO
FIGHT TO SPEND MORE MONEY ON
HEALTH. PROXY YOU SPEAK. TO A
YOUR HIGHER WON'T. THE THING
THAT I AND THAT PP I SEED A BOY
. AND IN THE LAST COUPLE DAYS.
AND I MEANT THE THAT THE BIGGEST
COLDEST HONEST COULD A BILL
DOLLAR. AND THAT ALL DISTRICTS
PROBABLY SOME THAT ARE MORE.
THAT HAVE R. O. WOULD NOT GAIN
AS MUCH MOVING TO ENROLLMENT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A HIGH AVERAGE
DAILY ATTENDANCE PER. PUPILS IN
THE DISTRICT NOW. THERE WOULD BE
A REGION GERING WITH IN. THE OUR
MINIMUM BETWEEN THOSE DISTRICTS
AND THE WINNERS MIGHT BE THOSE
TO GAIN A LOT MORE IN
ENROLLMENT. BECAUSE IT IS A
FREE. BUT WHEN YOU'RE SAYING
WITHIN THE GUARANTEED DOES THAT
IMPLY THAT IT'S A FIXED PIE AND
YOU'RE REALLOCATING THE SIX PI.
OUR THROUGH A NEW SYSTEM. THAT'S
CORRECT RIGHT SO IT'S A BEEN WE
HAVE FUNDING IS THAT THE BY. THE
OVER THE LAST. DECADE THAT THE
THAT I'VE BEEN AND THE OFFICE WE
ALL FUN THE STATE OF PROJECT WAS
FUNDED AT. YOU THOUGHT IF THERE
NOT GOING CHANGE MEANS THAT.
MAKING IT HARDER TO SPEND BUT
IMPROPER. SO THERE IS A THE
AROMA WOULD A THOUGHT DEGREES.
IN WOULD PROBABLY COSTS AND WHO
WHO BENEFIT WILL DEPEND ON WHICH
CAPTAIN RATES FOR. ATTENDANCE
FOR A NORMAL. I DON'T REMEMBER
BUT I THINK WE HAVE LOT. WE
DON'T RECKON OUR B. THIRTY THAT
THE MUCH THE WANTED MOVE IN THIS
YOU THINK ABOUT OUR. AND WITH
OUR- SOME PEOPLE WERE INVOLVED
IN SOME OF THE CHANGES IN THE
WAY WE FIND FUNDED ATTENDANCE
AMENDED IT DOES CRITICALLY. THE
BIRTH DATE CURRENT OF DOES
CRITICAL SCHOOLS LIKE. FOR
SCHOOLS STUDENTS THAT STUDENTS
ARE ATTENDING CLASS ON A REGULAR
BASIS OF ALREADY PASSED AN
IMPORTANT- THE TICKET THE IN.
BIG I DID MEAN TO TAKE US TO BUT
DOES GOING TO BE A VIRGIN
DISCUSS AMONG. AND I THINK YOU
ALL HAVE TO BE READY TO SPEAK TO
IT AND IT WILL BE A NIGHTMARE
FOR ME BECAUSE I HAVE BASIC AID
DISTRICTS THAN I'VE STRONGLY
DISADVANTAGED DISTRICTS IN MY-
SENATE DISTRICT AND SOMEONE WHEN
SOMEONE LOSE IF IT'S A FIXED
PRICE AND THAT'LL BE A- A
DIFFICULT DISCUSSION. AT BRAVO
LET ME ASK OF MY COLLEAGUES IF
THEY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS.
CAR SENATOR MINUTES GOOD SENATE
ROADSHOW. BOOK AMAZING SHE GOOD
AS WELL. THE SO ARE LET ME JUST. ARE NOT BY MISTAKE THE FACT
THAT THIS WAS PREFERRED SOME OF
THE DISCUSS. FROM FACT THIS IS
OF GREATER. THAN DIFFERENT
PIECES OF THE- DISCO AND I THINK
THAT WE WILL WANT- TO. JUST WE
MOVE TOWARD. THE DAY M. P. OF
ROLLING- THE THREE ROLLING YOU
DON'T WANT WHAT IT MEANS COMING
OUT OF IT IN I SUS. THAT FOR
ALMOST CALLED WITH WE ARE AND TO
GET YOUR FEET BECAUSE WE'RE
GOING TO BE REALLY ANXIOUS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT THIS IS DONE
IN A WAY THAT'S THAT EQUITABLE
DOESN'T CREATE. DRAMA AT THE END
OF IT AND WE CAN FIGURE THAT OUT
OR WE START TO PRESS FOR
FLORIDA'S SO. I CAN JUST SAY OK
CENTER BERMAN I WOULD ECHO THE
CHAIR'S COMMENTS AND I WOULD
ONLY JUST ADD THAT- MY LACK OF
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS ON THIS
POINT IS NOT A SIGN OF
DISINTEREST BUT RATHER- IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME AND BASED ON-
THE VERY THOROUGH EXAMINATION A
LOT OF THE ISSUES I CARE ABOUT
WITH- MADE BY CHAIR LAYERED SO-
I ALSO WOULD. LIKE TO CONTINUE
TO ENGAGE ON THIS ISSUE GOING
FORWARD BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO BE
VERY IMPORTANT IN AND ONE OF THE
THINGS I REALLY WANT TO
UNDERSTAND BETTER IS TO WHAT
DEGREE ARE WE SEEING A TEMPORARY
CODE RELATED DROP OFF IN
ENROLLMENT VERSUS THE LONGER
STRUCTURAL CHANGES THAT WE SAW
BEFORE CODED- AND WHAT ARE THE
RIGHT ANSWERS HERE. BUT- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR TESTIMONY. IN
EVERYBODY- HERE FOR PUT TO PAY
ON SENATE. IT IS ONE OF THOSE
THAT I WAS ABOUT AND RAW TIME
SORT OF TO SEE OF YOU SINCE THE
VERY OF BIG DISCUSSION AND
INCOME- SO BEAR TO- THE FACT
THAT THERE WILL BE DISCUSSIONS
LET ME THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THIS IS BEEN A VERY HELPFUL AND-
INSIGHTFUL HEARING. AND WE ARE
NOW GOING TO MOVE. TO PUBLIC
COMMENT AND BEFORE I. GO TO THE
OPERATOR AND I'M GOING TO GIVE
THE OPERATORS OR ANYBODY IN THE
ROOM THAT IS GONNA WANNA COMMENT
WE HAVE TO PEOPLE. AND ARE OF A
AND BE READY. BUT LET ME ASK OF
THE OPERATOR WELCOME- AS A
REMINDER TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBERS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. AND
THE CODE IS SEVEN THREE SIX TWO
EIGHT THREE THREE. A MODERATOR
HOW MANY VIOLATED. HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE IN LINE TO- TO MAKE
CONTACTS. FIVE CURRENTLY AT THIS
TIME WE TO HAVE. SIX IN THE
QUEUE AND THEN JUST ONCE AGAIN.
MMHM IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT ON
TODAY'S CALL YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO THEN THAT USUALLY
DOUBLES AND SO WHAT I'M GONNA DO
IS I'M GOING TO HAVE A ONE
MINUTE MAXIMUM FOR THE COMMENTS
IN THE ROOM AND THE COMMENTS
THERE AND WE ARE JUST GOING TO
END AT ABOUT TWELVE FORTY FOUR
WITH THE COMMENTS SO. EXCUSE ME
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR THANK YOU A
SENATOR MAN I JUST GIVE A HEART
ATTACK- A. N. BECAUSE WE ALL
HAVE TO BE SOMEWHERE AWAY AS A
NOTE SO WE'LL BEGIN WITH
COMMENTS IN THE ROOM PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS MATT PATTON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE AUGMENTATION
TO THE ADDED INCENTIVE GRANT
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE THE
ADAMSON OF GREAT HAS BEEN THE
MODEL FOR C. INCENTIVE FUNDING.
WE ARE VERY THANKFUL FOR THIS
ARGUMENTATION WHICH IS THE FIRST
ONE IN OVER TEN YEARS I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH MEMBERS
AND STAFF TO EXPAND THAT
AUGMENTATION TO MEET THE GROWTH
IN STUDENT POPULATION AND
INFLATION. OVER THE LAST DECADE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE WILL FOR
YOUR CON WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE IN WAITINGTILL WE GOT.
PUBLIC COMMENT MARKET STEVE
CALIFORNIAN FIREMEN TECHNOLOGY
EDUCATION NETWORK- IN ALL THE
DISCUSSION OF THE CHALLENGES
RELATED TO THE PANDEMIC AND-
DISTANCE LEARNING ONE THAT HAS
NOT BEEN DISCUSSED. HAS BEEN THE
EXPOSURE OF THE DEFICIENCIES OF
THE DIGITAL SKILL SETS. OF OUR
TEACHERS OVER TEN YEARS SINCE
SERVING ON A NASA TASK FORCE. I
HAVE WATCHED SEVERAL STATES THAT
ARE PROACTIVE DEALING WITH
EMERGING DIGITAL TOOLS. GETTING
VERY THEIR CLASSROOMS AND
SCHOOLS TO EMBRACE AND ADOPT.
THESE TOOLS TO- ENHANCE LEARNING
THEIR HEARING CALIFORNIA. THE
MAJORITY OF OUR TEACHERSDON'T
EVEN KNOW THESE TOOLS EXIST.
THIS IS BEGINNING TO- OF. ALL
FROM JUST A- YEAH AFTER DE GAP
TO A WAR FORCE CA. ISSUE AND A
CONVERSATION WITH ONE OF MY
ASSOCIATES RETIRED
SUPERINTENDENT WHO'S MOVED OVER
TO THE TEACHING CREDENTIALING
PROGRAMS THAT AN ABSOLUTE SHOP
THAT THEY EXPECT THE
EXPECTATIONS FOR DIGITAL
SKILLSETS. OF FEATURES. GOING
THROUGH THEIR PROGRAMS HAVE NOT
CHANGED IN TWENTY YEARS- IN
GENERAL IF THIS LEGISLATURE PAID
THE SAME AMOUNT ATTENTION IN
ENERGY TO THIS ISSUE WE CAN
CLOSE THAT GAP IF THEY DID A
WHAT IS BEEN PAID TO. PARK
ETHNIC STUDIES THANK YOU THANK
YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
THANK YOU ALSO FOR YOUR PATIENCE
MODERATOR WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THE PHONE AND- AND PLEASE Q.
PEOPLE UP OR GOING TO LIMIT TO A
MINUTE AND- TAKE AS MANY AS. WE
CAN TAKE TO ABOUT- A FORTY TWO
OR FOUR FOUR TO COMMITTEE. AND
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE DO
HAVE SEVENTEEN CURRENTLY IN OUR
COMMENTS Q. AND WHEN YOU'RE MY
NUMBER IS CALED THE STATE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION. ONE MOMENT
THANKS WORKERS COMMON. FIND
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NINE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING THIS
IS TIFFANY MARC WOULD SEE A T. A
UNION OF EDUCATORS AND
CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS I WANT
TO THANK THE KERR COMMITTEE AND
BACK WITH HER WORK ON THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES WE THANK. FOLKS
IN SEEKING UNDERSTANDING FOR THE
TOTAL AVAILABLE ONE TIME AND
ONGOING FUNDING IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET UNDERSTANDING THE FUNDING
WILL BE NECESSARY TO ASSIST IN
HELPING DISTRICTS PAINT. ELVIA
BEATTIE INCREASE WE BELIEVE IS
NECESSARY TO ATTRACT ONLY A
FUNDING PRESSURES AND EDUCATOR
AND CLASS BY PROFESSIONAL THREE
SHORTAGE THIS WORK FORCE WILL BE
NECESSARY NOT ONLY TO IMPLEMENT
NEW PROPOSED PROGRAMS. TO ENSURE
LEARNING BFORE AND AFTER SCHOOL
BUT EXISTING LEARNING DURING THE
SCHOOL DAY RIGHT NOW WE LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER DISCUSSIONS
REGARDING ENROLLMENT BASED
FUNDING AND INVESTMENTS IN OUR
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE.
YOUR COMMENTS MODERATOR MEXICO.
NINE EIGHT YEAR LINE IS A PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JOHN LINGER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION- HAS BEEN DISCUSSED
UNLIKE SCHOOL DISTRICT'S PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE NOT HELD
HARMLESS. FOR THE UNPREDICTABLE
EIGHTY LAW THE CURRENT YEAR
CAUSING AN IMMEDIATE FISCAL
CRISIS FOR A LOT OF OUR SCHOOLS
ARE SCHOOLS WITH A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES THIS YEAR WITH NEW
VARIANTS ARE RISING AND COBIT
WHICH IS RESULTED IN INCREASED
IT NAPS THE- LAW MAYBE A
FUNDING. WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATIONS WE HAD WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE ON INCLUDING CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN THE EXISTING ONGOING
OLD ARE MOST PROTECTIONS FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICT. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE L. A. AS-
RECOMMENDATION FOR PROTECTING
CHARTER SCHOOL FOR DOCTOR CAN
CHARGE BOTH IN THE CURRENT YEAR
WHILE WE CONTINUE TO DISCUSS A
LONGER TERM SOLUTION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN THE BUDGET HAD
IT WOULD NEGOTIATED LAST YEAR WE
DID NOT EXPECT THE SURGES IN NEW
VARIANTS OF THE IMPACT IT WOULD
HAVE A CURRENT YEAR EDA
THEREFORE WE BELIEVE IT IS
CRITICAL LEGISLATURE IN
MINISTRATION ADOPTED TEMPORARY
ADJUSTMENT FOR CHARTER SCHOOL TO
PROTECT AGAINST. THAT YEAH
CURRENT YEAR EIGHTY A LOT WE
SUPPORT AT FIVE NINE BY SENATOR
. WHICH COPPER ADDRESSED THE LOS
ISSUE BOTH THE SHORT AND LONGER
. IT WOULD ENCOURAGE ME TO ABOUT
OUR IN THE TRAIL BILL. WE ALSO
ARE RIGHT ENVELOPE YOU DON'T
SIGNIFY- SIR OF ALLOWED YOU TO
GO SEE. OVER THE MINUTE OF SO IF
YOU MIND TO- PROVIDING AND- COME
. TO THE COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE
YOUR- THANK YOU. YOUR TESTIMONY
MODERATE NEXT. NINE TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I KÞT HARD ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
REGARDING INDEPENDENT STUDY BPA
ACT THAT CHANGES DO NOT ADD
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD ON ARE
ALREADY STRETCHED PETERS. J.
ALSO APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO HELP DISTRICTS AND
THAT ADJUSTER DECLINING
ENROLLMENT HOWEVER THAT DOES NOT
ADDRESS COULD BE RELATED
ABSENCES THAT WE BELIEVE WILL
DESTRUCTION NOT BE PENALIZED FOR
STUDENT BEING INFECTED RECOVERED
NINETEEN. AND FINALLY WE URGE
LEVINE TEN PRIORITIZE I'M GOING
FOR THE L. YEAH THAT THANK YOU
FOR YOU WE PER YOUR- MONTEREY
NEXT CALLER. NINE TWO THREE YOUR
LINE IS A PLEASE AHEAD. LAURIE
MY NAME IS JOHN BIG AND I THE
CAL TO FOR BILINGUAL YOU.
PROBABLY HIS COLLAB WE CAL
TOGETHER TO CREATE A BUDGET
PRIORITY CALIFORNIA STATE
COMPOUNDING SHORTAGE OF
BILINGUAL TO SERVE CALIFORNIA
DIVERSE POPULATION ADDITIONALLY
THE CREATION OF UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN HAS
CREATED A NEED TO INCREASE THE
STATE'S CAPACITY A BILINGUAL
TEACHERS IN ORDER TO DEVELOP.
ENGLISH AND HOME LANGUAGE
PROFICIENCY OF DOING LANGUAGE
LEARNERS AND PROGRAMS TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TO ADDRESS THE
SYSTEMATICALLY BOTH
ORGANIZATIONS ARE RECOMMENDING A
TEN MILLION DOLLAR APPROPRIATION
TO BRING BACK THE BIBLE TEACHER
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS. WE ALSO AFTER THE
CREATION OF THE NEW A TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR APPROPRIATIONS.
THE FUNDING TO THE TO P. ARE AT
THE CONTINUE THAT EDUCATE. AS
YOU WORK WORK INVESTMENT PROGRAM
IN WHICH LEARNERS WILL MAP
POLICY. GRANT PARK. THE DAILY
COULD INCREASE THE NEED FOR MORE
WILL ACT TO HIGH QUALITY ANSWER
COOKING LEARN. MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS INCLUDING SCHOOL ARE
NOT A OF THE ENGLISH WELL MAP.
PROPPING CALIFORNIA BELIEVE THE
TO BUDGET REQUIRED WILL BENEFIT
CALPERS ENGLISH LEARNER AND
WILLING THE AND TO MOVE THE
NEEDLE CORE. I PROVIDE VITAL
PROGRAM THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDER.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH FOR YOUR-
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NINE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE OF THE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS AND IS A VICTIM DISTANCING AT
THE NASH CENTER USE BY AND I'M
HERE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A
ONE TIME ON. OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION TO ABOUT SERVE HOME
STUDENTS BY ADOPTING THE
HOMELESS AGING ARE RESOURCES AND
FOR HER PROGRAM IT'S VITAL TO
AND COUNTY OF THE- TO THEIR- TO
COURT WITH LARGER. AN INCREASE
AMOUNT THE PART IN MY ROLE IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF WORK EVERY
DAY WITH YOUNG EXPERIENCING
HOMELESS. I THINK THE GAP IN
REGARD IS IT IT IS IMPERATIVE TO
SEE AN THIRSTY COLOR. OTHER OUT
OF SCHOOL IN THEIR TO BE PRESENT
LEARN AND GET THE- THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH YOUR
COMMENTS- NEXT CALL. ACCESS
RESOURCES AND TRAINING OR HEART
PROGRAM. IN ADDITION ALMOST
HOMELESS STUDENTS ARE MINOR
CHILDREN LIVING WITH THEIR
PARENTS NEARLY EIGHT THOUSAND
UNACCOMPANIED HOMELESS YOUTH AND
THE GRAVITY OF THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCES DEMANDS
ADDITIONAL. INVESTMENT WE
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
INCLUDE AN ONGOING FUNDING
AUGMENTATION AT SIXTEEN MILLION
TO MODIFY THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA. TO BETTER SERVE
UNACCOMPANIED HOMELESS STUDENT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NINE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS DOCTOR ARE
INNINGS OF SANTA ROSA KATAMON
SITUATED MENIFEE CALIFORNIA THIS
YEAR OUR SCHOOLS FACING
SIGNIFICANT LOSS IN FUNDING DUE
TO UNPLANNED STUDENT ABSENCES AS
A RESULT OF CODE RELATED
ISOLATION. THANK YOU MANDATE BUT
UNLIKE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THIS
YEAR CHARTER SCHOOLS RECEIVE NO
PROTECTION FOR IAN LOSSES DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC. AS A RESULT UNLESS
SUCH PROTECTION IS PROVIDED OUR
SCHOOL MAY HAVE TO PURSUE A
REDUCTION OF PRECIOUS WORK FORCE
AT A TIME WHEN NEW AND ONGOING
MANDATES NECESSITATE
INCREASINGLY MORE WORKLOAD TO BE
SUPPORTED BY EDUCATION.
WORKFORCE THAN EVER BEFORE IN
HISTORY. ADDUCTION WITH GREEN
STRESS OF STAFF PROVIDE SERVICE
TO INTERVENE. FOR STUDENTS A
TIME WHEN THE TASK OF RECOVERING
STUDENT LEARNING AND STUDENT
WELLNESS INTERVENTIONS ARE
DEPENDENT ON SERVICES SUPPORTED
BY EDUCATION STAFFING. RESHAPE
YOUR VOTES AND TO SUPPORT SENATE
BILL FIVE SEVENTY NINE WHICH
INSURES ALL SCHOOLS ARE
PROTECTED FROM THESE LOSSES.
WOULD SUPPORT ACTION IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT CONFORMS TO SB
FIVE SEVENTY NINE. WE HAVE SANTA
ROSA ACADEMY ALSO SUPPORT ADDING
CHARTER SCHOOLS TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO REVIVE
I'M GOING HOLD HARMLESS
PROTECTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR
MODERATOR BEFORE WE GO TO THE
NEXT ONE HOW MANY- CALLERS DO WE
HAVE IN LINE. WE HAVE TWELVE WOW
LET'S SEE HERE. THEN WE WILL
TAKE THE NEXT FIVE AND ASK
EVERYBODY ELSE TO- TO SUBMIT
COMMENTS IN WRITING SO LET'S
MOVE AHEAD WITH THE NEXT CALLER. ONE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CRIMINAL LIABILITY CHACHALACA
NEARLY SOMETHING THAT'S NEVER
MENTIONING OPEN ACCESS THE
TELEPHONE OPTIONS- NOT HEARING
WE APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT FOR
THIS IMPORTANT TO THE DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NINE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE CHURCH
IN CHILE IN OUR SCHOOL HAS
CONNECTIONS SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION ONE
TIME BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS FOR
THE HOMELESS EDUCATION ACCESS.
RESOURCES IN TRAINING OUR HEART
PROGRAM I WORK WITH YOU ANYTHING
HOMELESSNESS ALICE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND
THE COUNTRY AND NOW MORE THAN
EVER ONLY IF YOU DIDN'T NEED
SUPPORT. NOT GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL IN THE GREATEST RISK
FACTOR FOR YOUNG ADULT
HOMELESSNESS TO LOOSELY
WANDERING HOMELESSNESS WE MUST
PROMOE EDUCATION AND THE ARTS
PROGRAM WOULD BE JEFF BACK TO
TARGETED OUTREACH SERVICESAND
MAKING SURE THAT LEAVES ONE
PERSON AT EVERY SCHOOL
UNDERSTAND STATE AND FEDERAL
LAWS I COULDN'T HOMELESSNESS AND
RELATED EDUCATION STRATEGIES.
THANK. YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK. THANK YOU FOR MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR COM. MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. NINE THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING MY NAME IS KATE
PATTERSON AND I'M WITH SENATE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS WE SERVE FORTY
FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS AND SEVEN
CHARTER SCHOOLS AROUND THE BAY
AREA THIS YEAR'S OUR STUDENTS
HAVE SHOWN INCREDIBLE RESILIENCE
AND OUR DEDICATED TEACHERS AND
STAFF FOR GOING ABOVE AND BEYOND
TO MANAGING EVER HANGING COBIT
PROTOCOL TO KEEP OUR COMMUNITY
SAFE. WE FACE A SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING LAW WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO ENSURE
STUDENT CAN REMAIN IN SCHOOL BUT
THE REALITY THE PANDEMIC NEEDS
TO INCREASE UNPREDICTABLE
ABSENCES AND I'M LIKE DISTRICTS
WE HAVE NO PROTECTION FOR THE
RELATED EIGHTY A LOT AND- IN
ARMONK UNDER RESOURCE
COMMUNITIES WHERE FAMILIES HAVE
BEEN HIT HARDEST BY THE PANDEMIC
JUST ONE DAY OF COMBAT RELATED
ABSENCES. AFTER SCHOOL NEARLY
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IF NOT
REMEDIED THIS TYPE OF FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP WILL ULTIMATELY RESULT
IN CUTS TO CRITICAL STUDENT
SUPPORT THAT ARESO. DESPERATELY
NEEDED. YOU'RE ABOUT TO SLIP
SENATOR FIVE NINE TO ENSURE
SCHOOLS PROTECT FROM THE THAT.
AND WITH THE CRACKS OF THIS.
TAKEN THAT FIVE SEVENTY NINE. WE
ALSO SUPPORT CHARTER SCHOOLS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO REVISE ON
GO COLD. BUT FOR. THANK SO MUCH
LAUGHTER. TO SPEAK TODAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR- OF MY-
NEXT CALL. NINE TWO SEVEN YOUR
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU BOB WHAT IRVINE UNIFIED'S
DISTRICT SPEAKING THE SUBMIT
SHORE COULD BE UP LEARNING
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM A FEW SMALL
CHANGES PLACE YOU ON TO DO. MAKE
THE NEXT YEAR OTHER PRAC ROUND
NOTHING DOWN THE RIGHT STUFF
THIS OF THE O'CLOCK FOR PURPOSES
BUT THERE'S CHANGE DON'T UP THEY
DO HIGHLIGHT. IT REMAINS A- BILL
. WONDER THANK FORTUNATELY I
WORKABLE NOW AREN'T. BY THE
MODEL REMAINS ARBITER AND
EQUITABLE AND WORST OF ALL
CERTAIN REPLETE WITH UNDER
CONSEQUENCES. THE PROGRAM
BECAUSE STILL DON'T BECAUSE
THREE OF WHAT DISTRICTS FACING
YOUR CARDS THAT. RACIAL BANTER.
WE RESPECT REQUEST THAT YOUR
SUBCOMMITTEE GET THIS THE
ATTENTION OF PROVIDING REGULAR
PUBLIC IN THIS AND DEBATE ANY
MOLD DOLLAR AND DESERVES BUT IN
THIS CASE HAS NOT RECEIVED. LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR CALLING
AND HOPE YOU WERE TO THE ROBO
DISCUSS THAT EARLIER THIS VERY.
ON THAT CHECK MODERATOR MOVE TO
OUR LAST CALL. THANK MISTER OF
COME COMES FROM MY TO SIX. ALIGN
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS DR DAVIES TO
CEO CARL OF FREEDOM OF THE COURT
CALIFORNIA I'M SPEAKING TO YOU
TODAY WITH THE TREMENDOUS
RESPONSE. FOR THE HOPES AND
DREAMS OF ELEVEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN NINETEEN GREEN
OPTICAL THE WALK ANGELES. THIS
YEAR OUR SCHOOLS ARE FACING A
FOURTEEN DOLLAR LOSS IN FUNDING
IF YOU'RE RUNNING ON DIDN'T TO
RESULTS COMPANY. BUT I SCHOOL
CHARTER SCHOOLS YOU NO FOR A
GALA. THE CAN DOWN HOUSES BY
TOWARDS PUBLIC FOR BECAUSE THE
LAST. BUILDING HOW RESERVE THAT
SHOULD THAT COULD BE HARMFUL
DURING. FINANCIAL IT'S A LONG TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS ARE
THE CONDOM. COVERSIN SCHOOL JUST
LIKE IN THE TEN PERSONAL FOR
ACROSS THE STATE HAVE. PACKARD
IMAGE HEALTH NEEDS OF THE PAST
TWO YEAR. THIS CALL FOR. ONGOING
IN ALL. WILL BE YOUR VOTE
SUPPORT FIVE NINE AND REFERENCE
TO ENSURE CARS ARE FUNDED
EQUITABLY THIS. BECAUSE ALL OF
CALIFORNIA CONSIDER THE SUPPORT
BEING TO THRIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU ARE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
. AND WHAT ME THANK EVERYONE UP
TO. IN THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY AND IF YOU WERE ONE THAT
WAS NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY OR YOU
WISH TO ADD TO YOUR COMMENTS. OF
YOU WE WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEWS OF. A SUB COMMITTEE ONE.
OR A WEBSITE AND THE DIRECT
EMAIL IS S. B. U. D. S. B. U. D.
DOT COMMITTEE. AT SENATE DOT CA
DOT GOV S. B. U. D. DOT
COMMITTEE AT SENATE DOT CA DOT
GOV- FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS WERE IMPORTANT TO US
WE WANT TO INCLUDE THE FULL
TESTIMONY IN OUR CONSIDERATION
DECISIONS. ARE WERE NOT MADE
TODAY AND THEY WILL BE MADE IN
THE SPRING SO THERE'S PLENTY OF
TIME TO GET YOUR COMMENTS AND.
TAKE THEM WE REALLY APPRECIATE
TO YOU- PARTICIPATION. I WANT TO
EVERYONE FOR THEIR- IN CORE. IN
TODAY HEARING. WE'VE AND
CONCLUDED AGENDA OF THIS BUT
OFFICE REVIEW SOME CA ONE STAND
ADJOURNED.